[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
oh here is there
Michael is it a manager
[Music]
foreign
yeah I'm feeling good I had a quick
question though about the show
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
what is a chess Dynasty
unceasing dominance move after move
again and again and again we have a
reservation we have history he is the
five-time fide World chess champion
but a chess Dynasty can also be cruel it
forces most to defer their dreams until
next time if there is a next time oh my
God he just blocked yeah he did I'm
Blown Away the game is over
as the Chess World Turns to Kazakhstan
the Magnus Carlson Dynasty is set to
close
the feed a world championship is finally
up for grabs
for two chess Superstars lying in weight
until next time is now
Jan napam Nashi has methodically done
what he needed to do to get another shot
at the title the pressure to seize the
moment this time rests heavily upon Him
thing freezes and Jan bounces on the
opportunity with Precision taking the
lead once again in the world
championship match
dingley Ren knows firsthand what the end
of this dynasty means an unexpected
chance to make history
can China's best turn his Good Fortune
into Eternal Fame he's under arrest
thinking
this is like what a collapse looks like
the legacy of this Championship spans
across centuries it reads from the names
of Chess Giants
for the first time in a decade a new
name will raise the trophy and be etched
into chess history
it's the 2023 b-day World Championship
whose name will next be called champion
[Music]
it's all eyes on Astana as the city
hosts an intense battle to Crown the
king of classical chess we'll be taking
you straight to where the action happens
the players Arena two incredible
Fighters
and daingler and are playing the match
of their lives a 14-game match to win
Ultimate glory to be world champion and
it is time for game 8. I'm super excited
to be your host for the day I'm
International Master Tanya sachdev and
alongside me for all the Deep diving
into the action we've got the one and
only the inimitable Robert Hess and
world number six Super Grand Master
Anish Guri welcome guys it's been a
tournament it's been a match where the
players have been fighting each other
but also their own minds game seven was
a total roller coaster Anish how are you
feeling going into the second half
well so far it's truly been a blessing
to commentate this match and I can't
wait for another game
it's it's really been uh lots of ups and
downs the most unexpected Captain
happening and well I don't know what to
expect anymore at this point
so good to have you here with us and the
last we met
at the Champions Chester and we had so
many discussions about the world
championship match how excited we were
but this one Robert has surpassed all
expectations
I think from a Fan's perspective
everyone is thrilled except for dingley
Ren yonda Palm she probably all smiles
but it's a second half a new beginning
hopefully if you're a dingley red fan
yes and there is a lot to look forward
to currently dingler and is trailing the
match by a point let's take a look at
our road to game eight it's been a match
full of decisive Games Starting very
early on in game two with janapamnushi
drawing first blood with black pieces he
wins a game Thing lyrics and Strikes
Back In game four and we've seen four
decisive games back to back with white
winning four times in this match Anish
have we seen a match with so many
decisive games in the first half
well we certainly have to go back in
history uh and the game seven that was a
special one I think surprised Ian as
early as move on with the French defense
got an interesting position was under
pressure for the most part of the game I
played it really really well
until that uh deciding decisive moment
where suddenly
for no reason whatsoever dink froze and
the club kept ticking down just didn't
make a move only to resign in the end in
a hopeless position
I don't think anyone could have
predicted an end like that in thing
navigated through all the problems came
up with a precise response seized the
initiative and then Robert we saw the
complete meltdown a complete collapse
have you seen anything like that at such
a big stage
it was shocking as a spectator but I
guess that's what happens on the world
championship stage nerves get to you the
momentous occasion that is this chess
match it's really hard to I think bear
witness to that so I feel like for
dingley rent he needs to have that new
beginning I talked about I just was
really sad to see that happen
it really was we were all shocked we
were all left speechless and we've got
our very own Mike Klein in Astana and he
brings to us the mood after the shocking
happenings of game seven and the
player's reactions
thanks guys and yet another win in this
most dramatic of world championships the
difference between the winners chair and
the losers chair was just one errant
move in time pressure as ding Lorenz
said he just didn't think he could sit
on the position and he decided to take
active measures despite the fact that
his clock was ticking perilously close
to zero after the game he recognized
that he went from a win to a loss and he
could barely stop his voice from
cracking here's what ding Loren had to
say
I prepared the Lord's
for the screen
yeah
the opening phrase was yeah on
yeah the opening was was the one which I
played in my childhood and as for the
winner John napomnushi he didn't just
navigate the vicissitudes of a complex
attack better he handled his clock
better I got a chance to ask John what
he thought of the time control going
into the match and here is what he had
to say maybe I play slightly more games
with this time control recently uh but I
don't think it it makes some difference
and so the question remains what on
Earth will Dean Lauren do now against
one E4 but before he has to answer that
question he gets white in game eight he
will now get white after every rest day
as the match enters the second half
could he possibly get back to equal for
the third time after being down to point
and produce the fifth straight decisive
game in the match it's going to be
really exciting to see this continue
into the second half fortress.com this
is Mike Klein inside the playing Hall in
Astana Kazakhstan
thank you so much for that Mike the big
question is counting again equalize the
match for the third time he's done it
twice can he strike back and do it again
it is the second half the players need
to step back and reevaluate their
strategy this is what our team at a
chesscom stats gave us for Jan's odd
based on the result of today's match if
Yan was to win this game 8 he takes a
two point lead which makes him a 97.7
favorite to win the World Championship
match but this is what surprises me that
in case this ends in a draw the Star
Team gives Yan an 86.7 favorite odds
Anish to me with the way the match has
been going the amount of blows that have
been traded the decisiveness of the
games to me this seems like an
overestimation
yeah it's always really hard to
understand I would also feel definitely
that this is an overestimation even even
the win I mean 98 out of 100 really is
that much you know things can turn
around quickly one win will bring ding
back and the momentum might change Jan
can also start getting really nervous as
the title you know just starts to be
right in front of him uh for grabs and
um with the draw as well 86 that's eight
to nine games out of ten
eight to nine matches out of ten that is
really a lot of matches I think the draw
wouldn't be too bad for ding a draw in
this game especially a next one I think
with the black pieces it holds that one
as well there will be two draws after a
very painful loss and then a chance
still a little bit of distance left to
strike back chance with the white pieces
I think a draw today wouldn't be such a
disaster
but you know the Numbers Never Lie let's
see the numbers certainly don't
statistics don't have feelings don't
have emotions but the players do so if
dingley red for example were to strike
back today I don't even think he's the
underdog anymore I know it's based on
pre-match ratings but if ding can win in
round eight after rest day we might see
a new player entirely so I just think
that uh the odds they make sense to me
but anything could happen in a match
like this
anything can happen and that's exactly
what we've been seeing in this match so
far now Ganda Pam Nashi in the world
championship in the first seven games
hasn't had a draw with the black pieces
we've seen a ding with two wins with
white and they've all been very
convincing so this is really his chance
going into game eight starting with
white and once again the big drama has
been all around the five decisive games
that we've seen in the first half Anish
are you expecting an equally bloody
second half
well always expect the unexpected of
course but uh I think at some point at
some point the blood the violence has to
end and um
well iron you know if we keep on going
at that place I would really be
completely insane I think sooner or
later you know chess is uh is a drawish
game at a high level I mean draws have
to appear if you if you both play well
at some point but so far it wasn't the
case I think maybe today one of the
coming days it's gonna be a draw uh you
know nothing wrong with that a little
bit of draws you know they're healthy uh
you know draw a day keeps the doctor
away as they say so I I think nothing
wrong with that but we will see I mean
so far really all the predictions have
always been wrong and uh we couldn't
guess a single single result so far
yeah oddly in this match the unexpected
is a draw we've only seen two of them
that's what we typically see at the
highest level but I don't know what to
expect Tanya but I do expect ding to be
well prepared to give us another new
opening in this round eight yeah and
that's been such a big narrative in this
world championship just a kind of
opening approach that we've been seeing
from players now traditionally you often
see these small variations these small
Novelties we see an opening being
repeated multiple times but here we've
been treated to new opening ideas and
surprises in every game no two game has
been alike and there we see yeah
napomnishi there looking confident
Looking ready for his match England
facing up and down while ding has been
absolutely fantastic in navigating
complications and finding the Right
Moves his time management has been a big
issue so far and also his confidence
Robert do you see that as a pattern that
Ding is currently struggling with
confidence
well Tanya you spoke to him in an
interview before the world championship
took place before he even flew to
Kazakhstan and he said that it's
emotional for him I mean this journey
has been a lot he wasn't even expected
to be in the candidates let alone in a
world championship match so I do think
that it's been getting to him the nerves
his time management has not been good at
all and I think that he's been kicking
himself based on game seven it's hard
not to look back at that game and be
like what was I doing I had a good
position and I didn't even realize it at
just how good it was so I do think that
Ding fantastic player super precise but
he has been shaky in this match
for him to turn into it because Robert
take a look
uh welcome Michael Anish has he started
playing a little bit of chess
well I think he will start today as uh
you know what an experience for for
young glad here to follow a world
championship from up from this up close
with all the commentators present and a
live feed on the board what I would what
I actually want to mention as well
besides that
my son is quite excited for today's
start I think Jan is also quite excited
normally Yan in the resting area he's a
lot more nervous but today he appears
particularly confident and I really
think well that's quite something
perhaps the last game could turn things
around and he could start playing very
confident chess with the black pieces as
well today
hmm yeah oh yeah I'm still I'm still
looking at Michael there he's definitely
ready what a way to start Robert you
start your chess career watching the
world championship match an epic game it
couldn't be better uh and we see Jan on
the screen there as you mentioned in
Niche looking very relaxed today he's in
his usual typical chill mode right now
but of course the pressure is on for
ding Jan to take a two-point victory in
this one would be too much a draw would
not be an absolute disaster for dink but
he does have the white pieces he's got
to try to maximize those chances and
Robert are you expecting yet another
opening surprise from ding today well I
see the flowers match Yana pomni's shirt
but I don't think anyone should be
handing yarn flowers just yet he does
not know what's going to happen on the
game's opening stage we saw in game
seven dingly Wren threw back to his
childhood he said the French defense was
a weapon he used in his early days when
he was as young as Michael anisha's son
right here and so for uh dingley Ren he
is going to come back at it with another
new opening variation maybe courtesy
of Richard report well this is too cute
how am I supposed to focus on the chest
when we have Michael on screen
no that was not the plan that he was
supposed to you know be watching baby
cartoon baby sharks or baby cartoon
but the baby shark uh yeah very
infectious
um song but he doesn't want to share it
with the entire world it seems so um
that's that's possible that's fine but
uh the players uh are not not at seats
just yet five minutes to go
pragmatic in his approach in this world
championship you know he plays fast and
he keeps his confidence going he even if
in the opening phase he doesn't go for
the most critical line sometimes just
especially when he's taken by surprise
he waits for the moment when ding is on
the time pressure he waits to have that
clock advantage to really make the
position chaotic to try to force ding
into a think tank that's been his
strategy this is the time that the
players step back re-evaluate going into
the second half while that is Yan
strategy what does ding need to adjust
uh to make things go his way Anish what
does he need to switch up right now
well I think his chess has always been
pretty good I I guess it's the the
mental state that's impacting him very
much when clearly in the last game at
some point the pressure really got to
him and I guess it was really difficult
to recover emotionally after such an
also you know recovering from a win is
an issue as well as we've seen so far
with the players nobody was able to
recover from a win after win they played
a poor game the next day and lost so so
many ups and downs for doing so many
emotions uh I hope he has them under
control today and if he gets a chance to
strike back
the emotions under control I think the
good things could happen for the Chinese
number one
yeah doing needs to fight Jan he needs
to fight his own mind today I think
confidence will play a huge a huge role
in Game eight as well as time management
we've seen thing they're fantastic moves
but then just crumble in those time
pressure moments and now he's had two
wins one when he started with the
English 1c4 the other when he played the
London the only time that we've seen
London in the world championship match
Robert are you expecting a repeat of one
of these two or a first move Surprise by
ding
I don't think it'll be a first move
surprise necessarily but I do think that
he is going to choose an adventurous
opening we saw him play an H3 move early
in the second game of match that
backfired uh but I do think dingley Wren
armed with the preparation along with
his second Richard report I mean that is
the type of player Richard report is
that's why he was hired and we are going
to see a new opening today and Jan he's
sitting there like what am I in store
for
we see the usual a play of body language
that both players have sat down jackets
have come off handshakes they're ready
to start those a few seconds right
before the first move super tense but
once they get into the flow of the games
everything else uh Fades away the big
question what is going to be move one
for dingler and will he stick to the
London which I would be pretty surprised
despite him having a convincing Victory
out of it Anish uh will it be shocking
to see another London yeah I think the
whole point of an opening like London is
that it comes somewhat of surprise and
you're hoping for a long strategic game
where an opponent isn't really expecting
the the type of game so I think
essentially we'll see something similar
in spirit maybe uh you know there's the
opening called the jobava London there's
all kinds of other Sidelines expect the
sideline with the white one appearing on
D4 at some point or something within one
C4 complex so no E4 for today maybe one
B3 is a little little risky maybe 2v3 at
least but uh an opening a similar in
spirit to London but something slightly
different because the whole point is
that you gotta bring that surprise value
if you play to London without the series
without the shock value it really loses
a lot of a lot of the
um appeal and other
um yeah no no London today and also not
the same English and not the same H3
something uh similar but something
different
two very different opening approaches in
World Championship matches we've seen
players stick to their opening and then
find a slight variation down the road
but this one has been full of surprises
from the very start and we see there the
first moves well ding smiling he's the
one who's advising what to play and wow
he did advise one E4 as the opening move
do you think we might be seeing thing up
for the King's Pawn opening for the
first time in this match Robert well
sometimes the players just like to have
a little bit of fun for the ceremonial
first move however we could see it
remember Richard report has played it
against Yonder promisee in the
candidates and that game did not go
Richard's way it was in a Petra of
Defense but dingley Wren he's proven
that he is willing to be adventurous in
the match so why not the kingspawn
it makes a lot of sense actually uh it
was you know actual surprise at this
point and I think it it could could be a
good decision but no no no surprises 1
D4 so far the close structures have
worked out really well for Ding and it
would be a little bit illogical to go
for the uh one E4 the opening that Jan
himself uses very successfully in this
match so far
and Anish 1d4 you said no opening
surprises and move on but I think the
important word there is yet I'm
definitely expecting something that
hasn't happened before well no London as
we were saying 2c4 has been played and
wow uh Robert it still sticks to what we
saw in game game four
yeah because when ding hasn't forced
things the result has gone his way in
game two when he lost to the white
pieces he played his offbeat variation
uh when he has taken a bit of risk it
Yonder Palm she has pounced and not
given him an opportunity to get back in
the game so I think this is a good start
to the game won't be surprised to see
them with Queen C2 one of the main lines
but Anish you have experience against
both of these players I'm curious how do
you see ding continuing this game I
think he'll play three uh
and he did he did well um yeah nowadays
there are so many so many different uh
options in the name so Indian defense
white players have started digging deep
the queens of two move you mentioned the
main line has has been the main line for
a long time there are also the sharp
lines the zamish variations where you
try to build a strong center with F3 or
a force black to give up the bishoper
with A3 doubling your own pawns E3 is
something in between it's known as the
sort of this slow middle game kind of
approach uh usually the lines are not so
forced not so forcing but you go for
that long strategic fight something that
suits Ding and we could still see a sort
of a Carlsbad Pawn structure and I think
um if if you are doing at this point
having had such good results with the
cards but one structure in the match so
far you could try to steer the game in
that direction
so at some point when the pawn will
appear on D5 perhaps it will make sense
to take it with cded getting that
structure that suits ding so uh so much
and so far Jan has been really drifting
there so we'll see
and this is a big moment now for white
to decide what they want to do in this
opening because very often Robert you
have to pick your knight to either go to
F3 or to E2 first ding decides to ask
questions to the black Bishop it is also
retreated but the Yan decides to
actually capture on C3 immediately so we
see moves being blitzed out now the pawn
structure looks really bad for white
already in the center but the good thing
is that you moved a Side Pawn towards
the center of the board what are the
Dynamics here and how does this actually
also help white going into the middle
game Robert well it definitely gives
dingley Wren chances to play for a win
because white has the bishop pair now
it's not the most impressive Bishop pair
at first glance because there's a bishop
sitting on C1 but I knew this move was
coming Knight to E2 and white is kind of
throwing the curveball at you on the
palm tree he's sitting here like what is
going on I was going to say a more
natural Square was Knight F3 with the
bishop going out on this first diagonal
but he first brings the Knight out so
Anish I was just expecting the
unexpected you told me to do so this
move Knight E2 it already looks quite
rare
well guys so
today is quite unfortunate that you are
not yet joined by Fabiano caruana
because this variation of e3 followed by
A3 that is fabianos pretty much
invention as far as as I remember he's
played a lot of Blitz Games with this
system and it's a really fascinating
system so ding has abandoned the plans
of going for the Carlsbad construction
and he goes for this damage constructure
which is really really fascinating I've
had a lot of games with it myself
recently and the nuances are very very
sophisticated and there's a lot to
uncover here of course on the surface
you can see the pawns are doubled on the
C file white has the bishop pair and a
strong Pawn Center
but the reason that Jinx started with
the move E3 and the point behind Fabius
invention is that uh White waits for
castling first and only then goes A3
here because if you start with A3 in
that in those other damage positions
very often black can delay cast link uh
King side and sometimes can even Castle
Queen side where the king sometimes can
be safer so a very subtle play by ding
problem with the move E3 is that
eventually white wants to push the pawn
to E4
and so uh the movie 3 will will be a
loss of time and uh the the details
after a D6
and the reason he goes for 92 it's it's
all about trying to get E4 in the right
uh version you could of course try to go
Bishop D3 which is the most logical way
to do it the problem with Bishop to D3
after D6 here is that black will play E5
and if you play uh E4
you have to deal with some direct issues
uh like EDC deep 94 Bishop E4 or K8
let's say or
um
yeah yes and you lose the the pawn
basically after the whole operation so
you you have to try to somehow uh push
the pawn to E4
without allowing any tricks like that
you could also start with the move F3
here of course but perhaps then you
commit too much maybe Knight H5 then
becomes a good option intending Queen H4
check and if uh it defends from that and
maybe F5 will be a good move stopping
this movie for this is uh I think this
is more or less how the game between uh
Carlson proceeded in a speeches
Championship perhaps those who follow
that event will remember but ding plays
92 uh trying to keep these options open
and maybe 93 maybe still F3
and yang seems to be quite confused and
there's a lot to think about here you
could go for E5 you could go for C5 if
you go for neither
yeah it's a tough choice initially I see
that look on your face you're like this
looks like a fascinating uh opening and
I'm with you because it's caught yawn
off guard I think that's an opening win
for dingley Ren and I don't think this
is beyond faking it I really think he is
digging deep trying to come up with a
plan this is not a position you just
throw a couple moves out and hope they
work because if you play the move E5
that's very different than playing for
C5 typically with these double pawns you
want to play against them so C5 may
follow up with Knight C6 but it's hard
to actually see a way for black to get
there in time especially with the white
knight coming out and you're expanding
the pawn structure but he does choose
the move C5 and I mean I think that
we're in for a fight
that is uh for sure that is a guarantee
with this kind of Pawn structure you are
in fortified Robert and Tanya do you
have any experience I think I recall you
being a I recall you playing zemish uh a
lot weren't you
yes I'm flattered Anish that you recall
any of my games but I do play the uh
samish I do play the nimso as well from
the white side but also from the black
side so I I played these positions you
have to strike in the center with either
E5 or C5 and I feel Knight T2 was that
slight surprise that thing got in it's
not it's not a move that's often played
you either bring the Knight out to F3 or
develop that Bishop to D3 before
bringing the Knight out so this is
something that did take Yan by surprise
and very Indian style he goes for a
direct idea he doesn't waste time to try
and bring out that Bishop on C8 with a
move like P6 it first tries in the
center but the move that he chose was C5
now very often instead of C5 we see
black go E5 rookie 8 try to pile on the
pressure on the king's side uh ding
making well at least the most natural
move in the position opening up the
diagonal for the bishop to develop next
and after that thing we see Yan blitzing
out the moves filing on the pressure in
the center very often one of the plans
as white I feel a bit terrified about in
this position is when black starts
threatening that C4 Pawn B6 Bishop A6
Knight A5 and putting pressure on that
pawn some point in the middle game is
that something that they need to watch
out for
swing across the second rank before
developing any of the Bishops so so
aesthetically pleasing
you know I love it Anish it's actually
not a novelty I just did an opening
check it has been played before but I
don't think that this was in Jan's
morning preparation when someone makes a
move like Rook A2 against you you're
like uh that's pretty much a new
territory for Yan and I love it I mean
what are really the ideas well
eventually white does like to expand in
the center and maybe you can expand
directly this Rook on the second rank we
may see it swing over the king side at
some point
yeah I think I've seen this before
um somewhere and uh the kind of
variations that come to mind right now
so I indeed this plant Anya mentioned
this basic Bishop 695 that's a huge huge
theme
and of course you are trying to pile up
on the weak C4 pawn and in the meantime
what will happen is that I'm going to
try to create something on the king side
now with my knight already on G3 the
ideas of G4 are out of the window so I
think likely scenario is let's say B6
E4
and B4 must be the The Way Forward
Bishop A6
I think Bishop to G5 perhaps what you
sometimes see is the black plays H6
white can play H4
I'm okay maybe I'm giving away too much
but I think I've seen this at some point
we're looking at this kind of stuff with
my team uh uh trying to give Checkmate
this way
so this this certainly rings a bell uh
the other a completely different
approach which is a lot safer than B6 uh
safer in the short term and that is the
plan of E5
so if I have you put more pressure on
the center now E4 would lose a pawn
you do have a possibility of going D5
instead I guess that's what you do uh
though isn't the time isn't it what the
damage players do
yes but Daniel was kind of happy with
this D5 right you fixed the center and
now you've got this idea of going for
the C
transpose the king the Knight to the
king side which is another approach in
the position and try to get the F5 break
in so I think D5 would be something that
black shouldn't be too worried about
right like that's perfectly situated in
the event that the Knight goes to A5 now
with the center close white can just
switch full Focus over to the king side
pushing pawns forward and this Rook will
slide on over and help in the attack
yes I I do Wonder though uh just uh my
understanding and I think I understand
now the point so why okay two over
Bishop D3 why why or over E4 that's the
main question of course why is that a
priority and I think you probably want
to remain flexible I guess because if
you start with E4 instead of Rook A2
uh what what would be the exact issue
here is that a central low certain
Central move in the center is at a D5 or
an E5 or
or what exactly is the
problem
can you take on D4 first maybe and after
poly64 then throw in the movie five is
this uh a way to just play in the center
you always have a queen A5 check that
you have to look for as well yes and
another thing is that let's say even if
I play B6 after E4
uh still I cannot play Bishop D3 because
the D4 is D4 Pawn is hanging so uh Rook
A2 in that sense is a very useful
waiting move I'm waiting for that Knight
to uh to go to A5 first and that planet
mentioned with e597 where you where you
go for uh where you go for a close
position let's let's look at it here in
5597 the only flow with that plan is
that now my C4 Pawn is completely safe
and so
you you will be safer with black on the
king side
but the uh disadvantage of this is that
you you forget your Ambitions on the
queen side and why it's double pawns no
longer no longer um yeah they remain
sort of nominally weak but they will
never be captured anymore C4 Pawn is
extremely safe here and so young goes
for the more ambitious plan the one with
B6 I think that's that's the main line
and I think we'll see the E4 Bishop G5
idea I don't see what else uh White can
do here
outside where Yan will try to take
control of the queen side hit on things
weakness on the C4 Pawn I love the
pressure on that while doing meanwhile
has to be fast enough to create pressure
on the center as well as the king side
is that the kind of dynamic that we'll
see in this one Robert yeah I think this
is a game where the players they know
three results are on the table
oftentimes in these high level games
you're like okay a draw seems like the
likely outcome we're gonna play a pretty
pretty solid game white will have a
slight Advantage maybe we'll play
precisely and win or black just defense
but I just think the players are
swinging they're holding nothing back at
this point and we see from John's move
B6 he is playing principal chess it's
not about the match score he's not just
trying to say okay I'm leading let me
hope to make a draw B solid he's playing
principle let's go after this pawn and
C4 it's what we keep talking about but
let's see how quickly ding plays at this
point and okay as soon as I say it he
makes his move when he returns to the
board E4 confidently adjusting the
pieces putting them on the squares but a
niche this is your idea with Bishop G5
will it amount to anything or is like
just going to say you can put your
Bishop there and I'm not fearful of that
PIN
yeah
well Bishop G5 certainly the idea and
then h6h40 this is the stuff I mentioned
earlier one point I wanted to to bring
up as well is that I think at this point
uh Jan he he who perhaps would want to
play it if he would want to make a draw
but the you know when you play
um at this level you have to play
according to the demands of position and
in this kind of position you kind of
play for a draw with black uh you cannot
defend you have to go for the counter
attack and one uh doubt one other doubt
I have obviously ding is in book I do
Wonder perhaps Jan is also prepared as
you see him looking up this is a sign of
people pretending that they are prepared
and even I have seen this line before
I'm afraid that Jan might also have seen
it and you know it could could be uh one
of these games where the fireworks
um you know are spectacular on the
surface but in fact maybe both players
are very deeply prepared in this what is
an extremely obscure sideline
yeah you know I was just keeping an eye
out on the database to see how often
this has been played and actually Knight
E2 itself is a rare move but it's been
played about 16 times according to my
database but the move Rook A2 there's
just one game in this position that I
could find it was ileana's Nick with the
black pieces who uh was countering it
and actually white eventually sacrificed
that C4 pawn and was able to break
through on the king side so again the
same kind of similar plans that we will
be seeing uh happen here and this move
Rook at you that looks so innocuous at
the start in the middle game very often
we suddenly see this Rook join the
attack on the king side there's a huge
slide that comes in with the Rook coming
on to the f file so those are ideas that
Ding has got in mind I really like his
opening approach here looking for that
win with the white pieces I think we are
guaranteed a fight in this one Anish
yeah I'm not sure Tanya not sure not
sure if we are guaranteed the fight um
I'm so sorry uh
the whole thing it looks really obscure
but the uh modern computers they point
this out as a possibility I think Rook
A2 might be one of the top choices of
the of the computer and it is an obscure
it would surprise anybody but Jan
preparing for the world championship
match
and playing so quickly so far I am
afraid I am really hoping not to jinx it
but I am afraid that they might both be
in in book not only Ding and if this
doesn't come as a surprise to Yan
perhaps he knows the entire sequence and
how to neutralize it and so what you
often have is you get fireworks and if
player is out of book then at some point
he will go wrong because it's crazy
crazy stuff you cannot play it perfectly
but if the player is prepared he could
know exactly how to make sure this
fireworks fizzle out and what you might
see is a certain weird long sequence it
will lead to an equal end game for
example this is the the stuff of the
kind of things that can happen in modern
chess and especially uh what happens a
lot is okay you try to guess try to
surprise your opponent but the players
are so well prepared that sometimes
you can guess it wrong and I am really
afraid the judging from the body
language from the time on the clock and
from what I'm seeing I'm afraid that Jan
is in book and he remembers what he's
supposed to do but we will see perhaps
and hopefully I will be wrong but so far
the players are following my um my
prediction Bishop G5 h6h4 is probably
going to happen as well so
well so far you've been absolutely right
and on point with all the mood
predictions that you're making the
bishop has been developed in G5 so now
again the ball is in ding's court and he
has to be careful with judicious about
his time management we know right now it
looks like a lot of time on the clock
but we've seen those minutes disappear
and here's a reminder of our format for
the world championship it's two hours
the players get two hours 120 Minutes to
the first 40 moves when they make that
time control when they reach 40 moves
they get an additional 60 minutes for
the next 20 moves and it's only off to
move 60 that with an additional 15
minutes they get a 30 second increment
every time they press the clock but
there's no increment until move 60 and
well at least for the first time that I
can remember we've seen that play out
we've seen what happens when when you're
down two minutes in those critical
moments with no increment that is
something that thing needs to avoid
right now yando and Yan things playing
super fast in an opening that maybe we
would expect it to be a surprise eight
six Anish you are shaking your head a
little bit what do you do you what do
you not like about this move
oh I'm uh you know as a spectator as a
commentator I would of course wish for
Jan not to remember his prep here
because that would mean we'll have a
more exciting game but I think yeah I'm
playing so quickly
I'm fearful for for The Spectators that
uh
yeah the you know what we have always
been fearing and what we've been always
uh uh what's up all the haters have
always been preaching you know that
there's so much theory in chess I think
after someone decides those games today
might just be that one where we see the
uh the ugly side of the modern chess
when both players are prepared extremely
deeply even in an obscure sideline and
uh well you would wish you know if you
throw this position uh to two unknown
great players
um to non-players who are unfamiliar
with the positions what I'm trying to
say if they will start improvising here
Yan ending or we would see a crazy
exciting game but when they're both
following the engine lines
not sure how exciting that's going to be
but uh we will see maybe this is a very
complex line maybe Jing has a surprise
down the road as well uh something to to
take Yan out of book finally but young
playing so quickly it makes me a little
bit worried perhaps she has anticipated
this very uh unexpected opening
well Denise I have a question for you
because everything you just said makes
sense John is responding instantly but
at what point because ding might have
looked at this this morning and Jan
might have looked at this three months
ago at what point do you start thinking
okay he's remembered the first 11 12
moves but after age four right you know
he might not move instantly so do you
think the next move or the next couple
moves when do you start sensing that Jan
he remembers the framework but not every
single exact continuation
well you never know uh the thing is
though this looks like a very very crazy
variation and so when you're preparing
for an event as important as this one of
course you know that okay there are
variations that you absolutely must
remember uh because uh you know your
king safety is at stake here you might
be checkmated if you mix something up so
in a variation like that if you looked
at it three months ago you better have
repeated it three weeks ago hopefully
and and hopefully three days ago well
three hours ago would be too much
because you have too much to repeat
before the game but three days ago it
would be nice three weeks ago would
still be um decent but yes if he looked
at it three months ago and I'm fearful
for fayan and indeed maybe maybe he only
remembers the initial of your moves but
uh given the importance of this event
and the fact that Ayan has become so
professional uh lately trying to become
a world champion I I do expect him to
remember the details as well because
this is an important uh very important
Junction and you cannot just prepare
pair H6 and then go a g and after 8G
okay let's think let's think and then
get made it in three moves on the H file
and it's not so simple but yes uh the
good sign is that now Jan is looking at
the screen trying to remember and uh
indeed sometimes what is even worse by
the way Robert and you probably know
that it's even worse to remember a part
of your prep because then you go into
the Into the Danger Zone but you don't
remember the way to come out and it
would have been better if you knew
nothing at least you wouldn't play
something so risky so yes we could still
see uh we could still see a collapse of
Yan's position if he suddenly doesn't
remember all the details but he should
remember the details if he yeah I mean
if you did his due diligence during the
prep
he should remember the stuff because
it's of course crazy Sharp
dingler and H4 I know the viewers are
getting their party hats at I love to
see it and this is a move that we've got
a deep dive into because it basically
sacrifices a piece and now the first
question that I have uh for you Anish is
that is it the best for black here to
accept the sacrifice and I think we have
to bring up the analysis board and take
a look at what actually happens because
the H file opens up it's party time if
that appears on the board uh or should
black just keep everything defended keep
the H file block what's the way forward
what are the lines I want to look at the
piece capture because that's something
that Jan's looking at right now
yes indeed I suspect Kiana is trying to
remember and the computer suggests a
piece capture the question that I have
Tanya maybe you want to include CD first
trying to open the center a little bit
and uh most likely it's going to be a
good inclusion but of course just as a
concrete game so you can never be sure
but yes I think cdcd AEG is maybe the
most straightforward approach and here
of course don't be naive
um dear if you're don't move the knights
and get checkmated between H5
but instead instead black should return
the piece and I and the most
straightforward way to do so is to go G6
to get some squares under control
potentially preparing to seven Rook h8
where the king will be quite safe and
um taking back the piece we are quite
happy
um
as black to restore material balance but
keep the king a little bit more safe
and already we see that white center
would be under Fire which I think is
another reason why taking on D4 first
makes sense and just looking at a
position like this lacks King is castled
though that means the Rooks are
connected white king remains in the
center the bishop is undeveloped so you
have this open H file for your Rook but
that Rook on A2 we need to jump all the
way over the pawns to help deliver a
checkmating attack so it does seem a bit
far off and black has the immediate
threats but if somehow you could get
another piece of the H file then it
would be worth it I just don't see that
happening here not too many pieces in
the attack so this is looking good for
yonda palmshi if he gets these trades
off but why would dingley rent go into
this if this was the national conclusion
well I like the feature chat uh here
Fabiano is indeed giving us lots of
insights as I told you you know he's
joining a little bit late I think he
knows this line inside out he's had so
many games he um he calls this line a
Grisha convention I I wasn't sure who
played it first I thought it was Fabi
but I guess the agric was maybe earlier
but Fabi uh he says the Grisha was going
after instead of 92 early in the opening
and uh I guess uh Fabi you see he's very
familiar with this particular trap and
um or well h6h4 is not a trap but he's
familiar with these ideas but it looks
like you know people taking Fabi very
seriously
and uh
well I I I've seen this variation
already before Jan also but now Jan is
trying to remember should he take on
default first or should he uh take on G5
first The Rook on A2 cannot swing all
the way to H2 Robert but at least it can
swing to D2 and I see some lines where
the Rook can go like Rook D2 Rook D3 and
e594 and Rook d2h3 so it's a very long
road for the Rook but it can't finally
double on the H file and if that ever
happens the fact that black doesn't have
this dark squared Bishop which would be
fair and shut out that would mean that
like can still get checkmated in the
long run and also one other line we
should probably take a look at after AJ
G6 maybe here instead of GF maybe white
has some other options
though you have to already be aware of
Knight D7 followed by King G7 Rook h8
because the mate is no longer going to
be easy to uh to set up but maybe uh
maybe F4 is an option sometimes and if a
knight to D7 maybe then Queen swing to
G4 King G7 maybe F5 or some some form of
Checkmate I I'm not I'm not liking this
for white I think it doesn't really work
but something like that could could be a
consideration
um Fabi of course mixing up his prep as
well he says he played F3 Grisha Queen
Bishop D3 uh yes Bishop D3 E5 E4 is what
I talked about a young takes on G5
without including CD you see even 5B
mixes up everything in this line and uh
very likely that the players today also
might pick something up
but so far Yan it's not taking too much
time just 20 minutes spent one hour 40
remaining uh yeah I think the big
question of today so far the big
question will be how far is uh Jan's
Recollections because his files have it
all worked out but how far does he
remember
yeah that's the essential question I
just want to point out for the viewers
that the move H4 was given a Brilliance
and the reason why is if he had simply
retreated the bishop away from G5 he's
wasting time sometimes you want to
provoke your opponent to make a move
like H6 but that's only if your g-pod
can get up the board you use it by a
hook to open up files but in this
position it would allow black to push
back White's forces then you can strike
against the C4 Pawn that we've been
highlighting is weak and that would not
be a good decision for dingley red so H4
sacrificing the bishop only temporarily
he's gonna win it right back and we see
this continuation with G6 and now ding
is fake thinking I want to say I don't
believe you give up a piece have the
option to take this Knight back and then
you are thinking for real I I do think
he's just trying to recall his
preparation and well Anish raised a good
point maybe the move F4 is an option
it's not just rushing to take back
because with the open H file there will
be some pressure against this black king
yeah I would think
um calling it thinking is is probably
another the right word I think he's
probably choosing because um I suspect
that there are a few options here that
are objectively are equal you know this
computer always nowadays finds equality
in all crazy complications and so ding
probably has a few a few approaches and
he thought okay we'll see if I get this
position uh with a big time Advantage uh
how confident my opponent will look will
he be in book will he end up here after
long calculation and now he well he saw
well Jan clearly isn't book
hopefully doesn't remember all the
details because he did spend 19 minutes
but uh ding is trying to uh to remember
yeah what what were the most he he can
play here besides GF and uh how
difficult are the variations what he
could try perhaps I'm sure he's also
feeling very ambitious so he's trying to
avoid the ones the continuations that
lead to simplifications so I I think he
must be prepared and he must probably
have looked at a few things and he's
just kind of choosing uh this is what I
would expect because being out of book
here that would be quite um quite crazy
because so far Jan has just played all
the best most and um Top Choice of the
computer and you don't want to be out of
book here in this in this very position
it's just the beginning of the
complications
yeah Dawn Of Peace you definitely don't
want to be out of the book I was talking
about bringing the party hats out after
age four Yan going for the most direct
approach of grabbing that piece grabbing
that Bishop it's time to get the
trumpets out as well right now I am
loving the action that we're seeing now
two options that we've been talking
about yeah a ding has the option to
either just equalize the material by
picking up the Knight or continuing with
the pressure an interesting option that
you mentioned earlier Anish was F4
trying to pile on the pressure on the
king side trying to go F5 but when you
look at these lines the first thing that
comes to mind is what actually happens
if black says you had the chance to pick
up my knight not anymore you wasted that
opportunity and after F4 Jana pamushi
has the moment has the chance to
actually retreat with the Knight to D7
and I'm guessing that one of the ideas
that white needs to look at is Queen G4
Queen H4 trying to give maid on the H5
you really want to double up on this
open Age file that's your big
compensation my question to you guys and
anyone one can take this is that after
Queen G4 which to me looks like the
scariest move if black counter is with
counter is counters it with King G7 show
me the attack show me the money
wow I mean honestly I like the challenge
and because I like it so much I'm gonna
pass it to a niche Anish find us a
Checkmate here buddy
you know I'm already miss Daniel my my
man Daniel you would always you know
you'd always Step Up he'd always be
there for me he'd be like okay Anish I'm
on it and he will start calculating here
you'll start throwing out lines okay now
H5 doesn't work because GH you know this
Rook H7 doesn't work probably Rook H6
look at Queen H4 take testing Jade then
we'll swing The Rook you know maybe so
and now we have Robert who immediately
Dodges uh the challenge his first day of
work already slacking
completely terrible Robert I have no
idea I have no idea am I supposed to do
this um there's no immediate Checkmate
here because Queen H4 is meant by Rook
h8 but of course there are some um
slower approaches we can't take the time
and try to get our pieces towards the
king side I do want to bring my A2 Rook
somehow into the attack but that seems
uh stretched too far
Rook H6 uh comes to mind this is a slow
move trying to keep the pressure but I'm
not sure after okay shade um win H4 who
takes H6 even uh if I have enough attack
after finish 16 G8 if I only now had
Rook H2 move but I don't think I am able
to swing The Rook even if I throw a
knight Into the Fire like Knight to five
and G4 I think it might be a little too
late
um yeah now you go Queen f8 and queen G7
so I'm just a Tempo to short so Rook H6
doesn't seem to be a move
but instead there should be other
options let's go back to the critical
position after Queen G4 King G7
uh oh God I missed Anya um here maybe
maybe
D5 is an option trying to dislodge the
E6 Pawn
um maybe I don't know maybe E5 as an
option whatever guys maybe something
else is the option
um very very very difficult to say
um uh what because yes I I don't I don't
know uh look at is coming
I I don't I don't feel like white has so
much time here
F5 was the first instinct I already
mentioned but if I remember correctly
that was also not the move that the
engine liked
doesn't hate it so yeah five was the
move okay F5 yeah if I was the first
move that came to mind actually uh you
know what happened uh Anish I think what
happened was we included cdcd before and
F5 wasn't loved but because this Pawn
has not been captured there's no Knight
coming in to help out in some of the
defense so F5 is engine approved and
anishkiri found so CD let's let's go
just CD just for fun and let's now try
to find that pretty
a pretty Checkmate is just F6 GF simply
because I have Knight H5 that could be
just enough
um but apparently this is
yeah I was hoping that it's still better
for white of something H4 but it's not
so simple maybe G5 and king of seven
yeah I just want to show everybody the
problem with the more natural Queen
takes F6 is Knight H5 is a check and a
fork and you can't take it and that's
not a bug it's part of the game the king
is behind the pawn so you will not be
able to capture it so maybe you have
time before playing F6 maybe that's the
key here is that instead of rushing the
pause
yeah I want to bring the Rook over to
help out but maybe this Black Knight is
also going to help the defense
um no I think night if the Night Comes I
go Queen H4 and F6 I thought after Rook
CR2 I thought EF
um EF look like they only move
but maybe is it just here for some night
of
Southampton a second either five in
quintix simply
because I have connection thread oh that
looks like a game Ender the rookette
shade ideas we're talking about do not
work Queen F7 is meeting one The Rook it
swings from A2 to F2 and helps deliver a
checkmate
yeah well lots of variations but uh
we're going back after F4 we black could
start with cxd4 in fact there's no need
to rush uh Knight D7 and then the whole
thing doesn't work anymore
so it is not so
all the way back yeah
we could include City here
all right so you recapture see after CD
yes and now in the same line so
supposedly after Knight D7 when G4 King
G7 F5 supposedly Knight takes divorce
is working
let's try that out considering the
evaluation I'm guessing it's important
here
oh no
misled us as usual so yeah that's why I
didn't talk I was trying to let you do
all the hard work and find the correct
Solutions
okay
um wait so E6 F5
because F6 you've got Knight F6 after
Rook h8 Knight H5 is defended
like in White's position though right so
you know F6 is a huge threat and there
are more open lines now so actually I
want to show something very quickly to
everybody that the reason why this could
backfire for black is that in this
variation here that uh if you take on D4
and we play F6 and we get this position
uh apparently there's a win for white
but I was just trying to show that in
event the king slides back here the king
is actually safe because their e-pawns
are on the board without the presence of
the e-pawns this king would be an even
more danger right if we just start
throwing pawns off the board there have
been open file against this King so I
think that uh it makes sense just
intuitively that keeping the pawns on
the board would actually be better for
blocking some of these lines
but black has a lot of defensive
resources there right I could also go to
change instead of Knight takes D4
because white doesn't quite threaten
checkmate
and uh okay ding has already left us
with um
with the move he's just gone for GTX F6
I guess he has looked at all these F4
business also after F4 by the way Knight
H7 is a possibility set of Knight D7 so
there were options for black um along
the way and there were lots of defensive
resources for for black
finally ding decided to take on F6 and I
think this idea of Rook D2 to D3
might play a role after Queen takes F6
also keep in mind e5d94 idea this is
also always there
a way to include the Knight
and well Jan better uh better has his
defense uh ready here because this is
very dangerous
yeah it doesn't waste any time to to the
F6 Pawn he does that immediately
so he plays it and now there is pressure
on the D4 Pawn but we see see that the
center hasn't yet been liquidated with C
takes D4 white can slide over the Rook
to D2 defended also ideas of getting the
queen out to G4 and all these uh Knight
jumps to H5 building on the attack is
something that Yan needs to watch out
for but the speed with which Yan is
playing it is that it does that just
show us that he's feeling comfortable in
this position Robert
he did have a series of only moves so I
think the last few turns by Yan I just
makes sense that he would play them
instantly and a big question right now
is if dingley Wren his looks ambitious
based on his opening choice will he play
E5 that will force Jan's hand to take
this Pawn so he'll play another quick
move but I'm looking for white to try to
establish a pass Pawn in the center it's
not just about the pawn quantity we want
to have a past Pawn especially one where
a rook can slide behind it this Rook on
A2 we keep thinking as an attacker but
if we can establish a pass Pawn the
center and a rook Gets behind it it may
be valuable in helping that pawn press
forward so I'm actually more surprised
by dingley Ren's slowing down than I am
Jana Palms she's speeding up
well I I think you know uh it happens uh
this way like even when you're well
prepared if your opponent is slow then
you you choose uh during his thinking
time and you play Fast to put more
pressure when your opponent is fast you
kind of realize that well
no point to put the pressure upon it uh
kind of knows what he's doing and
instead you you try to take a step back
and remember all the different options
you had and you try to still surprise
him perhaps because even here white has
options so ding is thinking okay maybe
Jan remembers what to do after E5 maybe
he doesn't remember what to do after
Rook D2 maybe vice versa maybe these two
lines also you know they they continue
in some way and things trying to
remember okay which final position is
more playable or
um the opposite you know maybe white is
slightly worse in all of these positions
so he's trying to remember which one
okay now I should bail out how should I
bail out all these kind of thoughts
might be going through his head but
knowing his aggressive um character I
think he is looking for
um for a way to take Yan out of book and
try to remember which which of the
approaches Rook the two or the direct E5
was more dangerous for for black
yeah it's a big moment the one thing
that always fascinates me about this
position is that how even one thing was
down a piece the computer showed this
level balance we were looking at lines
with F4 where you don't recapture the
piece but it's it still evaluates the
position as balanced and I want to ask
you a Anish that how do you explain that
because there's of course no direct
meeting idea if that was the case then
White's eval bar would be right up
you're down materially which is what
often the computer computer prefers and
you know for our newer audience how do
you explain being down a whole piece and
gets the computer showing a balanced
position
well um in general sort of the reason
why so far everything is balanced
there's this meme about Obama giving of
Medal to Obama so this is a little bit
of the case of the players preparing
with the engines that then say that the
prep was good so obviously okay the prep
was generated by the engine and we use
the same engine or commentate so it all
makes sense that it's equal but in terms
of why a p stack can be equal well um
you you can have enough conversations
for equality not for a win and one way
it can manifest itself is that okay you
have enough attack and the defending
side at some point to diffuse your
attack has to sacrifice the peace back
for example then you have even material
or it can be that you have enough attack
do you keep sacrificing a bunch of
pieces but at the end it only is
Perpetual which is a draw
or uh you have enough attack at some
point you threaten a Checkmate black
defense if there's another Checkmate
black also defense and this becomes a
perpetual so there are different ways uh
um you know in which the game can end in
the draw and all about that so this is
now no news uh and um yeah the peace uh
Speech sacrifice uh they they can lead
um to checkmates and you know even when
the position is objectively equal if the
player is out of book then um it's very
possible that one of the two players
will win because when you're down a
piece
you know sometimes you don't find the
the attacking continuation and you just
lose down the piece in the end or
sometimes when um black has a defense to
return the piece and make a drone he
doesn't he doesn't or or doesn't find it
and ends up losing the game to Checkmate
so the fact that the position is
balanced doesn't necessarily mean that
the game will end the draw but uh if the
position is balanced and the both
players are in book then possibly they
recollect exactly the same variation
that leads uh that leads to the drawing
you know so they both they are just
reproducing A variation the same
variation that they both have seen
earlier and uh that is indeed uh one
well one negative aspect of modern chess
that sometimes
Um this can happen but more often than
not one of the two players mixes up
something on the way the human factor
steps in and today already from the time
spending of the both players
um I do think that well
either ding or Yan they will somehow
deviate from these computer variations
and something will happen maybe dink uh
was a little bit sloppy you know and
doesn't even remember his Prep properly
thinking that okay we'll never
disposition will never happen uh or
thinking that uh if it will happen Yan
will be out of book but now okay he sees
Jana's in book and he doesn't remember
the details so I think uh thanks to you
in fact a lot of things can go can go
wrong for either of them but there is
that scenario that both of them are
trying to collect the same draw and that
would be of course unfortunate for us as
spectators
and I think that's a really nice point
there that even if the eval bar for
those of us looking at home or on the
computer shows an even balanced bar a
0.0 evaluation it doesn't necessarily
mean that it's an equal position it
doesn't mean that the game ends in a
draw but it just means that it is
dynamically balanced and both players
have their own trumps in the position
well this position Precision is
definitely required as a niche you're
pointing out with precise play very
often it can fizzle out into a nothing
position but that Precision is required
by both Yan and ding at the moment ding
in a big Think Tank right now trying to
create his chances with the white pieces
we'll use this opportunity to go into a
break and we'll be right back with
ding's decision
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
welcome back everyone to game 8 of to
feed a world championship and before we
Deep dive into the critical moment of
the game we are very happy to announce
World Quant is an official partner of
the chess.com broadcast of the fide
World Championship they are a global
firm that builds complex mathematical
models to identify market inefficiencies
now work on brain is bringing together
its International Quant championship and
the chess Community to hunt down the
next generation of Quant Finance
Specialists because nobody knows how to
analyze a position better than a chess
player if you think you have what it
takes register for the international
Quan Championship head to go.chess.com
iqc or use the command iqc in chat lots
of exciting stuff happening and on the
board as well let's jump straight to the
action now this is where we left it ding
is still in a thing after the move Queen
to F6 recapturing that pawn by Anna
palmnushi I'm slightly surprised at this
because the opening that we saw you play
H4 you sacrificed that bishop and G5 one
would think that Ding would still be
very familiar with the position it's
something that he's seen just simply
because it's such a dynamic opening uh
is there something Robert that takes you
by surprise the amount of time ding is
taking at this moment
yeah I think what Anish was saying is
completely true I mean ding is
remembering lines he's thinking what how
much risk do I want to take because
perhaps the best variation we see the
evaluation bar saying the positions
level is some kind of draw and I
wouldn't be surprised if it involves a
knight H5 move at some point going after
this King I'm already looking at
aggressive moves like Queen to G4 let's
bring the queen into the attack maybe
then play Knight H5 so I don't have to
sacrifice a piece but either way with
the evaluation bar at level I believe
that Ding knows that Jan knows that it's
an equal position and perhaps as we keep
discussing the best continuation leads
to some kind of draw by force
while we're talking about the best
continuation right and there is a
forcing threat in the position and it
might be a good time to also Deep dive
with a niche into this queen F6 does hit
the D4 pawn and if you've been
mentioning some very Dynamic ways of
taking care of that threat including
upon sacrifice in the center a potential
E5 or sliding The Rook a more pragmatic
approach uh guys should we take a look
at these options and see how the game
might proceed uh we could start with
Rook D2 perhaps just taking control of
the center
yeah
um
so an important point after two is let's
say after CD4 CD4 the uh orbit even
without this sort of the most tempting
move would be to go ninja 7 with ideal
catch it but that would be wrong because
then after Queen G4 I don't see a
response for black
uh suddenly Knight H5 is a serious
serious threat ninja 7 would be a bit
too premature instead black should
prepare that move and one good option to
do so
is Queen to G5
uh it looks a little slow but at the
same time white doesn't have a way to
get the queen to the H file and King G7
is imminent and already here
it looks as though a white uh White
strands out of the attack but actually
there is move Rook D3 and uh some of the
versions
when an idea is now Knight H5
but maybe bishop takes C4 is something
you want to
that this would be a great dream
scenario indeed but after root D3 I
think Bishop takes C4 is also there
instead of King 37 when uh well yes you
and ding plays instead E5 and uh this is
extremely direct and I think uh this
this was even more forcing I suspect DTX
E5 is is the move to to come and then 94
must be the only only way forward
then uh the complications are just very
Force 94 Queen F4 Bishop D3
Bishop takes C4
all forced
black one a bunch of phones but white
now has to chase the
chase the attack so I guess G3 is the
is the move here the queen is under
attack I suspect Queen to F5 is the
the only move
I think so right the queen is out of
square is the queen of five by default
looks uh necessary
yeah and now Robert you see a checkmate
uh well the evaluation Bar says zero so
I'm guessing there is no Checkmate just
uh yeah I think at some point at some
point Queen C1 to H6 is an idea and we
have to time that uh time that right
because you start with Queen C1 let's
say
Bishop takes d3's the uh
most natural then after Queen h8 at the
very least that can take on e4 and just
even take on H1 and already be up
material significantly so this yeah this
would be uh probably lost for white so
you have to time this kind of things
well but I suspect that
um
yeah we are witnessing a sequence of of
only moves here
but young probably doesn't recollect all
of them so he's in the same spot as we
are potentially there are options here I
mean G G4 is made by Queen F4 and if G5
then King G7 is um
diffusing all the attack
so why it really has to
uh has to be very accurate uh here in uh
yeah I mean this this would this would
already be disaster you have already
lost two pawns and you don't have any
Checkmate so you have to be very
accurate with the attack instead of G4
yeah we have to uh we have to find these
only moves here I think maybe bishop
Bishop to C2 uh could be an option
by Bishop C2 I I want to keep the bishop
I want to give you the A2 rook and then
I want to go for Queen C1 H6
and I'm just I'm just trying to find the
honestly I'm just trying to find the uh
the Right Moves here I'm far from uh I'm
certain that this works
but um
the evaluation bar backs you up a niche
so it's clearly dangerous
dangerous stuff because it looks that it
seems that Bishop on D3 is much more
vital than the A2 rook in um keeping our
position together as white you want to
you want to have this Knight on e4
protected
you know I have an idea based on what
you just told me I think I have a good
line because here it says black is doing
well maybe it's even just simple
captures and the white king is exposed
as well I'm gonna use your idea in a
different way what if I play F3
threatening to bring this Rook over here
and if you take this Rook on A2 I was
thinking one your queen is like almost
trapped over here uh but I was hoping
that I could just play Queen into the
game like you were showing and queen D2
to H6 yeah this is the right way to
sacrifice The Rook indeed because if I
go Bishop C2 as you mentioned first of
all I don't have a clear threads and
also e takes D4 is very strong intending
D3
and F3 is the F3 is the money move of
course
um because you thread on Rook a to H2
and now black has to take the Rook I
suspect after Queen D2 black will black
will be able to defend I think it's
Queen takes F3
and uh Queen H6 Queen xh1 uh and here
compared to what we had seen earlier I I
keep more activity with white the Knight
is still jumping and black has to still
diffuse some of the attack
maybe King to G7 is an option but then
yeah then Knight G5 I probably have
Bishop to D5
the variations continue I mean this is
crazy stuff
yeah I mean H4 yeah you have to allow a
ton of checks if this looks so dangerous
but maybe in the end the black king is
safe enough which is easy for us to say
sitting here and not at the board but if
this is what ding has cooked up Yan will
have to find some only moves and by the
way Jana's thinking so it's not like he
is responding instantly using his
preparation if he is prepared to this
point uh he's doing a good job of
fooling us because I think he's now on
his own
you think so yeah well that would be uh
exciting because I would think that
having played all these moves like B6
Bishop A6 and H6 so quickly
I would think that he he would still
know this variation
but it is for certain that he doesn't
remember the details that's for certain
and he will have to reconstruct this
entire line
and uh well if he doesn't know it he's
capable of that but then there's a lot
more excitement for sure and uh it's
mainly also on ding I mean the first few
moves are
are kind of obvious for black yeah I
think you have to take and you have to
go with the queen forward after d94 you
could also start with Queen F5
that's a little bit different after
Bishop D3 now Bishop C4
a little bit different one is no longer
on G3 that's actually makes even more
sense perhaps
from black because you don't have this
F3 idea because you don't want to swing
across maybe there's no need to go with
F4 reconna five is even more accurate
what are the chances of seeing a
repetition after Queen F5 Knight D6 and
then jumping back I like that oh yeah
yeah yeah oh that's it that's the
repetition of course is that it is that
it that that is
yeah yeah no that's that's oh I was
hoping some long line with 200 moves and
Perpetual in the end but just repetition
so early so quickly really no don't do
it to us and I mean the queen if it
steps forward it only invites to move G3
I I think that actually a lot of these
lines are very dangerous for black I see
the evaluation bar barely reacting
saying slightly better for white but we
just showed a sample line where that
Rook slides across the second reckon a
niche I mean the queen F5 is such a nice
move because it feels wrong in a way to
not weaken the white structure but it's
all about dings eight Rook A2 right we
said we loved it when it was played he
desperately needs to bring that into the
attack
yeah I also want to point out one more
advantage of actually not provoking G3
in those positions the other way that
you guys wanted to line up the attack on
the H file was a move like Queen D2
Queen C1 now in all these variations if
there's no Pawn on G3 that would be
exactly the moment that black would
offer a trade on this diagonal with the
move Queen F4 imagine no Pawn on G3 and
then you suddenly lose all your attack
so I like the concept of actually not
provoking the move G3
yes and one
oh you know what it is Tanya I I have I
think I understood I think I understood
I think I understood it dawned on me
what happened
I'm going to tell you guys what happened
you want to know do you want to know or
not do you want to know I would love to
know yeah do you also want to know or
not you don't want to know what happened
in which Universe because nothing's
happened so far
no but I'll
let you know or not
yes I would want to know everyone wants
to be good everybody uh this is Chad do
you want to also know what what has
happened in this game or you don't know
you don't care give us a hell yeah
is the chat saying yes
Krishna are you are you saying is that a
yes or no do you guys want to know or
not
okay I'll try it okay I'll tell you guys
what Jana's thinking I'll tell you what
happened
so
can I take the mouse Robert as well and
take the mouse go for it yeah go for it
okay so um what happens here guys is
that Jan's prep goes CD CD a g a g G6 GF
Queen F6 through the two
Queen G5 and all that
uh here of course E5 is very different
and it's not working anymore because
with this uh pawns already traded Knight
xd4 is a theme
so this is Jan's prep
so he mixed it up he played AJ first
which is also fine but it's not his prep
this is what happened in the game and
now after JFK and f60 this is the queen
G5 I remember this
and now ding plays E5 and he thinks why
don't I remember this and the reason he
doesn't remember that is because in his
prep he has included City and E5 was not
a thing so this is why Jana's thinking
here because he actually is out of book
yeah this is a good news for us because
it means that we're having a game here
super instructive just to show that it
looks like a small difference all you
did was take pawns off the board but if
I'm I know the queen is under attack
right now but just to once again show
the variation that Anish is talking
about that if we get here this doesn't
work this whole construction with Knight
E4 and everything it's no longer so good
because White Center is just falling
apart and with the King still here it
looks like a huge huge problem so uh
you're I think spot on there and that is
bad news for Yonder Palm Street because
if you're relying on Preparation and
then you get here and you have your uh
oh moment it's not too late we see the
evaluation bar suggesting that black
even maybe is slightly better in some
variations uh but it looks very
Troublesome your king is the one that
might be hunted or White's Knight is
very clearly coming to the center and
you have to find some weird Queen
geometry just to hold the balance in
some of these variations
yeah now the fact that dink has taken
that thought it only uh places more
doubt in Janice's mind because now Janus
may be realizing that he mixed something
up and he thought oh did I make
something up oh now did ding find the
refutation of what I did am I am I in
trouble because Jan doesn't know that
he's still fine he doesn't know he
probably all he knows is that he mixed
up and uh well that's a scary scary
moment for Jan and I think now he's on
his own and he's very capable with the
time he has on the clock he's very
capable of finding um the Right Moves
and they're probably there's probably a
choice down the line but we are we have
a game and we're not going to have
um we're not going to have both players
just showing the prep to the end and
this is really a really a lot of fun
that's what chess is about and I I love
what you're saying so it seems as if Jan
might have just rushed a little bit uh
just played a move too quickly and then
mixed up the move order to land up in
this position where suddenly the D4 Pawn
a small difference but it does exist the
D4 Pawn is still guarded by C3 he's
still taking this time right now if Yan
was to not take on E5 white anyway wants
to go 94 on the next move that's the
idea the only queen move that actually
stops that is Queen to F4 that looks
like the only other alternative that
makes any sense to not capturing on E5
not allowing to move Knight E4 but I'm
just wondering that after Queen F4 does
ding then have the option to actually do
that slide of The Rook that we've been
looking at rookie two rookie for Rook
age for one idea rookie to Knight e41
idea is this dangerous one and two is
Queen F4 something that Jan is
considering because if not you you've
got to take on E5 there's literally no
other alternative whether you in book or
out of book right because 94 is coming
94 is coming Knight H5 is also something
you have to contend with I know you
wanted me to beat Dania Anisha I'm doing
my best Dania impression right now
Knight H5 hitting the queen and
threatening Knight of sick it doesn't
work okay I'm not done yet we know
I'm a wannabe my whole point was it's
going after a Checkmate but the white
king is off the exposed so there is a
queen C1 check and that forces the king
into Center but this does look scary at
first glance yeah
yeah a lot of things to uncover and
um well Tanya you said the D5 is the
only move whether you are in or out of
book and well you know when you are in
book only moves are obvious when you're
out of book as Yan is you're on your own
and suddenly uh positions are much more
interesting when they are on your own
and you have all these different
thoughts so queen of four so Knight H5
presumably doesn't work because of pc1
and then Bishop C4 all sorts of checks
there which is pretty uh sportable for a
player as good as Yan so after Queen F4
I think rookie two
H4 is the big dream
F5 uh came uh came to mind I like this
movie F5
trying to guard the E4 square and if xf6
at least I get some room for the queen
and uh things that things look far from
obvious here to me I don't know Bishop
takes C4 let's say rookie four Queen F6
is a nice trick it doesn't look to me
bad at all for black so I can totally
imagine Jan calculating this I could
even imagine Jan playing this at some
point and this doesn't look clear I
don't know what the bar is uh
d
yeah yeah I think I think that he wasn't
really thinking so much about D takes E5
he's thinking about his follow-up
between 94. he's trying to understand
the nuances between Queen F5 and queen
F4 what we were dissecting because he is
on his own so it's not obvious which
queen move is better here he's not
moving backwards I think that much is
pretty clear but deciding which Square
forward to go to that is what he was
calculating because I think he wants to
respond to 94 pretty quickly and he
wants to put ding on the clock
G3 or do you keep that F4 Square open
and of course it will be absolutely
heartbreaking if it actually ends in the
repetition that we were looking at with
Queen F5 Knight D6 but I'm just
wondering if after Queen F5 is there a
way for ding to keep the pressure on to
keep the initiative going uh what do we
see instead of Knight F6 because Bishop
D3 with all these ideas now just doesn't
seem to work with the F4 Square
not occupied and wow ding goes for
something completely different we don't
have to answer any of this D5 and I see
a shotgunes you are not expecting this
yeah I mean I I was just under the
impression that 94 is the is the move
curiously
ding is also out of book and um oh my
God I understood what happened here as
well it's the same ding just hasn't
checked the variations without syntax
before has it both players didn't check
the variations after cxd4 and
um and dingas actually was thinking here
over the board he was trying to figure
out why did I take in my prep how to
refute it and I guess using his own on
his own he thought maybe e5d D5 is the
way to go and it's interesting much more
positional in a way you down a pawn but
you've got the strong deep on it I
remember Robert you were talking earlier
on about some Rook on D2 supporting that
past one
so you must be feeling proud here um
seeing what's about to happen 94 was
leading to lots of fascinating things
after Queen F5 Tanya I think while you
were talking about this I think maybe F3
intending G4 H2 another way to swing the
Rooks across was also interesting
but uh yeah I guess this uh something
didn't like here and also this line is
couldn't afford remember this long line
we were talking about after it was
Bishop D3
C4 G3 Queen F5 and F3 this long line we
were talking about uh at the end uh it's
it's not clear what's going on here
maybe black is fine here maybe ding
didn't want it what he does is it
ensures that we have
we have an unforced game because now of
course there's no more perpetuals there
are no more draws but um whether white
has enough for a phone more than enough
for a pawn it's hard to say and I'm
really surprised to see that both
players are out of book but
well that makes uh that will only make
the game more exciting and so let's
let's see what will happen
I have another I'm gonna try to do my
best on it and be a prophet in this one
so I I did mention this line thank you
for giving me that credit Niche but I'm
also thinking at some point this Rook
might go up to H3 like we may see a rook
lift on the other side of the board to
help with Knight E4 ideas but also if
this Rook were on H3 Knight H5 becomes
more dangerous for the black king so I
think both Rooks are going to be
activated and I honestly like the
decision we just went through a bunch of
forcing continuations where black had
maybe some opportunities to make a draw
by force or to create an imbalance it
didn't look so clear or favorable for
white but here despite being a pawn down
I think we like the position for white
in the sense that you have an
established past Pawn the black king
doesn't look very safe the white king is
perfectly fine in the center so I think
from a pragmatic perspective D5 does
make a lot of sense here for dingly red
yeah very interesting choice and it just
completely opens up a different Universe
of options for bringing in the attack
you're talking about The Rook being
centralized Rook H3 uh the Knight coming
to the center of the board all these
ideas the one thing that I'm really
amazed to see in this world championship
has been the opening approach of the
players just looking at the past right
in Dubai Magnus versus nepo we had so
many catalans we had so many
anti-martials and it just seemed as if
the players were fighting in the same
openings and then there was a little
deviation here or there but the the
standard structure remained the same it
if it felt so predictable even before
that in the Fabi match as well we had so
many petrovs go in we we saw the
swashniko we saw rosalimo whatever these
two three lines that they were looking
at here it just feels like every game
there is a surprise that the players are
coming with and it often also ends up
with both of them being out of book
spending a lot of time in the openings
but there's been this criticism right
with classical chess about how much
computers and engines have influenced
openings and you see 25 moves being laid
off rattled off by the players and then
you just feel like it's a home prep that
you're watching this match Robert has
been nothing like that both players are
ready for a fight they're ready to take
on a position that they might not be
familiar with and it's great for the
fans and I think that's the reason we've
all been loving this world championship
match is that something that has taken
you guys by surprise as well just the
kind of opening approach that we've been
seeing by these two players
I think it makes sense I mean From
dingley wren's perspective he hired
Richard report as a second you knew once
that pairing became public that you have
to expect variety you have to expect
some offbeat variations and Anish I'm
sure will be able to speak this better
than I can because he's played uh
Richard in so many tournaments over the
years uh but you pick some like that so
you're not predictable we know some of
the previous World Championship matches
have had the same openings over and over
again we know some top players they like
to play just the same lines you've
mentioned Maxine Russia La Grave he
loves to play his night orbs and his
grunfels and you can expect that from
him every time but some when you have to
kind of throw it Dart and hope that it
lands that is difficult especially in
the world championship stage when you're
playing the best of the best I mean
dingley Ren is a beast no matter what
opening he plays but when you can't come
into the game with preparation that you
worked on that morning or in the last
week or maybe even the last month that
makes it your life even harder
yeah this has been an amazing run so far
we've seen so much in this world
championship match and there's an entire
second half that remains we've seen
strategic wins we've seen tactical
brilliancies we've seen setups of mating
patterns that you don't get to see in
the Chess World it's an amazing opening
preparation and we've also seen the
psychological battle at the world
championship matches we heard from
janapamnushi after seven after after
game seven on how exciting this match
has been
clearly I didn't expect anything like
this
are so like a lot of like
like a lot of punches here
to both to both sides but uh
yeah I guess no one actually expected
yes or perhaps
uh perhaps
people for for at least for some time
wouldn't like stated okay classical
chess is dead or something yeah so it it
can still I mean okay uh I'm not sure if
it's fun but it's yeah it's it's
exciting for sure
and an absolute treat for the Chess
World as world championship match we've
been talking about openings all we're
not the only ones we've been super
impressed Fabiano caruana the former
World Championship Challenger he says
can't express how happy I am to see this
variation being played out at a niche
you were the one who called it out first
that this is Fabi specialty what ding
has chosen the A3 A3 setup off the nimzo
Indian and Lavon there replying that
he's familiar with it as well he
mentions
his colleague that it was something that
was brought up a year ago and how
exciting he's finding this what do you
make of this Anish
yeah um at some point when an
interesting side variation like this
becomes publicly known the players they
they usually have the same standoff of
um who checked it of course everybody
checked it and then so the the
tiebreaker is who checked it earlier so
Fabi just said you know I checked it and
left says you know I knew it a year ago
and now grishy was okay but I saw it
till 10 years ago and Chronicles
in 2000 and you know it's um it's a
standoff of who knew it earlier and it
happens very often you have these
off-beat variations that look of beat uh
and rare but somehow there is certainly
logic and Allure to them the computers
also point you into that direction and
um they are much more known amongst
hard-working top players
um then then they then you would expect
them to be so yeah definitely
um definitely
um 96 Twitter exchange there and I think
we are really lucky that um we're
getting a game here and ding has played
this E5 and D5 making sure to stay away
from the force complications and just
goes for this double edge position
taking massive risk you see the bar is
slightly on the black side because the
bar
um the at least Little Engine That is
used for this bar things that white
doesn't have enough compensation for for
the pawn but I'm liking it uh and I
think well it's the chances are at the
very least equal here and we are in for
another exciting treat and um whether
the unexpected this opening or not I
don't know but um another exciting game
uh
on our hands here Nisha I have a
question for you because as you were
talking and you know making the jokes
about who saw what first I was wondering
do you think if Yonder Palm she had the
option would he really choose to play
the Black side of this position or do
you think he would immediately jump and
say give me the white pieces
yeah uh it's hard to say um I think Jan
probably prefers white I know a lot of
players who are very materialistic you'd
be surprised you would really think that
everybody likes initiative but it's not
the case that even at the top there are
many players that are extremely greedy
and they like their pawns and I I think
a fair share of top players would pick
black hair given that both are both
sides are out of book but indeed uh Jan
and probably ding as well I think they
are both on the initiative side of
things then they're giving bones left
right and center and um yeah I think I
think also here you know is this kind of
fun that somehow doesn't feel like like
let's say you go edcd uh give me this
position at a glance like a half a
second or like 0.1 seconds you know like
the geographers do like show it to me in
a split second and ask me how many like
is white down upon and of course
I'll calculate pretty quickly that white
is down upon but my first instinct would
not be that I'm a down upon you know
what I mean like I don't see that I'm
down upon just because somehow
doesn't have a past Pawn the extra Pawn
is on the B file here this B6 Pawn is
the extra Pawn you could say because
okay this this was symmetric so far but
the B Pawn is not really going anywhere
anytime soon and it will take a very
very very long time for it to go down uh
and if anything it's white that has a
pawn that matters right now so short
term
you don't feel you're down upon but of
course if black is ever to trade queens
or then uh you'll regret being uh being
upon down so this is kind of a fleeting
moment here but in this particular
moment white has the initiative that's
for sure
whoa and he doesn't take I thought for
sure he was going to capture but he
brings his Knight back to E7 and the bar
stays level and I just want to say that
I'm sure rainbow is happy with your Geo
guesser comment there uh that was a good
reference and well 97 I mean he's really
backing up but it does bring another
piece towards his King and I guess he
wants to leave the status quo with these
double Pawns
yeah I'm very I was kind of expecting
the Knight to you know head towards A5
but by no means is clear what's uh
what's a better move and um night closer
to the king side it's very harmonious uh
you know night on the Remus dim kind of
thing we've talked about it before in
this match also uh who was it that had
the night on
on the rim I was young yeah with the
1995 already once so he has this traumas
of the 1985 he doesn't want to again to
have that issue so it brings it back to
E7 very sensible now uh well tempting
options again this 94 concrete ideas are
there but this is first indeed is also
very possible
looks super logical to my eyes you get
to hit this Knight this Rook can always
slide to D2 behind it I mean you're
pushing your past pawn and now there
will not be captured in the center and
you mentioned a niche not being clear
where the extra Pawn is if you can push
this Pawn to D6 does that really look
like an extra Pawn from black I mean
it's it is it's a matter of factly
speaking but with a knight coming to E4
or Rook to D2 I feel like you're gonna
be very happy about your Pawn even
potentially going to D7 soon
yeah this looks this looks scary to get
that pawn on D6 but I'm just wondering
this move 97 isn't it all pointed
towards trying to get the Knight closer
to the king maybe move it to F5 offer a
trade so that you can ease out the
pressure and after a move like D6
I see that Rook d8 is an option but it's
a bit scary to play Rook d8 right
because the queen anyway wants to find
itself on G4 you anyway want to play uh
your Rook to D2 and somehow it just
feels like it's spending too much time
uh after D6 Knight F5 is that what yeah
what Yana publisher wants you just try
and trade off these nights that we've
been talking about of course ding will
never allow this he will go for 94 in
this position
yeah exactly and uh you mentioned Rook
idea but I suspect Rook 88 could just be
very bad I'm uh I'm not sure of course
it's very concrete position but it gives
me that extra tempo for Knight E4 and
then these ideas of Swinging The Rook
across remember with F3 G4 and all that
I mean this becomes very suspicious
indeed 95 must be the idea 94 I think
went to d8 perhaps is what Yan wants
um I am not sure but I think that that
is maybe the move
um if G4 that is Bishop B7 intermezzo
I think
um
and just bring the queen to the edge
file instead of G4
yeah then again the screen G7 is the
standard way to deal with it as always
and well yeah I think this is Jan's
calculation I think 97 D6 95 94 Queen d8
if Queen G4 King j7 and if G4 Bishop B7
is what he wants to play it looks pretty
convincing at first glance I have to say
I don't immediately see how white can
develop the attack although F3 and Rook
a2h2 has to be calculated but without uh
control over the
over some crucial dark squares I'm not
sure why it can
can deliver a Checkmate this way I
imagine Bishop e4's possibility and then
if you go okay to H2 you have to realize
there is no thread of Checkmate because
King can
um can leave via F6 at some point so
yeah a lot a lot to on cork here is D6
the only move so uh 94 first is also um
tempting but I guess then uh we have the
screen of four queen of five situation
okay let's say queen A4 the most logical
one here and then we have a similar
version but a slightly different one as
the one we looked at so Bishop D3 again
and again Bishop C4 I suspect or ed5
here is an option again and this G3
Queen F5 F3 the old wait is that but
here is very different right
I'm not sure it is closer so that's
probably good news for black
probably but the pawn is on D5 I don't
know it's very very concrete so Bishop
takes A2
is the option is it again yeah but in
the same variation I think black just
wins a pawn
because then you just take on F3 and
then you take on H1 and then you stole
Bishop D5 and you you are up a pawn
compared to the line we looked at yeah
this is this is a bad version for white
uh so yeah not immediately clear uh what
are the consequences of including d597
and after d695 9428 also the honest is
on white to prove to prove so not sure
um if I dislike this 97 maybe actually a
very cool Solution by by Yan not not
going for this edcd positions where it's
indeed uh positional and you would trade
Bishops and just uh this long-term
danger was bothering him this 97 is a
very concrete way to try and solve the
problems and potentially even take over
the initiative but I guess uh yeah I
guess you know the variations are going
to be very forcing and uh White has also
also resources
super complex very critical
super complex position Robert and very
critical now is
now I like to actually keep the balance
and keep the initiative going so ding he
needs to find that 94 is also so
tempting uh coming in with that with the
tempo on the board
and it just turns out that it isn't an
accurate move thing needs to be also
judicious on the clock how important is
that at the moment do you think he needs
to take his time he needs to spend those
extra minutes right now or is it also
important to balance out the clock right
now I think it's really important he
spends his time at this critical
juncture because D6 you have a pass Pawn
you want to push it but then your pawns
are no longer in contact with one
another so you may very well lose that
pawn later in the game but I think he
understands that it is now or never just
in terms of the overall picture of this
board the landscape is such that he
needs to act he has an open file for
this rook and I'm actually going through
variations in my head and one of them
involves D6 something that we were just
talking about but I'm going to invert
the move order a little bit so if we can
just analyze this for a second then I
think in the variation that we were just
talking about what if white plays the
queen D3 to start with we want to bring
our piece to the H file that also makes
G4 more of a threat because our Queen
already defends this Knight on e4 so I'm
sort of taking the sting out of some of
Black's defensive resources while trying
to might bring my queen over to deliver
a Checkmate I understand that Anisha is
always kind of automatic but if I play
G4 here what is the reaction
well I think it's Bishop B7 here I don't
think moving the Knight is good I think
Bishop B7 is is probably the point and
after GF EF
Quinn H3
uh I can take on e4 and run with the
King
to F6 wow so I think it could work out
all right for black
amazing maybe
F3 and Swinging The Rook with Rook ah2
uh potentially so after yeah after GF EF
let's say F3
I don't I don't believe in White's
attack or maybe F3 immediately even
I don't know how dangerous is Rooker H2
um with the black king having all these
dark squares to leave I suspect it's not
so dangerous
definitely something to consider even
Bishop before Queenie for the Knight
takes D6 Queen E5 F6
look probably is doing very well there
because if you are able to uh diffuse
the attack at this point you have a very
good Pawn structure and good night and
all the all the right pieces on the
board so white white has to be concrete
but there is attacking potential for
white of course there is this H file and
a lot of interesting options and ding is
reaching um reaching deep
um here we can be certain that the
players are completely on their own at
this point at this point it's completely
clear and so so many tactics to uncover
it feels like the variations Never End
right like in your head after 97 you
have to calculate everything we just
looked at because uh the White Queen
venturing over to deliver a Checkmate
that will be part of the plan and it
involves a peace sacrifice we just we're
looking at this variation here where in
the moment after Queen D3 you know you
need to bring your Rook to defend your
king you cannot leave the H file
uncontested but after G4 Bishop B7 this
once you're here all right you see the
move but look at the evaluation bar we
have that the players do not and even
the evaluation Bar says that the game is
level which means that Dynamic equality
which really means if you make one
mistake you might just lose on the spot
because you are giving up a piece there
are tactics there are checkmating
threats uh this is actually really
really worrisome uh there are a lot of
tactics to figure out
it is
with all the all different combinations
to build in a fact that you've been
pointing out bring the Knight to the
center try and double up on the H file
you either bring the queen to the H file
through a lift or you transfer The Rook
from one end of the board to the other
on the H file with the pawns moving
forward reminds me of that little Rook
A2 move that we were talking about and
suddenly it comes into the attack so
dingler and currently thinking how to
combine all these tactical ideas which
make it as powerful powerful an attack
as possible currently a critical moment
Robert as you pointed out thing is in a
think tank it is uh it is important for
him to either decide on D6 94 he needs
to use the time judiciously so many
angles at play we're gonna take a quick
shot break and be back with all the
action
[Music]
I do recommend Meetup to a lot of my
friends that are looking for different
things wine tasting movies book club
meet a lot of new people a lot of new
friends and make you more social
[Music]
well it was bound to happen I now have
to do the challenge myself I'm totally
nervous even though I shouldn't be but
anyway it's time to see what time I can
post we have the world's highest rated
clock operator here straight as well
England's number one Junior are you
ready to start the clock but not now
okay
wow it's a lot harder to look if I put a
piece on a long skirt that's going to be
totaled in here
literally training my whole life to do a
challenge that I didn't know about
so viewers at home you might want to get
a more shallow box I'm also slightly
cheating by another Justin but uh we're
gonna try to get them in the middle of
the square Trey if you see any pieces
are in violation yeah stop 32 seconds 32
yeah
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back everyone it is move 16 of
game 8 of the world championship match
between janapamnushi and dingler and
dingler and playing with the white
pieces has been thinking for over 15
minutes in this position a big moment
for him as he needs to decide how to
carry forward the attack we have been
discussing different variations
different parts that white can build the
pressure on black skin Robert what do
you make of this big thing that Ding is
having and which option do you think
he's going to choose at the end
well you can rely on top players for
knowing when there is a critical moment
and it is right now I think the move D6
is what he wants to play he did just
push his Pawn up to D5 a turn to go but
he's looking at all of these tactics and
he's realizing that Jan probably has it
under control I think what he wants to
do is leave yon with optionality but
where some of them have pitfalls but
when you play a move like D6 there is no
turning back as we've been analyzing so
Tanya I feel like dingley rent he came
into this game knowing that a win is the
desired result that if he didn't get
this win he could be in some trouble in
the match Anish has earlier plenty of
time left even if he draws with this
game it's going to be all about game
nine he needs to hold with the black
pieces prove that he can stabilize but
he wants to make the most of this moment
he caught Jan off guard so Anish I mean
things still thinking here what do you
make of the current situation
well you know uh when you look at the
game of the computer uh it's always uh
very clear what's happening the
variations are similar very natural but
the problem is the the good moves are
logical and natural but the bad ones are
also logical and natural very often and
there's always much more that means the
eye even viciana said always you know he
said in my prep he said it's all clear I
do this they do that and this but once I
land at the board the computer is not
there all questions come up why not this
move why not that move you know chess is
much more Rich over the board when you
don't have the evaluation and there are
so many more possibilities here than we
see first to begin with there is no
threat just to be clear to be clear like
there is just no threat so
um you could also try improve the
position with Rook G2 94 is very
tempting not to allow the queen to come
back to d8 D6 Knight to 594 that's of
course the first thing you look at but
then the question is uh
what what next I mean then it becomes
really forcing Bishop B7 is next your
Knights getting targeted if you lose the
knights um and you lose the pawn on D6
it's all over so you will have to go
something like G4 it should be seven
it's forcing you cannot just go with the
694 and say okay I'll figure it out you
can do that if you know that this is
computer says this is the way to go if
you don't know if for all you know that
could be a mistake because you know the
responsibility is very high if you push
the Deep one forward
you might as well lose it and this is
not what you want
so these risky possibilities you have to
be sure what you do so ding is trying to
make up his mind already after the 694
95 94 28 he has to see a certain
follow-up because Queen D3 can G7 we
discussed that G4 Bishop B7 all of these
things I think he is looking at this
position after 23 in G7 G4 Bishop B7
which to me seems uh like a very natural
Direction it's kind of all all it looks
first I don't know if it is first and
here there are options actually to move
D7 came to mind at some point I don't
know if it's good but just to move the
seven I I like that that Bishop before
Queen E4 you don't take that pawn and
after 96 I have Queen E5 and if F6 I
have maybe even Queen oh sorry I just uh
collect the knife that's the idea so
um maybe this is what he's thinking
about but there are surely opportunities
for black as well here
um to play something the bar is not even
completely clear on on this end so uh
lots lots of questions here and lots of
choice for Ding and understandably he's
taking his time so far he's been slow
and this 20 minute thing it's uh it is
this one is uh probably Justified
I think he's about to reach out and make
a move it's the kind of uh feel that you
get from his body language a slight
shift there uh there's been so much chat
about his time management in the world
championship so far and I think we saw
the biggest drawback of that happen in
game seven the absolute collapse that we
witnessed uh when he froze with just
seconds on the clock and was just
physically and mentally unable to make a
move and while ding thinks I want to use
this moment to ask you Anish because he
has so much experience at the biggest
stage in the Chess World you've played
against and you played against Yan you
have your own team in seconds in a
situation like that at such a big stage
if it's being being someone from ding's
Team for example rapper is there what do
you expect how do you handle this what
is it that you tell the player going
into the second half after having the
experience that he did in game seven to
deal with this what's the best free Best
Way Forward
oh this is so incredibly hard and
I know even people who try to help me
and
after games like that especially when
things are not going well
just a slightly wrong wording you know
it could it could be that final straw
that damages your confidence or or the
opposite the certain right way of saying
or doing something it could restore the
entire being and um of course nothing
restores your account your own company
is better than your own good moves your
own good play but in a moment like that
when you just lost the game and you need
to come back and there's no time to
um so recover yeah you you need to feel
the player and everybody is different
and I hope you know
um Ding and his team they they found a
way but it is it is extremely difficult
and challenging I mean I uh can tell
from experience I I see often people
people try but uh yeah it's very often
very very difficult
um it's it's your own mindset and
sometimes you need to take the pressure
off um sometimes you need more pressure
sometimes you need
um
to feel the confidence and someone to
tell you how great you are
or sometimes you need to laugh at how
miserable you have been and uh it's
always different and it depends on the
moment and um I've had some incredible
um
well incredible it sounds stupid but
incredible
some very memorable experiences where I
managed to come back from a bad
situation
and uh it's it's often surprising uh
what what it was and what what worked
and without context it doesn't it will
not make much sense you know it's not
like I'll tell you you know one time I
went to an Italian restaurant and it was
a wonderful experience but somehow at
that moment with all the context around
it
um
yeah it was you know it was that trip to
the restaurant uh that that helped me or
sometimes
um it's a conversation or it's it's just
yes it's also
so details you know so fragile and
random to be honest and I'm not sure
that there's a universal recipe there
but we will see from ding's moves today
if uh if he is back because this
position it's a good test it's a good
test because well best thing he can make
something of it because this is his type
of position of course he can calculate
very deep he's very creative and uh very
very powerful but at the same time if
you are a little bit off shape here it
can go wrong and he can easily lose the
game I mean it wouldn't surprise me the
sliders that he if he'll lose this game
because this is a completely double-ish
fight yeah and just to Echo what Anish
was saying in there uh that as you know
I've coached and worked with some top
players and sometimes it really is just
about being there for them reassuring
them because they're the best chess
players in the world like Anisha is and
so it's about making sure that they're
having fun being confident and so it
just doesn't feel stressful and work and
like it's not happening the way you want
it to so I think for you know his team
of seconds he had a rest day yesterday
hopefully that uses a great effect and
well Anish I think you're going to be
proud of me I just was talking and a
tactic came to mind while I was talking
so I pulled that Donya that you've been
asking for I actually think we need to
analyze I can't believe this just
happened mid conversation uh or
monologue I should say but you saw
another tactic that fails uh no no I
don't think it fails I think you're
gonna like it
you're trying to replace Daniel I mean
this is why it's quite cute okay give it
another shot we're very different
stylistically in terms of our chest but
in this variation we've been talking
about with Queen D3 King G7 G4 Bishop B7
I think there's this move Rook H3 and I
mentioned a rook clip before and the
eval bar doesn't hate it so let's bear
with you for a second that if you take
this Knight and I take back and you take
on D6 this no longer works out for black
the same way because after Queen E5
check Pawn F6 Queen H2 you don't have
Rook h8 so I don't know how this is even
because this looks very scary to me but
the whole point is that Rook h8 is no
longer in the equation because the
Knight on D6 is spied by the queen on H2
so hey how did you remember don't be
honest okay be honest did you find it
yourself or did you see some engine
suggested you see what I see you have I
have the same uh you're on the same
parse I guess me
I was thinking earlier about ways to
make that Queen D3 Line work and I just
thought that we wanted to uh you know
get the Rook out of the diagonal so it
seems Let's cross check this young man
fair play Team chosen.com just go check
if he's not lying
I love it Robin what an what an amazing
line just using this Rook lift an idea
that he actually pointed out a few moves
ago right you you mentioned this idea
quite a quite some time back and to make
it work because the queen falls back
attacks the night but I will tell you
one thing Daniel would have probably
found her mate 10 moves ago you just
found a way to win materials so still
not there Robert hey would they say when
you see Checkmate look for better so I'm
just trying to steal some pieces but how
is that position even by the way like
yeah this uh maybe Knight F7 and King G8
is one thing I I was wondering like do
you really have a Checkmate no but I you
know I thought it looked good
amazing just cover the issues bad but
you need the A2 rook in the game as well
and I don't know
you have to bring these pieces in
quickly because I'm going to call Queen
B8 next perhaps try to chase your queen
out
and meanwhile ding has spent 25 minutes
in the current position
this is uh getting tricky now
I would go for D6 anyway and then choose
between D7 or Rook H3 uh because
well problem with the 94 we had already
seen this queen of five queen of force
or queen of four Bishop C4 business
Rook D2 is possible but two
maybe Queen F4 as well
and then Knight F5 and um
we lack we like active ways um to
somehow get our pieces closer to the
king I think the D6 it looks promising
yeah I like Robert's Rook H3 option I I
liked also my move D7 a lot I think the
seven was also nice um if you remember I
I didn't see the issue with that
um yet after the 695 94.8 G4 or queen to
three first let's say King G7
um
G4 Bishop B7 yeah D7
I like that move I didn't see what's
wrong with it
um maybe
yeah I don't know what's wrong with it
there's no threads but I don't need the
thread I won't play Rook D2 next or
whatever
consolidate my deepon oh and you saw
with a little bit more time the
evaluation went from minus you know 0.5
so Half Upon better for black back to
even so I mean this doesn't look like a
position we just say yeah of course it's
just equal I like White's position I
mean white has an attack what has a Pawn
on the seventh rank you can bring Rook
to defend there's always going to be
problems with the black king this Knight
is directly threatened I like this
second guessing himself that is what
it's called because remember he was
about to make a move at some point yeah
yeah and now he's back in the tank
um and I think he is still he's still a
little bit of
um his pace is okay he can afford to
think now it's okay he has an hour he
can do this but his face is a little bit
off again and I'm getting a little bit
worried for him I'm getting bad vibes
you can you know sometimes during the
game you can switch gears and you can
pick up the pace
but I'm getting the worrying signs like
in the previous games you know the
thought is a little too long
it does feel a little ominous right now
and we did see ding hesitate he almost
reached out for a piece but then decided
not to play on he's been now close to 30
minutes on this move 17. so still a long
way to go before meeting time control
and what happened in game seven it just
can be such a big nightmare to deal with
it in your own head when you're back
even though you've got to rest there
it's a lot easier to just to deal with a
loss that's happened over the board and
the way it happened as we saw it then
what because you're very aware that you
could not handle that clutch moment that
you choked in that time pressure and
that is so much harder to get over than
a game that you lost on the board
it is
this moment here you see ding thinking
he's down under an hour on the clock and
without increment we saw what happened
to him in game seven but he understands
that this is such a big moment not just
in this game but in the world
championship as a whole if he can win
this game equalize the score once more
he knows he's right back in it but I'm
wondering what his mindset is does he
believe he needs to win this game that
is dangerous territory for a chess
player you need to be objective you
can't play results oriented chess unless
it's the final round or you strictly
need a victory to stay in the match I
feel like this is such a big moment he
is trying to be precise but those
thoughts start to weigh on you a bit you
start to think about can I actually win
this world championship is Yan going to
be able to pull away if he makes a draw
here with black and then I have to
defend with black myself in the next
game and he knows D6 is on the table he
really wants to play it he wants to
bring his Knight into E4 next he just
needs to convince himself that it's good
because uh it's not easy there are a lot
of complexity and calculation to to work
through but I do feel like ding should
have the upper hand some of the
positions we looked at
yeah and Robert I just want to say um
what I've what I feel is kind of
happening in the moments like that so
what essentially it is is a lack of
confidence and the way it manifests
itself while you think so being a great
player the ding is of course if you saw
a variation that was forcing and it
ended with let's say a checkmate
let's say it's Checkmate in 15. he would
find it and then he would go for it
right but it is these moments where you
have to take a leap of faith in a
certain sense you have to just make a
call like
I will find a move there or
um it's so like it's it's good enough or
um it's probably maybe I'm not better
but I should do it so you have to take
the sleep of leaps of faith and you have
to do and that is what chess is about
most of the time you are not actually
you don't actually see to the end and
take a decision you take a certain Leap
of Faith with every move you think okay
this is the right way to go I'll find
the rest later this is the right way to
go Alpha and dress later and when you
are down on confidence
you are not confident about these
uncertain positions and um you start
second guessing yourself and before
taking that leap you try to oversee all
the consequences and that is by
definition impossible in chess so this
is kind of what's Happening you try to
dig deeper and deeper
but you're doing yourself a disservice
because you cannot do that so you're
just wasting your time and uh you cannot
call it because the three of the
variations is too too wide you just
you're just doubting yourself and um
messing with your own thinking process
because the thinking process should be
that at some point you rely on your
intuition and you make a call that this
is the way to go and something will be
found and once you try to find a
continuation that is completely forcing
at least a good position
and you don't trust that process then
you start making some weird decisions
and wasting too much time and also
making moves that are too bad and so I'm
seeing still the same signs in ding as
in the previous game this confidence and
this mechanism of calculating cutting it
off at
um at some certain moment trusting
yourself and making a move this is a
loop that has to keep happening when you
play chess I think that that Loop is
broken a little bit in Ding and he's
just not doing that and he's taking a
bit too long
yeah he's got 24 moves to make he's down
to 55 minutes on the clock
uh he needs to make this move 17 quick
he needs to make a decision a ding has
managed to of course create chances in
this position it is a game for three
results uh and we've seen the strategy
this math strategy from doing all along
where he gets these opening positions
where it's a it's a full-on game
Anything Can Happen Jan's not feeling
comfortable things not feeling
comfortable it's tension on the board
wait one gets the feeling that does that
even suit ding's own style has he been
true to his own strengths while doing
that and is that something that you feel
uh Robert has been a factor in this math
so far that while ding wants to create
chances where Yan can perhaps go wrong
but he's often choosing positions where
he doesn't feel very comfortable and
true to his own style it's such a great
question and I actually was thinking
about that when Anish was speaking
because in the candidates tournament
that led to these two being here
alvareza farooza he played many
different openings but they were
criticized as not being in farrugia's
style he was playing uh you know the
Catalan and all sorts of openings that
he didn't typically play and there we
see the move D6 a ding he plays it he
gets up and he walks away and I think
that he knows that it's the correct
decision objectively it is verified by
the eval bar here it is great but what I
want to say to answer your question
fully Tanya is that for dingly Ren I
think that he is such a precise player
but unfortunately perfect is the enemy
of the good sometimes you need just play
on intuition trust yourself rather than
trying to calculate to the very end I
think ding does struggle with that at
times and in this match he has Frozen as
we all witnessed in game seven but I
think players like Hikaru Nakamura they
play these moves on Instinct and they
are people who take risks in their chest
they're willing to play a double-edged
position where they might lose where
some people they play to win other
people play not to lose that is just the
mentality in the world of Chess and
Niche I mean you know ding you know Jan
you play them many times do you find
that sometimes not that he just doesn't
trust himself but he's really trying to
calculate to the very end and that holds
him back to some extent
yes of course but I don't think that
that is who he is I think that is what
happens when he's out of shape and um
what happens when Jan is out of shape is
that he starts playing way too fast so
this is just um yeah these are the
symptoms of of ding being off ding or in
shape he you know he does everything
great so uh he will he's not afraid to
lose I mean one of the most ambitious
players I know think to be honest I mean
I've played many players and uh so often
I've been in situations where my
opponents have a choice to either force
a draw or simplification of Swords or to
play for a win with unclear consequences
and uh there are a few players that that
are particularly ambitious of course
Carlson is one almost always does he go
for the clear uh option Fabi has become
extremely confident over the years I
think this is tremendous result in
six-fold cup and he won seven games in a
row that's really uh made a big impact
on his career I think ever since that
moment he's become extremely confident
in himself
and ding is also one of the players who
almost never take choose a safety but of
course when he is in a poor former where
he's struggling with his confidence of
course he'll start double guessing
himself
um while uh if Yan is in the poor form
and is struggling then Jan's instinct is
to just
um throw the pieces of the opponent and
play extremely fast and try to get rid
of the tension as soon as possible and
um and this is just a stylistic
difference but no I would I think it
would be a big insult to say that Ding
has a player who is uncomfortable to
take risks or you know or is is not not
um not good enough for any of that it's
just not the case but of course here we
see the symptoms of lack of confidence
he's playing a little bit slowly again
yeah he's undoubtedly one of the best he
is the world number three and currently
we see isamos being blitzed that Anish
you know the two players really well but
I also want to give a shout out to our
chat on YouTube and on Twitch who were
on point when they guessed that Ding
will indeed go for the move D6 and he
did play it will the amount of time that
he took to make this decision will that
come back to haunt him or not well we
will find out in just a few moves but we
see Yan doing that thing what he does
playing super fast immediately made the
move Knight to F5 offering the trade
which then declined played 94 this is a
position that guys we had in our
analysis hitting the queen and the line
that you pointed out a niche is on the
board with the queen Retreat to d8 and
how do we see this going forward willing
try to double up on the H file are we
expecting G4 guys take it away
I think the big question is will he put
that D7 move that and you suggested
which is a great one uh and it is at the
end of the line which we've been
analyzing with I guess Queen D3 first
king G7 G4 Bishop B7 we're saying this
is all pretty forced for black just to
execute on this pin just to remind
everybody who wasn't here earlier that
capturing on F5 would actually be bad
because there is problems down this line
so that is why we will not see this
capture on F5 but anisha's D7 really
really interesting move the point being
that after Bishop takes Queen takes no
longer are you stealing this past Pawn
with your knight and your knight is
threatened so it has to move but this
past Pawn will remain so what is the
response to D7 is you came up with the
move I know what the onus shouldn't be
on you to respond to your own good
suggestion but how does black deal with
this past Pawn one square away from
promotion
I'm not sure it's a great move I mean I
I like the look of it but uh I would
trust the bar more than my instincts and
to be honest my instincts in this kind
of positions um
yeah I would never never trust them
myself either because
how do I know what's you know what's the
right move here it's just so complicated
you just try to I mean all I try is to
to look like two three moves ahead and
not blunt or something and okay as long
as the attention is kept it's probably
all right but after D7 I mean one
question I have is um so I don't have a
big threat I think my next move is Rook
D2 probably
so in the meantime you also can
um you can also
take your time and do something
you could try to move the Knight to H4
but I don't think you have to
you could you could I'm not I'm not sure
if it's the right way to go because not
an H4 is it's just misplaced potentially
um but yeah you could you could go for
it maybe then go look at shade support
it and
um the D7 Pawn it's one step away from
promotion but I think it's that one step
it will never make it will never promote
to date because the eight square is so
well protected by both the queen and the
two Rooks so
um the polo do something it's more it's
just restricting the pieces rather than
really promoting also instead of Knight
H4 uh I do wonder if you can make a
waiting move like if you could of Queen
E7 and okay d8 group
uh I thought Rook D2 here and if rkd8
Queen H3 Queen and was the idea
about the queen history maybe you have
Bishop before
that's so nice
well one use of the deep one indeed is
that uh I can I can suck the queen this
way
but after Queen H3 I think again this
bishop before this King on six is
it it's just fine there I need one more
piece like I need the dark Square bishop
or a knight to to check my video but I
don't have this this piece so not not so
simple I mean I'm not sure D7 is good um
I'm also liking your look H3 suggestion
um and this haven't kept more attention
because Rook H3 it allowed this bishop
E4 Knight D6 Knight F7 sequence where in
the end I was not sure what's uh what's
happening
but ding is thinking already now and I
suspect there are other options here as
well instead of Queen D3 the only thing
I don't like is that I feel like when
I'm looking at these games
I feel like whenever we have this
complicated position which is
objectively like roughly balanced I feel
as though ding is
um giving Jan a handicap
and then I realized that this is not a
handicap that he's giving is the sort of
it's something that Yan is taking
um prompting because Jan is playing
these good moves quickly
I mean dean for example he would take
the time even on 95 and 28th even though
he knows that these are the best moves
he'll still take his time no matter what
we saw him taking time on every decision
other than the recapture while young he
just doesn't even let any seconds stay
behind and the problem is that when you
play so quickly not only do you save
these seconds but you also somehow you
somehow put even more pressure on the
opponent and the opponents tend to think
longer as well back which is weird but
that's what happens a lot and uh I I
feel a little
um annoyed for ding that somehow he's
yeah he's significantly behind on the
clock in all of these complicated games
and this is just this is almost not fair
but he does it to himself
yeah and he mentioned after playing the
London right it was his kind of kind of
a position and he played it to
Perfection he kept the time management
in hand but in these positions
especially the one we have right now yes
it's a mess but it just feels like
ding's confidence is making him stop at
every move at every moment to burn the
clock a little bit and Jan does that to
Perfection what you just mentioned when
he smells that when he smells that his
opponent is struggling with confidence
is struggling to make moves fast that's
when Jan who is such a beast who just is
so good at these kind of positions and
playing fast but it just multiplies for
him you know that part of him comes out
even more and that can be so
discomforting to already a ding who is
currently well at least looking shaky on
the clock unsure of his moves reaching
out for a move and then uh pulling back
so big moment but ding really needs to
get himself together he needs to start
making those moves quickly there are a
lot of questions yet to be answered in
the position
is doing Nepal things where he's leaving
those questions to be answered when he
has a big advantage on the clock when it
will get even more tricky for ding to
take control of the position running
down on minutes it's been all eyes on
this world championship match it's been
such a treat I saw a feature chat which
said that I'm so emotionally invested in
this match and I feel that too I have to
say that one really feels it because
it's been such an emotional
rollercoaster and our very own mic line
in Asana he spoke to the former world
champion the 14th World Champion
Vladimir kramne on his thoughts on the
match
thanks guys we are here with the 14th
World Champion Grand Master of Vladimir
kramnik who's playing his own rapid and
Blitz tournament but I wanted to ask him
first about the World Championship now
in 2000 you played a world championship
that was much more like Carlson style
mostly draws of course you won the
decisive games good for you but in 2006
you played a match which was much more
like this one you got a lead then you
lost the lead then you came back so let
me ask you since you've played in both
types do you enjoy as a fan this type of
world championship more
yeah I mean uh you know each
championship match has its own kind of
drama yeah has its own way to develop so
this one is very original I mean so many
decisive games five out of seven is
really I don't know maybe unique in the
latest history of Chess so it's a very
interesting its own way it's very
emotionally dramatic maybe I mean
players showing some very good moments
low low moments of play but all in all
it uh yeah it's it's interesting that's
maybe the most important yeah from the
majority of the people your event starts
at 5 PM local time here which is two
hours after the world championship so
when you spend that two hours keeping an
eye on the world championship or will
you be more preparing for your own event
I think I will be talking to my kids and
doing some emails so I I think neither
of it so probably only in the evening
when I finish my game of course I will
have a look at at the games and what
happened you've seen the players you've
seen their emotions can I get you to
make a prediction for the second half of
the world championship
no I mean you uh actually my prediction
before the event was correct I mean yeah
I felt like it's going to be very uneven
much I mean very up and down and many
decisive games that's what I predicted
on camera so and I think it will
probably continue like this but now
after yesterday's games I'm I'm pretty
sure it's going to be nipponishi who's
going to win in my opinion but we can
still have a number of surprises I mean
and a number of decisive games and
finally there's a lot of rumors going
around on the internet that you may or
may not be on the palm nashi's team of
course you're playing here in the
tournament that should settle the rumors
but can you just clarify for our
audience if you are or are not no but
the no rumors it's of already official
information some yesterday somebody have
sent me this article from financial
times that I'm official you know like a
chief of the team of of yan and I
suppose if it's published in financial
times it is truth yeah I mean it was the
first time I heard about it but who am I
to argue so I guess it's true all right
you could be a world champion you can be
a second and uh play in your own
tournament a little bit of sarcasm there
but thanks so much Vladimir kronik for
your time
wow that was a very interesting
interview with Vladimir kramnik we will
come to discuss about everything that
was mentioned especially him being a
potential uh trainer to yarn for this
match but look at that this is what the
action that we have with a dingler and
who is currently trailing Jana pamushi
in the match going into the second half
historically these are The Comebacks
that we've had Magnus Carlsen in his
match against Sergey kariakin he lost
the game I think guys it was a game nine
and then he strikes immediately back in
the very next game to equalize this goal
vision and against Boris girlfriend back
in 2012 and Vladimir kramnik is there in
that list as well it's of course no easy
task as the match is getting closer to
that finish line to make a comeback
we've seen ding do this time and time
again at least twice in this match can
you do it the third time Robert big Vlad
he gave Yan as a as a favorite to win
the match
would you agree well Vladimir krummick
knows something about mounting a
comeback in the second half of a world
championship as you see in the graphic
here T did it twice so he knows what it
takes went trailing to win critical
games in fact against Peter leco it was
that very last game that he needed to
win to tie the match up and he won
because he was the reigning Champion so
uh you know kromnik is not working with
Yana palmchi at least that's what he
made pretty clear in that interview uh
but still I mean he is a legend of this
game it's great to see him playing in
these rapping to Blitz events because he
said he retired so he's not fully
retired he's only retired from classical
chess it would appear but I am happy to
see Vladimir playing once again and I
think that Vladimir is right that Jana
Pomchi is the favorite he has a lead and
right now he is a massive lead on the
clock and I'm starting to get nervous
for ding again we've only seen 18 moves
played he has 41 minutes remaining
there's no increment so if my math
serves me well he is 20 two moves to
play and doesn't even have two minutes
per move
hmm yeah we've seen Vlad even play I'm
just gonna go back to that interview
because it's still in my mind Robert and
I felt it was a little ambiguous about
his uh working with Jan of course right
now he's at a tournament he himself is
emotionally invested in the in his own
students there who are playing right now
in Astana but there is a possibility
that perhaps he's done some work with
Jan proceeding going into this world
championship match what are the chances
of that uh Anish do you think that might
have happened
yeah certainly uh anything might have
happened and I really like that
prediction there by Vladimir kramnik you
know is a famous uh anecdotes according
to topgren master Vladimir kramnik Yanni
is leading by a full point here so yeah
definitely definitely a good prediction
there right now but um no Vladimir
Kramer you know is a very um
yeah it's a very cunning
um cunning player you know he's always
uh very clever in his games but also in
the interviews you never can tell you
know what's um what's going on there uh
has he you know has he helped Jan at
some point or not uh very very possibly
of course and uh the help could have
been also very
um limited let's say I mean he could
have had maybe a few days of a
consultation with with uh Jan maybe just
one call you know maybe
um young could have consulted him on on
some strategy some advice what he thinks
is the are the strengths of doing for
example because Vladimir also played
both Jan and ding a lot so he he could
have some opinion you know on what a
general approach to take he could have
sent certain files as well concrete
opening files or not so we don't know
any of that the fact that Vladimir
karmic is now not helping Jan but is
playing his own tournament doesn't say
any of that it would have been uh doing
and okay what do you want him to say I
mean especially if Jan asked me that's
it three main secret okay what do you
want him to reply you want him to reply
it would be secretly but yes or what I
mean it's frankly yeah so it's difficult
um it's difficult but um we will never
know until we do so yeah but now we have
to speculate and watching
um
keep thinking which is uh
a Pity but finally he makes the most
obvious uh obvious move at this point
well most obvious for those who have
already delved deep into the position of
course this is not at all the most
obvious move but um if you if you spend
some time realizing that geforcement by
Bishop B7 then you can figure out that
okay Queen D3 King G7 G4 is uh it's a
likely one uh likely way to play and uh
I guess we'll see the position we were
discussing earlier uh quite quite
quickly because Jan is not going to
waste any time he's going to come back
like in your seven and go away we know
him
is that your prediction that Jan's just
gonna Blitz out his move right now
immediately go for King G7 he has no
other move if he doesn't play King G7 he
just loses the game because Queen H3
will deliver a Checkmate down the H file
so yeah Jan will play King G7 and I
think dig needs to respond instantly to
Jan's move because he can't keep burning
clock this mission is very complicated
this isn't just some position where you
can make a draw at any point or keep a
quality he's down a pawn let's not
forget that Ding sacrificed upon by
playing E5 several turns ago he has a
passer which is great but if he's down
to just a couple minutes on the clock
for say eight moves like we saw in the
previous game it's not going to be easy
for him
yeah great galda Robert Anish King G7
the only move and played very fast well
the good news for ding fans is that Ding
replies instantly as well pushes the
Knight now again this is a line This is
a position these are ideas that we've
been looking at uh so we see them being
played out and here the move that you
came up with was the bishop Retreat uh
simply to be seven taking advantage of
that pin on the long diagonal not really
moving anywhere with the Knight allowing
a queen H3 to come in so Bishop B7 is
that still what we're expecting from
ding here
I think it's the only move to be honest
I don't know Robert do you see any a
sensible alternative at this point
no I mean Bishop B7 is the only way not
to just lose a piece
um if you're going to sacrifice a piece
maybe there's some clever way to do so
but Bishop B7 does feel automatic for
janapamshi and
um I mean now that you ask the question
I'm just trying to come up with any
sensible move Knight H4 doesn't
determine yeah but it looks looks pretty
awful I mean at least include Bishop B7
and then after Rook H3 or D7 then you
can play Knight H4 so realistically I
think it's the it's the only move yeah
Knight H4 I mean it maybe doesn't lose
on the spot but even Queen G3 is an
option
I think it probably loses on the spots
to be honest as well it looks awful
because after Knight H4 Queen G3 hits
Knight hits Pawn also what's wrong with
just a move like G5 at some point to
give yourself the F6 square but why even
risk it yeah I wanted to start
and 10 G5 oh wow I made a mistake
what a surprise
because like this Pawn is also gonna
fall and yeah I thought this was the the
Finish area maybe I should have reversed
the order yeah yeah but doctor could you
see I missed some resources oh Bishop is
Bishop B7 Bishop B7 Maybe
and G5 maybe
um
trying to figure out as well yeah G5
somehow saves it not an easy move to
play by the way with your king already
exposed but the point is it defends this
Knight if white starts taking Pawns in
the center uh black can play this move
F6 here and this E6 Pawn unfortunately
is Untouchable because the last thing
you want to do is open lines in front of
your own King you see the eval bar uh
suggest black would be completely
winning at this point because the king
is wide open and there are going to be
pins and that's a problem
but G5 first indeed was probably the way
to go and Jan plays the most natural
move Bishop B7 again it's not
necessarily that you have to see why
another short loses but is that Bishop
B7 is a good way to start the bishop on
A6 serves zero purpose a mission p7 is a
double X slam there by kind teachers.com
uh whatever whoever that person is who
gives this exclamation Much must be a
very busy person by the way sitting in
that booth and continuously giving
exclamation marks to all kind of
different players must be a busy job
there but yes double slam their um by
chase.com uh and uh now ding has to
choose and next move you can play
another short if you want having
improved your Bishop but I suspect the
Knight will stay on the five for quite a
while no need to move it just yet
and Knight H4 is just such a hard move
to play and as we see Bishop B7 is a
brilliant move it's the only move that
kept the balance every other move gave
white a huge Advantage but just in
general Knight H4 is so difficult it
actually there's one variation I'm
thinking about your line from before
with D7 I I just want to look at
something very very quickly here uh that
if we go forward with this move Queen
here I think we said Rook D2 Rook d8 we
need to move this Rook eventually off
the pin so like you please move Knight
H4 at long last is there an issue with
G5 and just trying to bring my knight to
F6 I know it won't be so easy with the
bishop slicing down the board but bear
with me for a second Anish can I go full
uh exchange sacrifice and bring my
knight to F6 how does this look
no I see I see what you're doing
um
I see what you're doing and this could
be really really good
maybe black here will actually just go
out of the way and just force
um Force to return the material with
Rook of four Rook takes F6
because I definitely see the point with
Knight and F6 and the Paul 97
oh wow this is actually not the way oh
is it Queen no no 26 Queen to six yeah
trying to get this Knight here
where is the win here is it just simple
chest like can I yeah you can attack the
E5 Pawn Rook f625 I don't get to exactly
I don't I don't get to return the
material I'm just gonna put it there
just yeah I missed that internet so this
is incredible actually very beautiful
yikes wow
yeah Robert this is a construction of
Knight and F6 is so beautiful because uh
not only are you sort of setting up a
mating net you also uh you you also
defend the D7 Pawn so it's very nice but
ding has played your move Rook H3
nice nice choice there
the real Cliff that you've been talking
about Robert for quite a while in this
game I think it was at least five moves
ago that you mentioned this plan we
often think about lining up the queen
and the Rook with the queen in front to
give a mate we're very often in position
The Rook in front of the queen can be
equally powerful especially uh when
you're trying to combine all these
attacking ideas uh along the light
squares and the attack on Black's pieces
well the chess is definitely heating up
here and also on our Blitz arena in our
play zone because this Saturday for our
viewers you can't miss the chance to
play in The Blitz Arena that's being
hosted
fan club you can compete against fellow
fans of the video World Championship
Challenger with a chance to win a
diamond membership so you've got to join
the fan club to enter the arena use the
command uh exclamation mark Yan in chat
for details see you on Saturday that's
gonna be a fun one don't miss out on
that right now singular and fans are on
the edge of their seat as the game is
heating up rook H3 has been played both
players have left their chairs to play
we will be back on the other side of
this break
[Music]
thank you
I do recommend Meetup to a lot of my
friends that are looking for different
things wine tasting movies book clubs
meet a lot of new people a lot of new
friends and it make you more social
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
unceasing dominance move after move
again and again and again we have a
recitation we have history he is the
five-time fide World chess champion
but a chess Dynasty can also be cruel it
forces most to defer their dreams until
next time if there is a next time oh my
god did he just block yeah he did I'm
Blown Away the game is over
as the Chess World Turns to Kazakhstan
the Magnus Carlson Dynasty is set to
close
the feed a world championship is finally
up for grabs
for two chess Superstars lying in wait
until next time is now
has methodically done what he needed to
do to get another shot at the title the
pressure to seize the moment this time
rests heavily upon Him thing freezes and
Yan pounces on the opportunity with
Precision taking the lead once again in
the world championship match
dingley Wren knows firsthand what the
end of this dynasty means an unexpected
chance to make history
can China's best turn his Good Fortune
into Eternal Thane
this is like what a collapse looks like
the legacy of this championship's fans
across centuries it reads from the names
of Chess Giants
for the first time in a decade a new
name will raise the trophy and be etched
into chess history
it's the 2023 feed a world championship
whose name will next be called champion
[Music]
contemplates his move number 21 in the
game eight of the world championship
match this is the biggest stage the
biggest moment of the career for Jana
abomishi and dengler and as they fight
for their dream to become the world
champion it is a critical position in
game eight with dingler and currently
Trails Yan by a point in the match but a
game that anything can happen all three
results are possible the last move by
thing a rook lift to H3 just
sidestepping The Rook from that Bishop
diagonal and now Yan's Knight on F5 is
under Fire G takes F5 is a real threat
on the board and of course also always
eyeing a doubling up on the H file you
could either push the F Pawn slide up
with that Rook to A2 bring it to H2 join
the attack or one can Envision the queen
coming up onto the H file to bring on
and pile on the pressure on a Black's
King
has to navigate at all these
possibilities the first big question is
do you move the Knight is Knight H4 the
only move in the position or is there an
alternative that Jan can be considering
right now Anish what would you play as
black here
yeah I think a huge huge uh Junction
here a big important moment even Jan is
taking his time here because
it's very tempting to get rid of the
disrespondent for good as you can take
on e4 and take on the six play F6 and
then Knight F7 like this variation
screams at you
and it screams to be considered
and
to meet someone screams to be played as
well but maybe not to everybody's taste
there is some danger here with the H
file so this is one option and it's a
big one that Jan has to consider
there are also other other options uh of
course and Anish can I just pause you
for a second
I think as you're saying this is the
main one of the main lines that Jan is
considering and he can visualize this
quite easily but evaluating it is the
hard part right you get here in your
head you're up a pawn is black but your
king is unsafe especially if this Rook
lands next to it so is this what he's
really doing is he's picturing this
position in his head and going through
all of the possibilities
yeah because the danger is obvious if
the Bishop from F1 was to magically land
on like G6 it will be all over so you
know you are like one one Strong
attacking move away from uh from the
edge here with black
and also you don't have a clear
follow-up with black let's say white
plays F4
it's not like black has an immediate way
to resolve
um the potential problems I mean the
problems are very potential but they
could come I mean Rook the two Bishop D3
or queen H3 Rook H2 there are various
ways of trying to get a rook de Turok D3
Rook dh3 another way as well to yeah I
think the more I look at it actually the
less I trust this because black doesn't
have a way to get rid of the problem
along the way the idea is gone he is
stuck on F7 black has to be really
drastic here maybe some g26 G27 G5 some
something like that but it's very very
dangerous for black and the alternatives
are well I think sacrificing the Knight
is a little too much
a little too much
um so I guess Knight H4 in the starting
position that we have right now on the
board I think Knight H4 Maybe
is the other attempting move and then
you mentioned this G5 but it was a
different version you already mentioned
G5 here is also a move a G5 maybe Rook
h8 uh okay and finally let's let's look
at this
the sacrifices of the night just to be
sure we have all the options covered so
if if you had to sacrifice night how
would we do it or do you think Tanya
oh wow that was a really tough question
the sacrifice the night and how to do it
if you have to give up the night maybe
just offer a rook trade rotate it and
let's say if you were to take on F5 I
know one thing I'll take with the epon
yeah yes
wow it actually oh wow because I'm
impressed right in this but this is
another one of these situations where
when we're watching as commentators or
spectators at home you're like oh yeah
black is fine when you're at the board
you're like black is down a piece for
just a couple of Pawns and is this
enough and I don't know Anish when I
first look at this position I feel like
I wouldn't want any part of this from
the black side well I know myself and I
can tell this is uh I would 100 not do
this with like like I would 100 not do
this because uh
I mean unless I know it's good and then
I can justify why it's good because you
are kicking your night away I'm going to
surround your deep on after Queen H4 and
Rook d8 your pieces are very passive
blah blah blah and the Deep one is alone
like a soldier in the field without any
backup it's going to eventually be lost
I don't even have to capture it quickly
and I can you know make sense of all of
this of course because I'm good at
talking crap but in reality I would
never do this um I would never do this
okay Bishop F5 don't blunder yeah on my
behalf please
so uh
but uh yeah no this is too risky for for
black uh only player extremely confident
um in Dynamic positions with such
material imbalance could do this so I
suspect the main choice here is between
Bishop E4 and Knight H4 these are the
most like most likely moveset is nice
Ayan is capable of that though Yan is
one player who is capable of going for
move like ruke he's very confident
in himself and in his positions always
so whenever he has an unbalanced
position
he's always on the optimistic side
seeing all the pluses of his positions
and not worrying about the minuses so if
anyone that's young who is capable of
um ushering rookette shade but I am
really not sure and uh yeah a nice nice
moment for Jan to take his time and I'm
glad that for a change we are witnessing
Jan's thinking process and are not you
know restricted to ding um being the
only one thinking the entire game now
it's a nice moment for Jan to go into a
tank finally he he has a problem to
solve here
yeah I would be amazed and awestruck at
the same time Aviana actually decides to
sacrifice the Knight on F5 the most
natural response to me that just looking
at this position just like you've got to
move the Knight now why does just
sidestep the pin GTX F5 is a big threat
and you gotta move the Knight Knight 86
just feels like a very ugly move to make
I don't know if it's good or bad but
Knight H4 and then these ideas of G5
that we've been looking at in some other
variations trying to just consolidate
the position well if white doesn't play
G5 I think black would be happy maybe to
get G5 in uh looking at this position
the one question I want to ask from a
more generic from a more General point
of view is that we look at the king
placement right white is also going for
black skin but it's the white king
that's in the center of the board and
we've seen these lines where if certain
liquidation does happen especially in
the variation that we were looking at
with Knight F7 at the end it just felt
like white skin also might be on the
fire but who's King safety Are we more
worried about currently is it is it
Jan's king or is it dings King right now
I'll gladly take this question it's
definitely Jan's King in fact the lines
we've looked at I we have the eval bar
telling us ah Black's doing fine every
single line we've looked at
aesthetically looks great for white like
I think that Jan is staring at this
position at his options to think I'm in
trouble I think he actually believes
that he's in danger because he is a
fantastic player obviously he's the
number two rated player in the world
he's won the candidates twice in a row
you can't say enough good things about
his chest but when you are sitting in
that seat not from the comfort of a
commentator's chair not with the
evaluation bar at your side you're like
wait a second let me just to bring up an
analysis board and show that again like
we're looking at some of these lines
this looks terrible to my eyes if your
best idea is to play Knight F7 and then
go here as Anisha you can just play the
move F4 I wouldn't be surprised if you
could throw in Bishop G2 and try to
bring your Bishop to E4 if one Pawn push
happens if this Pawn goes here or this
Pawn goes here you're like immediately
lost so I I feel like you know you're on
the precipice and it's likely you're
going to be pushed off so I would not
want any part of this position and
alternatively speaking we're looking at
this kind of position the Knight coming
into F6 that doesn't look very good like
what about this
I'm curious now if you take it right I
was thinking about exactly that uh yeah
I was calculating this line just for fun
Bishop before Queen E4
um
yeah so sorry also Bishop before
actually Rook H4 I was also considering
to be honest okay I was trying to take
the bishop but yeah 25 is also possible
then I think I thought about yeah
um
yeah I thought also get sure was
interesting yeah but I'm not sure
because the idea is that after rookie
for Queen H4 I attacked the bishop then
I wanted to bring the Rook back to the
two and the queen back to G3 I was
thinking about it
I wasn't sure what to think of that but
look kind of interesting for white it
says even but as we keep saying I mean
this looks like white has the advantage
I I just look at every position we've
analyzed this far I think it's much more
difficult for black to keep steady and
defend here even if the eval Bar says it
I mean Yan will have to prove it every
single turn
and one point I want to make about the
uncastled king in general
because we always think of a castle as a
way to safeguard the king
but I have uh I have an alternative uh
alternative view on this I think the
castle is actually in very often not the
way not necessarily done with the idea
to safeguard the king but it's a way to
develop The Rook because very often the
king is
not too much uh not too unsafe in the
center and sometimes it's okay on F1 as
well
and what you often see is the castle is
needed to bring these Rooks out of the
out of their corners but once you
already have a rook developed on the H
file the other Rook uh making its way
VIA A2 to D2
you don't actually need the king
um to Castle in fact if I think about
this position
I mean you could argue the king is
certainly safer uh in the center than it
is on the king side if it was beyond G1
and
it's arguable if it's safer on E1 than
it's somewhere on B1 but the B let's say
the pawn shelter on the queen side is
also damaged so
um yeah the king safety doesn't have to
limit itself to whether one side has
castled or not that's for sure not the
case and here it's also very important
which pieces are around the white king
so for now there are no pieces let's say
if you look at Rook h8 let's look at
that on the board because it's also
possible that it occurs let's say Luke
takes h8 Queen takes h8 GF EF
already afterwards say night
um
G3 Queen H4 for example
as my queen gets and the bishop get a
bit closer to the king maybe then the
king safety becomes more of a factor for
white but uh let's say let's just for
argument's sake make the move Queen F4
next and just to show that at least I
can already give a check you know
um or let's say Okay um yeah yeah I can
give a check let's say and so the king
starts to feel a little less secure than
it than it was uh just a few months ago
so it's also very important you know
your king might be wide open because
there's no one to attack it it's all
good
so these are the other factors that are
important and I guess yes all in all is
Robert has pointed out black king is a
in danger right now although in a
position like this the situation of the
King City gets completely reversed I
don't know Robert if you are big in the
back house are you a big in the back
house uh you like big buck house chess I
do like bug house yeah
so I don't know if it's too much off
topic but I just want to point out so in
this Buck house uh there is this opening
so the buck house is the opening where
you are able to you play on two boards
and you play with the white pieces your
partner plays with the black pieces and
the pieces that you capture of your
opponent they go to your partner and he
can then Place us place them on the
board so what happens is that the value
of pieces is a little bit different
because of that because you can keep
placing pieces and initiative is very
important and King safety is like super
important in that game because your
attack runs very fast you don't only
attack with your pieces you can put put
your partner's pieces onto the attack
and so there were King safety matters a
lot one of the big openings is E4 Knight
F6 and we could maybe show it just to
demonstrate because it's actually
relevant to this game so E4 Knight F6
um E5 this is the elegant variation of
course normally you move the Knight but
in back house you ignore it like D5 use
of the move you play and after e takes
F6 it takes F6 you double your F bones
but then you castle kingside and these f
phones are really guarding the king very
well for a piece and this was kind of
similar situation with young he could
have sacrificed the Knight for this
double doubled F ones that would protect
his King very well but as as I'm giving
this useless species he just doesn't do
it and he just moved tonight to H4
instead and ding didn't even budge he
plays Pawn to G5 instantly and now young
will be back on the clock so we know Jan
likes to take his strolls go to his rest
area but I don't think there's any rest
for black here because your king is in
danger he may play Rook h8 here but
there's still so much to consider I mean
we we're talking about Queen G3 as a
response to Rook h8 uh I think Dingus
finding his confidence in this game yeah
it's Danny rash would say love it
I'm gonna say that dude love it it is
the kind of position that we would all
love to see because G5 blitzed that by
ding he hasn't opposed for a thought
there so showing some clarity some
confidence in the attack but once again
the Knight on H4 hangs I don't expect uh
I don't expect Yan to take too long to
make the move a rook to h8 and then once
again it will be a big question for ding
how does he want to continue but can Yan
also consider now that the F5 square is
awakened one more time to just fall back
with the Knight to F5 or is that too
dangerous with the potential doubling up
on the H file and the Knight jumping to
F6 is Knight F5 an option here
that's also what I was thinking Tanya
and I was about to suggest it because
the Rook h8 allows Queen G3 as you
pointed out where I would potentially
eliminate this this Knight and clarify
uh the position when my D6 Pawn would be
out of danger Knight F5 keeps the Deep
one in check still Bishop takes E4 and
queen D6 is an idea and I think Knight
to five is definitely definitely a move
to consider uh question is indeed
whether I can swing my Rook across from
the A2 uh
Square so maybe some F F Pawn action F3
maybe even F or
probably not but maybe who knows with
idea Rook a to H2 and then Knight F6
because if you play Knight F6 right away
uh of course you're always met with Rook
h8 you don't have any uh
you don't have any uh yeah defense did
you see that oh yeah Knight F5
apparently maybe it's not a good move I
love that idea of just pushing the F
Pawn and getting your other Rook to H to
just stopping Rook at chat
yeah I love it wow just
wow and that just shows that it's game
over after F4 yeah
it looked good yeah because after this
happens if you take here comes the queen
and you think oh I have enough pieces to
trade off guess what my happy pass
d-pawn will win the game because when we
swap everything off here there is D7 and
the King takes first and then D7 you
can't stop d8
so this would be a winning situation for
you yeah so let's let's yeah I mean
going back in the starting position uh
indeed uh Rook h8 is uh Rook h8 is
probably the move you need to need to
make because this Knight A5 F4 idea it's
too pretty never forget this A2 Rook
coming back into the attack
is probably the money move because you
you have okay you can also try and Sack
that Knight with Bishop E4 Queen G5 this
is another move
but I don't think it's it's enough no I
mean it's a pity a night a night of the
night I wouldn't give it up for nothing
yeah I guess that you're saying that
there's a check here on C1 and that
looks like an option for black but even
if I take this way you have one check
and yeah unfortunately I was more I was
more hoping that I have a bunch of Pawns
but um yeah you have you keep the d-pawn
alive and these pawns they're not like
you know they're not going forward and
no not enough of course I'm just looking
for an alternative I don't think there
is one Jan's probably in the resting
area used to the fact that Ding is
taking his time on obvious moves but
ding no longer doing that for now I'm
really happy with that because G5 was
obviously the only move but ding still
uh was taking time on those and I'm
really happy that Ding just says okay
you know I I see what you're doing you
are pre-moving I can also pre-move
so G5 G5 has been played quickly and
Rook h8 is a must and after Queen G3
Bishop before we'll have a fascinating
uh fascinating Choice here for ding I I
like this option of Rook H4 because it
gives full clarity like you don't have
any peace anymore that can jump and I
can go like route to two queen just 325
but then the problem is that my light
Square Bishop it's of course
um
I cannot touch anything I still have
ideas though there with F4 Rook H2 and
this looks really tempting to me to take
this Knight but uh also interesting is
what you said Queen E5
that's also possible although I I would
be hesitant to allow Knight to F5 back
because I think maybe the night one day
can
can win this D6 spawn
2016 is a nice one though here
oh oh this is a painful one
yeah 95 also remember seven yeah that's
nasty your King has to go back to the
last Rank and then you win this Rook for
free and that's game over it's funny
Anish I think this was a stylistic thing
I wanted the bishop against the Knight
that's what I was really thinking about
when I wanted to take on uh in this
point when I want to take on E5 I was
like okay I just get the bishop I don't
think you're gonna get my Pawn I'll
bring my Rook over but yeah maybe the
Knight does hop back in because the
evaluation Bar says it's zero somehow
and I think the evaluation bar was
saying they are kind of equal in value
these two moves I mean I would start
with the Rook H4 option uh maybe because
it's really clean and clear-cut in a
sense uh like it's very easy to
calculate it further I used to take on
H4 I will take back you should drop the
bishop back then I bring the room to D2
nothing is jumping but
yeah if blackout probably has resources
but of course if you allow me Queen G3
Queen if I have a four Oak H2 you will
lose maybe you have resources here
of resources check out this fun line
again don't know if it works or not but
I'm going to give it a go
Al instead of Bishop C6 if you just get
a
just you know a little well not precise
and move it to B7 Bishop B7
and we've been talking about peace
activity and giving checkmates but
suddenly there is this line where there
is another Pawn on the boat that could
become decisive so let's go F4
you take on F4
I go Rook H2 double up
I'll trade everything and guess what I'm
gonna win by queening I go D7 game over
yeah another variation where the d-pawn
strikes I mean just such a thorn in
Black side
is that a saying winning by queening uh
because I think it's winning by pinning
no no I think the saying by queening
also is saying or is this one now
okay okay I don't know like if there is
Authority that
um that determines you know what sayings
are like real and which are are fake but
I hope for you that winning by queening
will be added as well because I think if
if anything winning bike winning happens
much more often than winning by pinning
because by opinion yeah
contribution yeah it's a more definite
result but maybe after Queen H4 then
also the ideas of stopping the F Pawn
from going forward and doubling up on
the H file a bishop C6 stopping the D7
Advance maybe bishop F3 stopping the F
Pawn from uh advancing as well I also
like the square Bishop F3 and maybe
after Queen G3 I can just go E4
defending my pawn and the bishop and if
you're not checkmating me then I'm
gonna yeah this one that you have
stopped the F uh the F Pawn from moving
and The Rook cannot swing across at all
my Rook is stuck now on the left side of
the board I love that
yeah although I'm happy that my past
Pawn is easy to protect uh I feel like
at some point I'll just play Bishop E2
and trade and I don't see an active plan
for black but maybe you don't really
need one maybe just uh sit and say
you're not gonna make any progress uh
because one idea that just came to mind
was if you went backwards this is why I
like Tony is Bishop F3 could I just
throw in this check and just try to
Checkmate you immediately like how are
you gonna stop this
another saying before you take over
winning by check meeting
definitely should be a saying but it
doesn't even rhyme I mean at least the
previous one right I think we are you
know it's it's fired us out of control
completely now Tanya is making up things
that don't even rhyme I think maybe
somebody has to put an end to this like
this is completely
but I mean this position is getting out
of control for black right like this is
just your king is being hunted and the
only way to stop check Miss probably by
giving away this Pawn Center and that
looks terrible
yeah dangerous dangerous because if we
trade Queens with queen of Fates uh
well the protected passer is uh
is scary because it will never be able
to ever attack or capture it because the
pawns are on the dark Square the bishop
is on the light Square
it also Rhymes by the way uh it's also
saying the Bishops on light squares
becomes attack the dark squares so
that's also a problem
because you've just used the same word
at the end
have you ever heard like Nicki Minaj
songs that's always the
so the last thing I expected was for
Anish giri to be talking about Nicki
Minaj
she retired at some point but I was a
big fan I always liked how she made
these uh these verses where she would
rhyme uh like she would use like the
same word in like three lines in a row
and it would still sound Epic so I'm a
big fan okay we have to ask for the fans
what is your favorite Nicki Minaj song
oh that's a great question you put me on
this spot and also I think the the names
of these songs are usually so
inappropriate that I think I like it was
a family friendly showing exactly
exactly exactly okay we'll we'll take
this you know off like there's one
called Super Bass but I mean like it's
very tricky very tricky stuff don't uh
ever call me out on that
I wasn't expecting that
beloved it's a great song also the other
one I came to win I came to fly it's
another great way exactly exactly this
is actually even better it's even better
but I think the one where she uh says
the same word three times in a row I
think that's probably from the Super
Bass but I don't remember for sure I
have to I have to brush up on my I mean
I didn't listen to it for years but
suddenly it occurred to me you know it
occurred to me this is the greatness
it's like these games you know they'll
go down in just history and in moments
you don't expect they will pop up in
your memory and that that's that's what
Classics are essentially
you know when we're in Dutch chat can
always help us so Chad can tell us what
song you're talking about and I'm sure
when the commentators don't know chat
always knows
I just can't believe we're talking about
Nicki Minaj right now I just wouldn't
have expected it if Danny wrench were
here yeah no Nicki Minaj is going to be
talked about but Anish you uh surprised
me every day it seems and well are you
surprised that Jan is so deep in the
think tank here because the clock is
about to even up and White's position
does seem much easier to play and it
starts to slowly slowly the Contours of
a masterpiece are emerging this deep on
uh on D6 the dark squares around the
black king the domination you know the
dark squares I slowly I slowly feel um
The Contours of a masterpiece um are
appearing and uh Jan is feeling that as
well so he he is doubting he's dropping
on the clock they've almost caught up
surprisingly uh Jan is having this one
long thing is it almost uh caught up
with with digging and uh yeah well I I
really like Black's position if not for
the bar I would be already very very
very concerned with black everything
bothers me Rook H4 uh after Queen just
Rebellion also Queen E5 uh bothered me
as well
uh to be honest I mean I I was telling
you about tonight coming to F5 but the
more I was talking the less I was seeing
I didn't like there was some lack of
coordination in Black's pieces I felt
the deepon is uh starts looking very
firmly protected
I'm a little uh uh more than a little
concern for Yan and if not for the bar
yeah I would think that his position is
critical I'm not laughing at your news
but Fabiano getting involved and seeing
his favorite is Anaconda and so I was
thinking about that song but I was
purposely not gonna talk about it but if
Bobby talks about it on a live broadcast
then everyone can talk yeah five is also
a man of culture yeah
expecting
it yeah on my on my anaconda um
wait wait wait he just took me he
panicked I told you I told you I didn't
like the position he thought he's
already lost he thought he's already
lost I told you
oh my gosh leading
no we we definitely all agreed on that
but is he going for this night sacrifice
line you talked about or is he just
gonna bring his Knight back but either
way we can see that the position is
getting very very bad for black this
Pawn on D6 is not going anywhere E5 is
hanging with check the H file is still
open my goodness oh I think he blundered
because he probably wants Knight F5 and
I don't immediately see why it loses but
probably it's a blunder of sorts
um wow do you see why it loses already
or so is it F4 again
is it a transport or not or is different
F4 wow I mean there's so many options
here yeah Queenie 5f6 of course is the
is the tempting one but um I'm looking
at a
four
so we need so quick let's just show that
very quickly yeah Queen E5 F6 and just
to show anisha's point that trading off
pieces is not going to go well for white
the king in the center Tanya you called
it out a long time ago not the safest
King in the world now that the board is
opening up and you can bring your queen
to H2 but black will play Rook 8 shade
and counter along the HR the d-pawn
still exists which gives white some good
play but there's problems brewing in
this position with loose pawns and the
king is weak so Knight F5 uh wow do you
see how quickly ding played Rook D2 why
is so fast we have a it's the best move
yeah wow yeah
we have a confident dig right now
everyone it's going to open up the more
depth the engine gets the more it
approves of Rook D2 and those are the
type of waiting moves that are so easy
to miss in chess let's just take a step
back for my moment here so fast
yeah you could take on E5 with check you
could bring your queen to the a trial
try to attack the king that wasn't going
to work out but he does not take on E5
he doesn't even calculate it very much
he simply slides his Rook over to D2 he
keeps the board a little more close he
keeps all of the pluses in his position
namely this Pawn on D6 you can't take it
because very simply Queen E5 check wins
a piece on the spot Rook D2 is just a
nasty move and this is hanging D7 is
next what is so why is this all this I
don't I don't understand so I mean I of
course understand the Deep one and the
Kings and all that is all nice but uh
Queen G5 so why is it so it's what you
said before Watch What Happens Queen E5
F6 first of all
oh my gosh there it goes okay and d8
equals Queen and ding has seen this all
I feel very confident that Ding has seen
the conclusion he gives up his Queen to
get a new one and the Monarch will reign
and unfortunately for
Beyond the Palm Street I mean this is
just lost at this point yeah but this is
uh well there are two tactics uh Queen
E5 can have six Rook H7 and queen E5 F6
Queen H2 and Rook takes a shade Queen
xh8 and Yan probably means the harder
one but uh this is over of course once
you maintain the G5 Pawn and you
maintain the this exponent and queen E5
comes uh I mean this this is uh lost no
this language 525 is brilliant the ding
has seen it but he plays so fast
this reminds me of uh the London game
where he won D5 and then he eventually
set up that mate and D5 was a critical
move in the line that we just saw with
the Rook on D2 it's so important to get
that in so that the Queens cannot jump
over to C1 and give a check at the end
and suddenly after Rook D2 all these
tactics work out where you can end up
queening the pawn because you're
defending the D7 Pawn but also your own
King from checks this is nasty and very
devious stuff that Ding has just set up
it's incredible I mean this match this
match is completely completely
incredible and I have to say by the way
the reason he plays so fast is because
we are here uh looking at our own things
with our own moves
um but of course Bishop takes E4 and
Knight F and Knight F5 it is a very very
uh reasonable response an attempt to get
rid of this bind by Yan so it's more
than logical that Ding was also thinking
about it for all this time and queen E5
F6 looked unclear to him of course and
then he spotted Rook D2 already uh so he
saw it all coming in uh for a long time
already so that's why he played it so
quickly probably because you cannot like
find Rook between an instant he must
have thought about it already before a
really
um really very impressive and also so
uncharacteristic of so far suddenly he
plays it instantly confidence is back
yeah no this is really ding right back
in the match and I think at this point I
mean I hate to call a game over before
it's over but you can just sense it
right ding knows that he has this game
in the bag because black has no counter
punches there's not even a threat in the
position Queen takes E5 looks
Unstoppable and with so many ideas of
sacrificing your queen for a rook that
lands on h8 because of your past Pawn I
mean I just don't see any way for yon to
even keep competing and I just want to
take a step back like you did I think
that's really good for everyone watching
to recognize that in this position here
it's starting to look terrible Anish
made this comment himself it has the
Contours of a masterpiece with white
controlling all the squares the dark
squares with a bind and Knight could
land on F6 this is a past Pawn that can
go up to the seventh rank at any moment
so I understand the impulse to get that
Knight out of there and what yon
undoubtedly was thinking about was Queen
takes E5 that is the obvious move if
they're playing bullet you simply take a
free Pawn with check then move F6 is
played and now after a move like Queen
H2 you could maybe even take this Pawn
you can play Rook h8 to trade off and
the point is this D6 Pawn will not be
that long for this board it's going to
fall under attack and black will likely
be able to keep putting pressure on it
so I think that John's decision makes
sense but it was an oversight because of
a quiet move often the easiest move to
miss and chess a quiet Rook move like
this to D2
but you know how deep it is uh
sorry but look it's not only uh that you
have to see Rook D2 a quiet move you
also have to see the entire line behind
it and uh that is Queen G5 Queen E5 F6
Queen historical D7 and it is so easy to
miss with black I mean this is not your
usual kind of you know like one move
blunder this is like a understandable
deep oversight
because
of course I mean if you're calculating
with the black pieces and you are in
trouble and as I already told you before
with this bar it's I was never buying it
I mean I thought like if I would be
thinking with black in that position I
would think that maybe I'm already a
lost or something I don't know like it
looked all looked very bad like
borderline like lost it's not not even
just bad I was very worried for black
there I didn't even hide it at that
point but um Jans he was counting on
this uh idea and he saw Queen E5 F6
which was pretty good he probably made
sure F4 Queen H1 don't win on the spot
and Rook D2 I guess on the back of his
mind he thought he will take the pawn on
G5 Queen E5 he had to Sequin F6 Rook H7
of course which is also a tactic you
could miss from afar from a very from
afar of course yeah not once you get
there it's quite easy but you could also
have thought okay I have F6 you cannot
take only six if Queen H2 I have always
ricocheted and so it's uh understandable
that he might have just missed the
entire thing and remarkably his position
it collapses because indeed everything
hangs on this quintess G5 move and one
more thing I want to point out is that
Knight H6 here in this position it loses
also to f 4 on the spot as well so
there's no way to even continue the game
and in the starting position yeah there
is just no move because okay let's say
Rook h8 maybe maybe Rook h8 you can try
maybe that is your only
um only chance but then even even these
seven I suspect is very good Rook H3
Bishop H3 and uh or I have Queen E5
after Rook B8 and after threaten Queen
A8 I think like your whole position it
hangs on Queen takes G5 and this kind of
stuff to work
but if it doesn't if Queen G5 doesn't
work then you just get lost here
yeah wow Yan with a seven minute thing
one gets the feeling that he's really
realizing it at this moment all these
dangers that exist and how close this
game is to just think taking it away and
equalizing the match yeah knows now that
it's all gone wrong you see a complete
shift in him he's gone into a bit into a
big thing but it's not gonna help
anymore
Queen G5 Queen G5 loses on the spot with
the tactics that we just saw Rook het
keeps the game going for a bit longer uh
is there a third option that Yan can be
looking at and he's feeling the tension
saying Lawrence staring at a third
comeback in this match just amazing
stuff he makes a move and he goes for
Rook to Edge it
yeah no he's just trying but I think
that dingley red he he knows it's over
and D7 is a pretty straightforward move
you're pushing your Pawn one square
closer to promotion it allows you to win
this Pawn E5 later he could probably
take it now and still be well ahead but
push your pass Pawn threaten the
sacrifice in the corner and Anish you
call this very early that it looks like
Jana Palm she mixed up his move order
and that cost him dearly in this game
the fact that he still is a Pawn on C5
and white still has this Pawn on C3 that
may look beneficial in terms of Pawn
structure but if we can go way back to
the opening that was the critical error
for yonda Palm Desi that way back around
here when H4 was played had he taken
first on D4 change the pawn structure so
that once we got to this position their
E5 was not as threatening you see the
evaluation plummet in Black's favor he
maybe made a mistake with his opening
preparation not throwing in C takes D4
and it is costing him it didn't loosen
the game objectively speaking but I
think it put him in unfamiliar and
uncomfortable territory
definitely and one other mistake I want
to point out I mean from a practical
Viewpoint so the moment where I shifted
from feeling that position is double
edged to where I thought it looks bad
for black like from from my eye I
personally I I feel this uh moment after
G4 was vital I didn't like the short
text E4 uh and Knight D6 any longer it
was a bishop B7 yeah Rook H3 Rook HD was
by the way brilliant move of course
Turkish 3 was a big blow to Yan he
missed it I no longer like Bishop E4
either because it looks extremely
dangerous the position with Rook on H7
which we talked about I didn't like the
look of Knight H4 yeah this one at Rook
H7 King j8 and let's say F4 it is just
smells very bad like this smells very
bad to me looks very dangerous I
understand yeah I'm not going for it I
uh Knight H4 G5 Rook h8 which is uh
the way to keep the bar happy instead of
this uh also looks really bad to me to
be honest I I mean maybe it's just me
but I can I think for two players it
also looks bad which is why Jan didn't
do it in fact the move that that Jan the
right move from a practical Viewpoint
and the brilliant one and the one uh
with which Jank would have taken over
the initiative it was rookie immediately
that China suggested here in sort of
Knight H4
uh okay I kind of forced Anya to find to
find it in a sense like it's not like
she just suggested it I told her how do
you suck the piece and she was forced to
suck the piece what kind of a compliment
was that you took it and then you you
gave it and then you just took it away
and I'm really sorry no but just just
you know not not to not to uh over
overdo it of course and uh you know and
completely
um over flatter uh or flatter you there
but of course no it was ruke it was a
brilliant move that you that you
mentioned
um I just want to take some of the
credit myself like I was also thinking
I mean we talked about this earlier
right even this peace sacrifice yes the
engine saying yeah Black's just level I
mean look at this position white is up a
piece for two pawns and white is the one
with the most impressive Pawn on the
board of course it doesn't be winning
for whites it could be winning for
whites but this is one position that the
more the more I look at it the more I
like black well the other ones the more
I looked at them the more I liked white
so this was this is kind of the
difference but of course not I mean from
afar like if you told me this is lost
for black I'd be like yeah of course the
Deep one and the p in pieces but if you
if you dig deeper the Deep on it's kind
of neutralized but of course yeah you
cannot find this stuff um
but uh today today uh was not the day
and what he played was a decent attempt
but he completely overlooked this
through the two and now we'll catch it I
have to say that after catch it by the
way D7 I think the the move um the movie
you have to review this queen takes G5
you have to refute this move and I think
one way to do it is Queen E5 check
uh F6 is forced
I think Rook takes h8 is probably the
most accurate
so does Queen C7 Rook hd8 I think right
exactly yeah it's just kind of it's
isn't the transposition
yeah
it's a direct transfer right so you
taught me how to win once the night went
well but guys it's a direct
transposition to it's just a different
mover of the queen G5 thank you coach
thank you coach Geary
it's all winning I mean D7 just wins on
the spot thing just takes his time
because he can uh this is just
completely hopeless isn't it this
position but the big question is this
way to win or does ding have the luxury
to find other moves and still be better
off or does he need to be super precise
right now
but why is it super precise just the
Deep one it has to promote make one step
one step come one step closer what is
there to what is there to think maybe he
sees some resource
[Music]
yeah of course then F6 again you have
that issue of F6 no but this uh suddenly
gets completely completely back
um
really back
it's exactly what yawn needs right he
needs some sort of play for himself and
we see the evil bar reacting but I think
also from a practical feel this you know
gets you back in the game
just just to show that this would not
work because black takes here at the end
and D6 is loose
duper critical moment oh
to do is
is winning game eight he's thinking he's
calculating his way will he make the
move or not we will find that on the
other side of this break we'll be right
back
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
everybody International Master Danny
wrench here chess.com's Chief chess
officer we are here and excited to be
collaborating and partnering with World
Quant as an official partner of the
champions tour in the year 2023 I'm now
speaking with Chief strategy officer for
World Quant natish mining the people
have met us and now time for the big
questions jumping right into the basics
tell everybody a little more about world
Quant and what exactly is it that world
quad does thank you for having me Danny
and you already introduced me I'm the
chief strategy officer at World Quant
World Quant is a global asset management
organization it was founded by Igor
tulcinski in 2007. World Quant today has
over 850 employees who are working
towards designing investment strategies
in multiple asset class across Global
markets World Quant believes in
empowering the ideas of the talent
across the globe and we have 23 offices
in 13 countries today amazing amazing
stuff so tell us now a little bit more
about this project called World Quant
brain so worldcoin is built on the
belief that Talent is global but
opportunity is not and we strive to take
this opportunity to everyone around the
globe world Quant brain has been
designed as a tool which empowers us to
take that opportunity to anyone that's
fantastic seriously that's amazing I I
had no idea about that learning about
this along with our viewers and
obviously as a as a website and a
company with a mission to also connect
Global communities and increase the
opportunity for chess that makes it even
more of a natural partnership tell me a
little bit more from World quads
perspective why you guys run the ITC so
World Quant has this mission of
democratizing quantitative finance and
international Quant Championship is one
of the tools we have to spread the
message about this operator opportunity
which World point is offering to
everyone to be a Quant in the world of
in the quantitative space and
international Quant Championship
empowers the individuals to utilize
their ideas and show that they can do it
and gives us an opportunity to take this
message to them wherever they are that's
great now you said the finals will be in
person was I right that it'll be in the
Bahamas that sounds like a pretty great
location can I come yeah absolutely
absolutely and I can okay so I don't
know that I'm qualified to be in the iqc
but uh tell everybody a little more so
the finals are going to be in the
Bahamas what will that be like for those
who make it yes so the finals as you
said is planned to be in Bahamas for the
iqc so worldcoin celebrated its 15th
anniversary last year in 2022 to
celebrate that occasion we are getting
the whole world Quant organization
together in Bahamas this year and we
decided that we will organize the finals
of iqc at that event so this will give
an opportunity to our finalists to meet
the world quantity in person it will
give them an opportunity to watch the
culture and rigor of the organization
and we are very excited that everybody
will be able to get together at that
event in Bahamas well this has been
awesome nitish thank you so much this is
where I remind everybody it's their
chance to get involved in the iqc the
international quad Championship you can
use the command iqc you can visit the
world Quant brain website we encourage
you to do so ASAP registration is open
until May so it's time to jump in and
maybe you'll get to meet the CSO and
others in the Bahamas maybe I'll be
there I don't if I'm lucky I don't know
but it sounds like a great time either
way and the Tish uh the Chess World and
the Champions chess tour thanks World
Quant for their partnership and we're
looking forward to the rest of the year
together thank you Danny and good luck
to the community for participating in
iqc
thank you
[Music]
England has to make 15 moves to make
time control but it looks like we won't
even have another 15 moves the way the
game is going his last move trades on h8
we see that Jana punishi walks back to
the board Jana bamashi is in big trouble
as dingler and deepon is all set to
advance he is ready to bring the Rook to
the H file guys we were looking at the
move D7 but ding chose the alternative
Rook hitch it our eval bar still
approves where is the killer blow he
goes for D7 so Queen A8 is a big threat
right now
oh wow yeah but uh
this is also win because I I think the
winning move was Rook D3
the winner was Rook G3 which after Rook
takes h8
during the break I had a look at this I
saw what the computer was saying so I
saw the computer okay was actually the
first line and it was actually a very
elegant solution because it read the new
look h325 and probably with D7
the way I'm seeing it is okay you can
play Rook d8
and after Rook uh now after Rook D3
you're no longer have Queen takes A8
after let's say King f8 so this is not
exactly the same maybe this is still
good for white
what if you just take the pawn and yeah
take the pawn yes but I'm just playing
uh well I guess it's the same maybe King
H7
yeah I don't know can I just do this oh
that's a mistake
yeah it's is it somehow related to these
checks down here
yeah I think you're messing it up I
think he's messing it up
oh my God
montage is actually dropped now so he
gives a check on E5 King it's seven
yeah you might have missed image seven
because King G8 is bad but King H7 is
better because after Queen H2 I'm going
King G7 and I never go to G8 so I never
give you this queen to seven Tempo but I
get Quincy seven because if you go here
I check you first and then you go back
now Queen C7 yeah okay Queen takes C3
okay okay I see I see but at least what
I meant to say that I wanted some time
with black because I can now play a move
but maybe you mean that the move doesn't
help me well maybe I can at least bring
the queen to f8
um
maybe you are winning still let's say if
yeah some move
yeah I want to do your sort of Checkmate
attack that's what I mean seven F6 then
yeah you have to be fast
maybe F4 as well as an option
but you said Queen E7 and
I I wanted I just want to show everybody
what we're talking about I I want to
deliver a Checkmate down here but it
doesn't even work because the Knight
hops back to G7 and now black is winning
yikes okay wow yes when we got out of
the break I said we might not even see
15 moves I think uh it might be the
commentators guys here because uh we
might be heading we've got another game
Jana punishi is out of the biggest
trouble that he was in and Robert if we
just back up on our analysis board to
that moment when we were looking at D7
that would have been game over in just a
few moves instead of the trade on h8 we
saw that line and it was completely
busted 67 though we said seven though is
the move that I missed there uh
originally Cruiser seven keeps it going
for for a bit
and I think maybe Queen H1 here is the
move take some Queen A8
all right so the players they just
making tons of moves right now so let's
see what's happening here the queen went
back to H2 oh being repeated one second
oh my gosh once I hope no no but once
position is wonderful no you repeat once
again
C7 do not go Queen E5 oh there's there's
no way you know Anish was saying oh
maybe they prepared this to some kind of
repetition for a draw this is not that
repetition he's going to play a queen up
to C7 and he does that was just that and
can white just go Bishop H3 and take
this Knight like black is Frozen the
best black will do is bring this queen
to E7 and the big question is what do
you do after that
but then EF5 will be a check right like
if you go Queen f8 Bishop H3 Queen E7
you take on F5 I'll take with the E Pawn
my queen gets maybe a little active yeah
I'll collect the G5 Pawn Rover that's a
small problem if I collect the G5 phone
as well then return back with the queen
okay my Rook is stuck but maybe I'll
push some Pawn on the king side at some
point and try to deflect you of course
situation is critical for uh for a young
maybe he I suspect he could still be
lost uh but ding he has to put these
finishing touches uh here he has to play
it out nicely I'm just wondering so what
is the actual threat like let's say you
get your queen here I'm just gonna make
these moves if we can because the
players have taken a moment here it
looks like John needs to sit and think
what is your I'm just gonna make random
move okay oh King D1 you go here engine
C1
oh you're taking on G5 so that's clearly
not the right Square yeah yeah 493 maybe
93 is there
I don't know what it does but at least
it's small
so in other words I can't just do
absolutely nothing because you're gonna
try to win my G5 Pawn that's what you're
telling me yeah but also after having
your G5 fun maybe I bring my king to E7
you know
and then um when I bring my king to E7 I
have an idea of going Queen to E5 Knight
to D6 disrupting your coordination along
the D file and then collecting the Deep
one so you cannot I think you would want
to uh you would want to keep your G5
Pawn I'm thinking
yeah you whenever you go Queen E5 check
I guess you go F6 or because if I get
maybe my queen to F6 maybe I sort of
dominate
you have to be careful with some really
nice insights that Rook D3 not a niche
that you were pointing out which looked
so strong and we were talking about it
during the break as well it's such a
difficult move to find and one of the
reasons apart from it being a difficult
move in itself to find is that there are
so many other options that look equally
attractive here Rook D3 is a quiet move
while D7 is screaming to be played right
you want to push that pawn to D7
yeah but if once you see Rook D3 uh it
resigns I mean that's the problem it's
really given what he has found so far in
this match I mean Rook D3 is a joke for
the uh compared to all of that it's just
uh it's just uh Elementary for for him
uh his fund is brilliant finishes I mean
the this is just Rook H3 next let's say
queen d8
probably only move
I think even after Queen d8 I have Rook
H3
and uh I I think it's just like forced
Checkmate simply I don't think there
there is anything to calculate while of
course in the game I mean okay it's
attractive continuation but I mean at
that point you are really I think there
are two types of um two types of lines
there are those that look good and those
that win on the spot I mean of course
everything was good but you want to
finish the game there
um so I'm really not thrilled with what
ding has done because okay here maybe
he's winning but it's far from over and
Giannis oh does he sacrifice The Rook oh
it looks like a beautiful therapy
beautiful Perpetual idea beautiful
Perpetual idea we gotta show that Robert
does it yeah because of course this Rook
is hanging Queen E4 check
if Bishop E2 You Queen H1 that's just
going back to uh because otherwise Queen
B1 right so now Queen B1 check is you
have to give a check
King D2 and oh I said I said idea I
didn't say Perpetual that's a beautiful
professional idea just to be sure
Queen B2 King D3 only move one
kingditsu
I'm running running
two options of running but back looks
good because yeah
you know Janice for the second day in a
row he does it remember uh the Natalia
do you remember the press conference of
the previous day he suggested some
Perpetual for ding which was not a
perpetual
now he's found the Perpetual that's also
another it looks like a special but it's
somehow not and it's very
counter-intuitive
but if you do your uh due diligence and
if you do your math you will figure out
that it's not a Perpetual but it does
look incredibly like a perpetual
you're saying that all
that also do
and calculate and
there is no Perpetual in this position
21 by the way
21.
1 no I mean I don't see it of the bad so
Queen d8 24 rookie two um
one is all forced Queen B1 Rook C2 windy
one check here this looks like a
perpetual
where he came from
so only movies again King E4 King E4 I
mean you give the Rook with check
okay give the Rook with check
Bishop D3 I guess Knight D6 this is in
E5 I guess oh my God followed by Queen
takes Queen takes G3
and F6 can H7 d8 Knight C4 King F4
yeah this is five
King G4 mini 4G
yeah
no but but Anish is right what he's
doing right now
he's demonstrating what Jan was probably
thinking he's like let me just go and
hope for this he didn't see a Perpetual
check let's be clear about that because
it doesn't exist but he's seeing it's
complicated and he probably felt that
the other position was losing if we just
backtrack to the start where we were
looking at instead of Queen H4 which is
considered a blunder which it is uh
Queen f8 this looks bad and we were
talking about this it doesn't look like
black has much Gunk for him but maybe
there is some kind of better defense
even though it doesn't it's very fun
into it by the way Robert it's so easy
to buy into it by the way it is so easy
to buy into that
he doesn't capture The Rook instead
sidesteps a check with King D1 and it's
not the best move that's exactly what
young one first of all he saves a Tempo
even in those variations we were looking
at you had to play Queen f8 Queen E7
then take he could just take this Pawn
on G5 and he's like out of the woods but
he's back in the game oh he bluffed him
oh but this was by the way uh I have to
say this was such a weird non-perpetual
like didn't didn't it look like a
completely like a Perpetual guys it
looked like totally like a perpetual
it was so weird for the benefit of
humanity can you take us through that
line that you just showed us the one
that was in Yan's mind the one that you
played through which looked like a
Perpetual it looked strong enough that
even ding bought it guys can we just
play through it one more time
foreign
here so instead of King D1 to run away
Queen takes d8 Queen E4 check Bishop E2
the bishop can block then the queen goes
to the corner there's no legal moves to
the king the bishop goes back we already
saw this so now
elimination yeah this is also easy so
you must work it too yep and by the way
more moves are happening but you have to
play at this point rookie two queen B1
check King D2 black can only give these
checks and white has to block and you
don't even take this bishop which is
available there's QC D1 windy one is
what you what you yeah and this is where
you end your calculation I think you're
done seeking four maybe you might not
seeking E4 because it's
counter-intuitive to give up a rook with
check is not what you want to do but the
point is that you're running out of
checks as black this Knight can give a
check here the King goes up Knight takes
Pawn thank you very much for your piece
on here no way I take with check so you
have to take this bishop but in the end
we saw that white gets the second Queen
and black unfortunately for Jan If This
Were to have happened runs out of checks
very quickly you have a few more up your
sleeve but no matter where you go the
white king sits on G3 and that's over
because Checkmate is threatened here
it's doable it's doable by the way but
it's super hard
yeah which is and the confidence with
which Jan played it I think that also
makes you a little
to the end they could have taken a few
more minutes it almost felt like a flare
like ding would find this to the end and
take the Rook but instead he buys into
it he moves the king to D1 and how much
of his Advantage has he given away
Robert well I think if he hadn't lost on
time in game seven he would have spent
much more time there and that's what I
often critique I don't want to be overly
critical it's you know the players
they're under a lot of stress they've
been playing this game it's
nerve-wracking it's intense but what I
have in the past criticized is not when
they miss an idea but when I feel they
don't spend enough time calculating it
and right now ding has 22 minutes left
on his clock to make it to move 40. he's
already made 33 moves so that is quite a
lot of time but because he lost game
seven in that fashion I'm guessing he is
intentionally speeding up but it is
backfiring because we see the evaluation
right now I think that the English still
has very good winning chances because he
has a pass Pawn in the seventh rank he
has given up his G5 pawn and John bring
brings his Queen back to E7 that seems
like a very logical choice but can the
white King by the way is there a future
for this King to just walk up the board
well I can tell you one thing Robert the
good news for ding is that both players
are under the impression that there was
a Perpetual check so both of them don't
feel like something has gone wrong I
think ding feels that okay he has a big
Advantage he always had it and so far
you know everything's going according to
plan I don't think he missed anything he
doesn't realize that he missed something
probably so he's feeling uh comfortable
and he's trying to speed up indeed and
you know this is so often happening like
one day you make a mistake you're too
slow next day you try to correct that
and you're becoming too fast and this is
the wrong thing you should never double
guess your thinking process you know a
player like ding he's played chess since
he's a little baby and he does it all on
automatically it's all you know uh
unconscious process and when you try to
interfere with it consciously and you
try to correct yourself then all this
weirdness can can happen and you start
missing stuff but that said he still has
the advantage and perhaps indeed the
king run there
but starting with King B3 is uh yeah
probably a good idea the question is how
much counter play back black can drum up
I can think of an idea maybe Knight H6
G8 F6 but then I will get my Bishop to
C6 to support the pawn uh I think
pushing the e-pawn is also an idea maybe
E5 E4 E3 or something like that trying
to generate counter play I think black
has a lot of practical counter chances
and
um yeah it's not going to be easy
I think he brought his Bishop out so he
wants to reinforce this Pawn on D7 yeah
I'm with you Anish of course black has
more chances now than before but I'm
still looking at this and I'm
I would hate to have this position if I
were young
Knight Knight D4 is there Knight D4 is
there
could have been a lot worse Robert it
could have been a lot worse for Yan and
I think he feels like it's uh the best
position he's had in some time maybe in
the whole game in this game eight that
we are seeing Bishop G2 and we see we
see an uh a question mark to that move
the computer the evaluation the engine
doesn't love it Bishop G2 not the most
accurate but such a natural human move
to make to just bring the bishop into
the game defend that D7 Pawn you guys
are talking about this insane idea of a
King march to win the game honestly if
that happens in this game I would just
feel like I've seen everything in this
world championship King B3 King A4 King
B5 to try and win the game it sounds
absolutely insane to me can you break
that down what's the point you just want
to go pick up all the pawns and use your
king to do that I do I'm saying that
black cannot really move effectively so
I'm just gonna start stealing all your
pawns and create a pass Pawn on my own
here but Fabi was just we saw his
featured chat he said King B3 was too
difficult to find I was talking about
the idea I didn't necessarily think King
B3 in that position but apparently it
was the best move that's what Fabi said
in the featured chat yeah you know the
other point of King B3 Robert is to
protect the A3 pawn and the relevance of
that is after Knight D4 check which is a
huge opportunity opportunity here for
Yan
and 94 CD Rook D7 yep
25 is forced F6 screen E3
because queen of four I have CD and now
uh yeah I can take on D4 and at the end
of the line I can take the A3 Pawn
right that's huge yeah so this is a
resource that Jan of course spotted
because Jan always spots resources Yan
misses a resource for opponent yeah
never misses resources for himself
Knight D4 is going to come now and I
think this is the first time in the
match that a player having a winning
position actually actually ruins it
wow I mean to see that King B3 is needed
not just for potential uh king walk but
to protect the A3 Pawn uh that's that's
really off most people's radar
wow
amazing amazing and he's used
to say that did not look like an easy
find to just sacrifice the Knight on D4
and he he doesn't go for it he goes for
E5 and the eval bar shoots right up it's
again I think Lauren in the driving seat
because you know surprisingly now uh
Knight D4 is actually no longer an idea
because I can now take CD and queen X E5
so this was a one-time opportunity that
uh Jan missed and I'm actually surprised
because
after Bishop E4
yeah ding is back uh ding is back in
this dominant position and Jan cannot
get rid of this deep one and this Knight
D4 I really yeah I think Jan was very
capable of that
um I'm surprised he didn't um
he didn't find it I'm thinking although
maybe he thought of Queen F4 instead of
Queen E5 check
because after Queen F4 okay just to show
very quickly what Anisha is talking
about so here Knight D4 takes Rook
descent Queen F4 yeah
yeah because here actually this does
look very good for
White
because because of the CD I have Rook D4
ah of course Rook D4 D4 E5 is the but
then I have Rook D7
wait
where oh here E5 now Rook D7 for sure
yeah yes and after Rook default I have
rookie 4 as well so so
actually this looked bad for black
a great surprise that this is
but so when you're excusing Jan for not
seeing Knight yeah I'm not I'm not I'm
no longer seeing why this works actually
even so Rook D4
I have a maybe Rook C7 or
okay but think about you know this but
I'm trying to explain this to everybody
at home giving up your night now you
have just two pawns for a bishop we get
there's no more pass Pawn that's the
good news but you are down material so
uh there may be a way to defend this for
black but it's not going to be easy no
it's really difficult yeah yeah no and
oh sorry Queen 93 and queen A4 check is
that it oh my goodness okay but this is
hard yeah it's hard
yeah
yeah I knew that it works so then it's a
bit easier to find it but if you don't
know it works it's very hard to find
okay but we see action Knight H6 played
by Young The Palms he did not want to
love the bishop to take but the eval bar
is getting higher and now that the
Knight is all the way over here can
white just start taking these pawns I
know I wanted to bring the king up but
if the pawn presents itself why not grab
it
I can understand this Nitra treat right
by Yan because allowing Bishop F5
opening up of the G file The Rook steps
back comes into the attack with such a
scary alternative to let that happen
sarian decides to keep the king side
intact it goes back with the Knight and
now you're mentioning that it's time to
start picking up the pawns to increase
the advantage you've got all your pieces
placed at the best possible position so
why not I don't see a direct repetition
or or is black ever going to dream about
getting F5 in is that a move that Yan
can be considering after Queen A7
yeah I have to say uh the problem with
why it's a position here okay you
dominate you control the d d file the D7
Pawn is under firm firm protection
but um you cannot dislodge The Rook from
the default from this d8 square and so
probably you have to indeed switch to
just
um gobbling up the a pawn then Bishop C6
then Queen B6 and then run down the a
pawn of your own
I guess this is the winning plan in the
meantime Jan will go for this E4 E3
business and I know Jan he's tricky
he'll try to throw that in at some point
and uh I don't know what to move or
maybe Knight G4 maybe F5 first but um E4
E3 is is the black source of control
play and it feels like it shouldn't work
of course but with white thing a little
bit open
it still it still can slip away
wow this game there's so much more than
meets the eye you know you look at the
evaluation bar and you think oh yon had
a way to come back and oh he was fine to
begin with why did he take this Knight
on e4 but the decisions have been so
difficult and draining move by move he
does play Knight G4 Anish you called it
he wants to be tricky he wants to bring
this Pawn forward and go after this King
because the bad news about taking all
these pawns for now D7 is hanging we get
that but in general when you take pawns
you open files what does this white king
not want more pieces to attack it
especially if this Knight kicks his
Bishop out of there and the pawn goes
forward so he has chances here
absolutely absolutely I think a big
moment there uh was when ding didn't
finish the game off immediately with
either D7 or Rook takes h8 and Rook D3
because after that it of course spiraled
out of control somewhat and although now
he's still doing very very well we are
no longer in the territory of um of a
force to win so while position might be
winning it's a long way to go and he has
to be very accurate for sure for example
right now I'm trying to find a good move
so Queen B6 you don't want to allow Rook
G7 Bishop C6 you allow E4 so I'm
thinking maybe you could start with the
move like A4 waiting for Knight F6 and
only then going Bishop C6 but already a
move like that I mean uh you know you're
not you're not sure anymore if that's
the best move and uh you have to take
all kinds of things into account and uh
well it's it's not easy for sure I
really don't think this is a
straightforward as straightforward as
the bar suggests and given the time
situation I wouldn't be surprised to see
a lot of swings still in the evaluation
of this game
yeah it's been about
chances to get to white skin
you're talking about the Knight coming
back the e-pawn advancing and you just
have to push and try and break through
so four moves still to reach time
control Yan's idea is clear meanwhile
ding has to find a way to break through
do you think time is going to be a
factor in this one uh it is we are on
move
we're on move 37 right now for white so
foremost to be made and uh
how do you see 16 minutes in this
position will it be enough well ding has
made sure that the clock will not be his
issue in this game and he actually left
a win or maybe a couple wins on the
table by playing a bit too hastily he
had time to spend but it's clear that he
is not going to find himself in time
trouble but what he does find himself
with is one pass Pawn on D7 that can be
defended he can also take on BC I would
not do this I certainly wouldn't but if
he wants to go up material he can just
start taking all the pawns right he
gives up his most pass Pawn trades Rooks
takes on C5 and says oh I still have
this outside passer no part of me wants
to do that trust me I'm wanting to keep
my most advanced pass Pawn but at my
point at large is that Ding he is kind
of having several options that will
leave him with an advantage but how big
of an advantage is the essential
question and I think that he needs to
defend this problem with his Bishop but
I would also be a bit worried about this
Pawn going forward Anish you have been
calling for this Pawn push it's going to
happen whether ding wants it to happen
or not
yeah and I have to say I really like
doing some body language there um I like
uh the way he looked at his corset just
threw the span a little bit a little bit
of aggression there he's uh brought this
emotion from his previous game where
he's you know he's pissed at himself or
being frozen there and now he's no
longer freezing he's trying to calculate
you know he's he's on a full alert mode
he doesn't want to repeat the same
mistake yet he understands that he has
to calculate so he is now very sharp
very alert I really like his body
language and I think he's going deep
into the position I think the time is
definitely a factor but I hope for him
today that he will face it well he will
spend the time on his three moves and
he'll make the good ones and indeed uh
going for Queen B6 that would be uh
definitely it's not something you would
wish I mean it's selling a position much
too short I I think the D7 Pawn Robert
is definitely something we want to keep
isn't it and um yeah I think the
question is do you just go for Bishop C6
E4 Queen B6 E3 take let's say in 93
let's say King B3 do you trust that
there is no counter play there because I
wouldn't be sure at all uh or do you do
you try to be smart and clever and and I
don't know this movie A4 is kind of
staring at me not sure if it's good but
it's definitely a kind of smart move
that Ding is thinking about but maybe
it's not so smart since
um I think the computer just wants to go
for the director Bishop C6 approach and
to win a game we often talk about the
concept of creating two weaknesses while
it's also important to create two
strands here so D7 is one of them and
the other one that you want is to create
the a passer that's why the idea of
Defending that D7 pawn and only then
capturing the B6 spawn so that you can
start advancing step by step the a pawn
down the board to Queen but it is about
evaluating how dangerous the Knight and
queen will be against the white king
once this E4 E3 will come on the board
once again for nepo the plan is clear
for ding not as much because he needs to
take his time to evaluate and see how
much uh his King will be safe in those
positions Knight G4 on the board Bishop
C6 is what we're expecting a big moment
for Ding and you've been saying Robert
that time is not a big factor currently
because he's been judicious but he still
needs to take a decision fast he can't
burn the clock too much the next three
to four moves will be super critical and
he needs about three to four minutes for
each of them You're gonna laugh at me
and I mentioned this idea earlier can
you play King B3 King a4k
okay I see what he's doing there I see
what he's doing there so he he's trying
to
um Force the Knight back to F6
but it's a blunder yeah but I see what
he's trying
and I I told you I didn't like this E43
thing
and neither does ding but uh the
computer is not happy do you guys see
why
is it your idea for a night sacrifice to
win D7 that doesn't quite look like it
does the trick
it's good it's good
wait what's wrong with Knight F6 yeah
then I think Bishop C6 I'm probably very
happy with that I I would think because
then I can take on B6 later and uh or I
keep all the advantages of my position
and I've sent your knight back but I'm
afraid that uh yeah the reason computer
doesn't like it there's some something
something different maybe it's Knight F2
related
wow another piece sci-fi yeah that's not
clear either right I was just reacting
to the evaluation I say go to zero I
don't see anything else besides maybe
Knight takes up I'll just let's put it
on the board so something is also
possible of course some move with the
queen I don't know
yeah
six
it works Robert if
itsu I think but but this is so far from
Clear I mean this kind of blows kind of
it looks lost for why doesn't it for
black sorry down a piece
it wow
and that deserves the double exclamed I
mean that was a big decision from Young
and you can look at his body language
Anish you were just talking about ding's
body language look at Yan now he looked
a bit dejected earlier but now he is
leaning over the board and he feels that
he has legitimate chances to hold this
and the eval bar agrees
yeah well unfortunately for ding not
only is this a good practical chance
because you hate seeing your deep Pawn
disappear but also objectively this
seems to be strong I would personally
think that white is still uh objectively
White should still be doing good but if
even the bars with with the hand and
well I mean I have to say dig in this
game he has uh taking a lot of very bad
decisions once he got a winning position
and I think yes he's he's just uh he
hasn't fully recovered yet it seems to
me because he's let young back into the
game multiple occasions and now I'm
allowing Knight F2 uh which apparently
is also very strong yeah it looks like
things are not going his way at all
anymore
wow what a shocker for Ding and I mean
he's now calculating when someone takes
the pawn that and you can capture that
piece usually you take it but the fact
that he hasn't moved yet it's clear he
did not expect that that was an
oversight by him and the fact that he
hasn't taken this Knight immediately he
may be gathering his bearings but maybe
he's gonna say you know what my past
Pawn is that important I dropped my own
Pawn but let me keep my Pawn on D7 try
to take B6 next it's not out of the
question
wow but after you play a move like
Bishop F3 and then to go back Bishop C6
just losing the F2 Pawn that's such a
difficult decision to make as a player
on the board and Knight F2 is definitely
not something ding was expecting it's
been played I have to say that is that
is a high class defense resource to just
sacrifice the Knight on F2 for the
e-pawn to push on to pick up the D7 Pawn
to some incredible chess Jana abomishi
doesn't miss his resources when he gets
the chance he does it and again I'm
gonna come back to the clock Factor
there's three more moves to be made 10
minutes but Knight F2 when you're faced
with this shocker something that you
were not expecting that changes the
complete dynamics of the position it's
not an easy shift in the mind rabbit
no it's not easy at all but I I I get it
like he but he has plenty of time left I
guess that's my thought is if game seven
didn't happen I don't think we'd be
talking about the time trouble the same
way he has 11 minutes to make a few
moves he's a very experienced top level
Grandmaster to him that's probably not
huge time trouble but I think we are
having this recency bias where we're
looking at the position and be like Oh
time trouble I really think it's the
loss right what just happened not time
trouble in a in a vacuum but we don't
live in a vacuum and we're not
emotionless creatures dingley Ren highly
emotional as we've seen in many of his
interviews and I do think that it's game
seven coming back to haunt him but he
had a winning position I mean you
mentioned it earlier there were some
choices that he made that you know if he
had spent a little bit more time maybe
he would have found it because he is
that strong he's that great of a
calculator it just seems like something
is a bit off and it could be a remnant
of game seven
he picks up tonight so he takes a
decision fast and makes a lot of sense
you kind of just don't want to give up
the F2 Pawn for free uh Rook F2 so are
we expecting Yan to pick up the D7 Pawn
immediately or can he throw in an
intermediate E4
guys you know I'm looking at this
position and I'm seeing uh I'm just
seeing a fourth draw here
uh you want me to tell you the first
draw
yeah
that was the move I was thinking it was
more I was thinking about the line I'm
thinking about that's just rookie two
uh F5
Queen
um well let's say queen B6 or Bishop
Jitter first that's the same could be
six let's say it would be seven
and I think uh I don't see how your
queen ever gets out uh from the
following of The Rook so I'll go just
Rook B7 7 rupee seven okay seven uh
whatever you whatever you do I will just
follow your queen I think it's trapped
oh my goodness if I wasn't on screen but
my jaw dropped Anish that is sickening
let's say Bishop G2 Rook B7 the queen
can't get out of the cage
the big cage it's a very big cage well I
think maybe it can via VIA B8 so maybe
you can go like yes maybe but but well
then I three Pawn already hangs yeah so
I could also get more ambitious with
black you should should not uh
completely dismiss it
but um
maybe you go C6 first
maybe like this you can try
but then again you lose the a pawn
and White's winning chances look yeah
you can play this of course with white
but uh yeah um you don't have a past
spawn anymore and the bishop is staring
at the spawn chain I'm not gonna push my
pawns I think I'll just keep them there
just keep your Bishop locked out and try
to set up attack against your king and
end game is also good for black at this
point no I think this is it I think he's
uh ruined it and just uh
I mean I I think it's just a draw to be
honest um
for at best for white
wow it's as if the queen is trapped with
so many squares on the board an open
position that is a very interesting
pattern not something that I've seen
before Robert that Queen B6 Rook D7 with
the idea that your queen doesn't have
enough squares to retreat a black spawns
dominating so many squares what are the
chances of the Game ending this way I
think that because of that uh fine the
niche just showed us Bishop G2 first is
the better way of going because that way
if the Rook takes Queen B6 you can't
just follow my queen around because now
I'm actually threatening your Pawn here
on e4 so I think that Bishop G2 first
keeps the game going I'm just not sure
that Ding wants to keep the game going
with this one his King could be in
trouble like it's not like he has safety
for himself at the moment now all three
results would be possible so I don't
know I think you kind of have to play on
if you're ding you're up a bishop you
want to win this game to even up the
match you were winning before but he is
going to take some significant risks but
Robert if I do that Tempo down okay so
Bishop jitor of the 7.6 F5 how do you
prevent that idea anyway I'll give you
an extra move
you're a very kind person and you're
saying I just simply cannot get out of
it well you can try to get out of it but
uh it's not very convenient maybe Queen
to B8 but even if you get out of that
cage I mean
first of all already material material
is bad because I have a pawn for a
bishop but the C pawns are irrelevant
the a pawn is very far and my three past
Pawns they're very formidable so I have
like I'm kind of have some positional
conversation with black at this point as
well but yeah tactical as well I mean
after rugby seven I'm sending your queen
all the way back it has to go to F4 or
G3 I guess and then G3 threatening Rook
F5 as well yeah that looks more
threatening
okay here I have to consider uh options
I have some ideas like 28 Queen A4 I I
don't know if Rooker 5 is an issue then
I have to calculate a little bit more
deeply I could try to do the same way I
decided but then 25 Checkers what I
didn't like that's why I want to eat I
can also try to reinforce my position
with Queen E6 and just keep everything
protected and just attack a C4 pawn and
threaten Queen B6 potentially as well
sometimes I'm just not liking White's
position is so passive and dinka's uh
completely misevaluated when he went
from Bishop F3 he only thought about
Knight F6 back I guess and it was yeah
not not uh not a good decision there by
Ding and now I think I like the
exposition and then could overpress it
uh very likely and potentially even lose
it
my goodness
I mean the position
no you go I was just gonna say it's so
easy to not adjust your own mind space
to the fact that you messed up a
complete
completion where you're up a piece we've
got the eval bar telling us what the
evaluation of the position is the ding
of course has got no idea right now he
goes for the move rookie too I still
like the fact that he's making decisions
fast and that's a good sign that's a
sign of a confident thing he plays
rookie too and now you're expecting a
capture in these seven Rook D7 and then
just reinforcing the E4 Pawn with the
push of the F Pawn and it looks like
Jana bamushi is really back in this game
it may not even last for very long after
The Rook starts uh pursuing the White
Queen Anish you have a thought yeah just
wondering why don't I start with F5 even
stronger and after Queen B6 Queen D7 yep
that was bad to say the same thing so I
drew the arrow that this is going to be
a problem down the D line and your
Bishop is hanging here so wait wow yeah
yeah so white has to start with Bishop
G2
instead of Queen B6 and after Rook j7
play number six
and then hope black will just do a
Perpetual because I'm not sure can we
start thinking about trading Queens like
is that why not you didn't even take my
B6 oh my God yeah yeah no just just
winning of course of course you can but
so you think already wait this thing
works
ding is in trouble I mean Rook E2 after
F5 what is his plan
and here comes Jan he is going to play
F5
he does it he finds it it looks more it
looks really good
you can't avoid the queen trade after
Queen D7 there's just no way to avoid it
you can't allow the queen to penetrate
on the D file
I mean Giannis sees in control of the
match I can't believe I'm saying that
based on how this game has gone but all
of a sudden he had a pump she could find
himself with a huge advantage and look
at the body language Dean grabbed his
head before in disbelief Yawn is peering
over the board and he knows that he is
better he's gonna walk away right now
but dingley ran in huge trouble and by
the way you keep asking about time
trouble everyone is talking about in the
chat dig now has five minutes and he's
one move to make but this one move could
turn the game completely in yon's favor
if he decides to move his Bishop back
and queen takes D7 happens Yan will be
facing what looks like a great end game
with really strong winning chances guys
I don't know if you're so but ding shook
his head there I think he missed Queen
takes D7
this is the maybe the counter-intuitive
move the tune that you miss and I think
that at this point he maybe he has to do
something desperate with Bishop E4 I was
looking at Bishop H5 briefly trying to
do some tricks but I don't think it
works
um so I think before a Fe
Queen
B6 Queen D7
and try
bitsu maybe but
it's shaky shaky and there is creeper
black of course are completely at this
point as black regains a piece and has a
safer King here the thing is completely
lost control and
I'm afraid he might even lose this game
but maybe he really pull himself
together and find something like this
because I see the bar still so the
sequel but optically it looks uh very
dangerous for white
it's the opposite of what we've been
talking about right earlier we were
saying how the eval bars said zeros but
black was in big trouble this would be a
role reversal and very bad news for ding
he cannot afford to lose this game
yeah that would be a two-point deficit
for Ding and that also coming from the
position that he did completely
commanding opening middle game brilliant
play and then these last few moves one
in accuracy with the bishop falling back
to F3 and it looks like the position has
turned around yeah finding a brilliant
night after sacrificing the night uh to
take over the initiative and now he's
the one who's pushing he's the one who's
trying to get something out of this game
you're pointing out the line of giving
that Bishop back that is a very
difficult decision to take one is you
evaluate the last position where Black's
got these past pawns your Pawn structure
is ruined your king is absolutely weak
Black's pieces are Super Active compare
the queen and the White Queen and Rook
but if you don't give up the bishop
right now I want to take a look at that
is that ending lost for white is it how
difficult is that ending where you're up
a bishop but black has got three pawns
steamrolling down on the king side in
this position if dingler in decides to
not give up that bishop and just fall
back with it how do you evaluate Queen
67 Queen D7 Rook D7 yeah I think it's
dead I think it's just long-term debt
I'll bring the king to E5 and push my
pawns down you have zero counter play
that's the problem if you had control
play it would be a different story but
you have zero counter play you need like
2 000 moves on King side on the queen
side to make something happen uh you
have to bring the king to like B3 and
even then it's anyway nothing so I think
that position is like it's sort of it is
that looks sort of slowly but surely
lost
I think I think I asked to sacrifice the
bishop at all cost and I have to say
that I mean we should give credit to Jan
for Knight xf2 but we should also
mention that this was ding's on doing in
this game he has had so many
opportunities and I mean player of his
statues normally at some point he takes
one of them I mean you cannot of course
of course if you keep not grabbing
opportunities at some point this will
happen and some kind of tactic will
happen but ding made so many mistakes in
the winning position he didn't finish it
off on the spot with Rook the three Rook
H3 then
he didn't call him out on the Perpetual
which was not a Perpetual I mean you can
miss each one of them and then finally
he allowed Knight F2 you can miss each
one of them which is sort of normal but
if you miss all three of them in the
same game then it's not you so
something's off with ding he's he's
totally pissed also because Bishop E4
that's an admission of failure and you
have to then defend at no hope of
winning at all and it's such an awful
awful decision to take and move forward
I'm really fearing for ding here and Jan
I know Jan the more you know the the
more the better so young smelling blood
here and he wants to finish the match of
today
yeah well if he wins that is practically
a very difficult situation to come back
and ding is down to a minute and 20
seconds he still has one more move to
make it's a difficult decision because
you now need to go on the defense you
need to give up that Bishop to play that
end game with the queen and Rook to try
and keep it under control ding right now
has to take that decision otherwise
positionally he would be lost as you're
pointing out Queen D7 is coming in sing
make a move down to less than a minute
now one move still remaining Robert but
as we've been talking about he might
have to play Bishop takes E4 it's such a
difficult move to play psychologically
he doesn't want to do that but he will
have to if he wants to hold on to this
game and even then it will not be so
clear-cut so dingley red he is down to
40 seconds for his final move this is
scary territory for him and he is just
so upset
I think he has to take on e4 it looks
bad the king is still unsafe there but
you have to do it um I'm afraid he might
not take the decision but he has to yes
it's exactly the moment in game seven
when he messed it up with that Rook D3
move which is
he has to make a move 10 seconds one
more move remains
oh he's so upset
whoa Queen takes B6 this is losing on
the spot right out to Queen the seven
windy seven
as well as a bishop
oh my gosh he did make it to move 40. so
you know he can breathe I can breathe
because I got so worried he made him
move four seconds on the clock and
somehow the evaluation bar doesn't
change the White's position
Robert
oh counter attack
yeah it looks actually fine
it looks actually fine doesn't it
wow what a move then if he played that
with four seconds but he found a way out
yeah it looks looks kind of
doesn't look bad for white maybe between
the seven is Queen the seven even the
move
it seems like at the evaluation bar
stayed the same what if I offer a queen
trade again maybe maybe I'll check your
king just to push but now I have the ape
on now I mean I was preaching how the
apron like is all
engine happy even without the apron
where's your Bishop going
well I was thinking I mean I can take
the queen and then drop it somewhere but
um yeah it's it's who I guess
yeah it's very fast F4
yeah
yeah my a pond is not so not too fast
well I can totally understand being
taking on B6 actually I think I would
have done the same
oh definitely I would 100 play the same
move by the way because I I missed 32
before now when I have root 2 of course
I go here of course I don't want to
suffer there without the bishop I'd
rather uh I rather play this position
hoping it's fine
because there's that hope deep inside
right that you have some winning chances
maybe and yeah
because it's very hard guys it gets very
hard it's very hard this uh YouTube
business was very hard so now a position
is actually equal again now this is
Queen trade was extremely weird I have
to say
very weird
Jan just takes with the rook and now we
are back to Bishop B7 Pro right
I think so this is the one you called
out yeah this is the one you might be
seeing
yeah yeah no Dingus uh dingus
at least thing has uh you know salvaged
likely established the position somewhat
and draw would not be the end of the
world as I mentioned earlier I don't
think Joe is the end of the world for
him in this match especially if he holds
the next one with the black pieces so I
think Joe would be okay he just has to
now calm down drink some water
hot water as they do in China and then
just play play some good moves
what is this Arbiter doing
walking around you know getting on
camera there but yeah that was
unbelievable stuff I'm still wrapping my
head around what just happened there
dingley Wren making that move with four
seconds left but now he has time to
consider his options
and with that we got on the player it's
got an additional 60 minutes on the
clock for the next 20 moves the dust the
madness has settled for the moment the
players are in the restroom just getting
their thoughts together and while they
do that we've seen incredible action in
game it so far and it continues we will
be right back
[Music]
I do recommend Meetup to a lot of my
friends that are looking for different
things wine tasting movies book club
meet a lot of new people a lot of new
friends and it make you more social
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
makes the 40th move with just four
seconds on the clock and what a game
this has been so far he had his big
chances and now it is all about keeping
things under control for dingler and it
has been a topsy-turvy game and that's
exactly ding story things path to the
world championship dings path to Astana
is also a topsy Derby one take a look at
how ding made it to the World
Championships
dangly wren's unpredictable path to this
year's feed a world championship was
born from the right combination of good
fortune and persistent gameplay
ding's journey to Kazakhstan almost
never got started travel restrictions in
China prevented him from qualifying for
the candidates the Gateway tournament to
the world championship but when a spot
unexpectedly opened up ding ground away
to earn the vacated seat and punch his
ticket to Madrid
[Music]
his foot in the candidate's door ding
struggled in the first half of the
tournament failing to earn a win and
falling to the eventual winner Jana
pomnishi
but that's when the magic began in the
second half ding began to turn things
around starting with a resounding win
over yanked off Duda we have a victory
for dingley Wren and his candidates
chances are not gone at this time
ding then continued his momentum with
back-to-back wins over Rickard robort
and Fabiano caruana
in his final match of the tournament
ding squared off with Hikaru Nakamura in
a battle for second place with rumors
suggesting Magnus Carlson might step
down as Champion second place at the
candidates now had an entirely new
meaning
needing a win ding took advantage of a
missed Opportunity by Hikaru on move 38
and worked steadily from there to secure
the Victory and second place the second
half of the tournament has been his four
wins in seven games
while his runner-up finish at the
candidates was certainly an
accomplishment ding left Madrid without
a seat at the world championship
that all changed later that summer when
Magnus announced he would not be
defending his title
with the five-time champion out of the
mix ding's second place finish at the
candidate suddenly became a golden
ticket to Kazakhstan with the rare
opportunity to cement his name amongst
the distinguished list of fide world
champions
much like his opponent ding chose to
skip most of the high-profile classical
events over the past few months and
instead selected to immerse himself in
his preparation to face neponishi time
will tell if that approach and ding's
string of good luck and competitiveness
will earn him the most famous title In
classical chess
World Championship has been won for the
movies it has been filled with emotions
and so much drama on the chessboard
we've seen him take his own destiny into
his own hands to get to where he is
right now and currently he Trails the
match by a point after he lost game 7
going into game 8 the current one that
is on thing makes the time control which
is four seconds on the clock and he's
fighting to keep the game alive he's
fighting to keep the game going we see
that with his last move making sure that
the queen can indeed come out of the
trouble spot on the queen side dingler
in he needs to win this game to equalize
this match Anish what are the chances of
that happening
yes
he has an extra piece no I mean the
smarter chess prediction you know the
the one that easily hands out is 97 uh
stuff I think it would give ding like uh
0.2 chance of winning here
because I think the last move I think
the idea maybe
is not to
um play for a win maybe the idea is to
force the draw with uh move like Ruby 7
Queen C8 with someone B8 because at
least with the queen on the eighth rank
you maybe thread on Rook H2
so maybe he's trying to just force the
draw even more than with the move like
Bishop G2 because maybe he's worried
that Jan will play some quiet move you
know
uh or if you're somehow repositioning
his rook in the queen and start the
attack I could easily imagine that yeah
this could be eight is not not
necessarily a winning attempt but we
will see uh we'll see could also be that
Ding wants to bring the queen back but I
think after Rook B7 bringing the queen
back that's very dangerous because black
has all sorts of different interesting
options to try and um
penetrates and start the attack so I
think you have to be careful with white
and I don't think winning is on the on
the menu here for ding I think he should
be happy that after missing so many
opportunities in this game that at least
uh at least you can get away with half a
point and as I already mentioned
um multiple times earlier I think if he
holds the next game with the black
pieces he's still in with the with a
decent shot
yeah and Robert we saw this this whole
path to the world championship fitting
it's been something that we haven't seen
in the history we saw him kind of carve
his own way to the candidates and then
Magnus withdrawing from the world
championship deciding to not defend his
title and then ding gets a spot and now
here he is he's the first Chinese player
to have surpassed 2800. he is the first
player from China who is fighting he to
win the fideo World Championship it's
such a big moment for him which also of
course adds up to all the pressure and
the expectation
how much do you think this means to ding
it is of course every chess player's
dream to become world champion but there
is so much that has happened to get here
for Ding and it's such a big moment for
him
yeah it seems borderline overwhelming
for him we've heard him uh talk he has
been very emotional and if you think
about the match as a whole thus far he's
actually had an advantage for a good
percentage of the time he has won
several games and the game he lost in in
the seventh game right before the break
he was the one who was kind of ahead he
was out playing Yonder Palms here in
game eight he was outplaying him once
again so I feel like the result doesn't
necessarily reflect the level of play
he's shown overall uh you wouldn't
expect him to be down in the match based
on how well he has played but I do think
that the emotions are getting the better
of him and he will need to get them to
check ASAP because there's not much time
remaining in this match and if he does
not win this game here and let's say
this eight game ends in a draw he'll
have to come right back tomorrow with
the black pieces he has not finished off
well when he is in Black
Daniel Robert I also I'm sensing some
trust issues there uh and in case of
ding I think he trusts Young Too Much I
think Jan's body language tricks they
work on ding because I keep noticing
that the impacted in his thinking
process in his decision making today he
trusted him on the Perpetual of course
if he did his calculation
the line okay it how to say
if you put a position after Queen H4 and
you ask me again in a second is this a
Perpetual or not I'll tell you to
Perpetual this is not the point the
point is that when your opponent plays
Move Like an H4 you are supposed to as a
professional of course do your
um do your check do your um calculations
and you're just going to calculate and
as we had seen you just keep calculating
the fourth line and in the end you are
shocked to find out that you are winning
I mean it's a shock you're shocked but
you just get there if you do the right
procedure that you are capable of
but of course the moment you start
trusting your opponent the moment you
start
um
doubting your time spending is when you
start playing you know taking these
weird decisions and you you basically
scan this line you think okay it's a
draw because also the guy probably looks
there you know confident and he's always
with his Young's constant Faces by the
way this it's a thing like you make a
good move and Jan makes a face and um
it's and you doubt your move because you
think okay maybe I made the wrong move
you know and uh I've experienced this a
lot of course and you have to learn to
resist this as well I mean I'm nobody's
immune to that so it's not like I can do
it on demand all either but you have to
uh resist the stuff and you have to
trust yourself you cannot trust your
opponent and I think also in the
previous game I I saw the one that he
lost
um Jan's Yan's body language has been uh
very misleading that game as well he was
making all these faces faces when he was
getting out played basically I was
getting outplayed missing every strong
move and every time dick would find a
strong move he would make a face uh you
know Jan is trying to dominate ding also
psychologically and when you look at the
body language and time spending Jan
basically dominates things
psychologically
just like I was reading in the books you
know how caspara was slamming the door
against vision and all that I see I see
it so if you ask me because I haven't
watched that much but I suspect it was
similar back then when Gary kaspara was
playing with Shannon uh one of the
players is just uh trying to intimidate
the other uh in in a way and the other
one seems to start getting intimidated
yeah no I think it's very real what
you're saying and uh you know just going
back to that Queen H4 moment that was
Black's 31st move and if I'm remembering
correctly ding had about 22 minutes
remaining on his clock and he only spent
something like three or four and that
was a very critical moment because as
you said you calculated through either
it's a Perpetual or it's not and I I
firmly believe and I don't want to you
know kind of keep going on about this
but I firmly believe that if game 7 had
not just happened he really would have
spent 10 plus minutes on that turn
because he did have the time to
calculate it and we know dingley Ren
when he is at his best he didn't lose in
a hundred consecutive classical games
when he's at his best he's over 2800 the
number two rated player in the world he
can beat anybody on the planet including
Magnus Carlson which he did in the
sinkfield cup uh tie breaks right he was
able to take him down so I feel like
dingley rent has been rattled by what
happened in game seven because that
never happens when do you see someone
freeze like that and almost lose on time
it it's rare so I think that for ding he
should be kicking himself the good news
is the position he has right now is
level and I don't think that he at the
moment is probably overly concerned
about losing because if he doesn't want
to lose he can just Shuffle his Queen
back and forth we'd see it in B8 uh but
for ding he needs to trust himself more
he cannot lose sight of the fact that he
is a superstar he's freaking dingly Wren
I mean the guy is a beast we all know
that that goes without question so I
think he shouldn't question himself and
as you said he should not believe yawn
upon the street like his mannerisms his
gesticulations they're in part in Act
and we've seen this uncharacteristic
side of ding throughout the world
championship match right even in the
press conferences he just seems a little
emotional he has said it himself that he
feels the distrust of being where he is
uh that shaking as you can sense it and
one just wonders if this exact situation
what we saw in this game was just any
other stage any other match these two
have played against each other so many
times zingler would have probably just
done exactly that calculated the line to
the end not had those self-doubts not
had that trust on Yan that yes you're
pretending to give me a Perpetual it
indeed is a Perpetual but actually
seeing the line through and how much of
that has to do with the fact that this
is the biggest stage the fact that this
is the world championship the experience
that is required to deal with the
pressure here and how easy it is for
even a player like ding to sometimes
just choke under that pressure and maybe
if it was any other stage any other
Elite level tournament absolutely really
anything else in the world he would have
called out Jan's Bluff at that moment
yes uh and ding has mentioned before
before at the start also that he uh in
interview before tournament also that he
was trying to get mentally ready
uh for the you know for the big stage
and it's really really hard to do so but
I think yes he also had to probably take
into account the opponent he plays and
specifics of playing Young
because uh indeed if we look at like the
pure quality of of the moves you know at
certain uh parts of the game it doesn't
you don't get impression that Ding is an
inferior player by no means but the
Practical aspect of chess the time
spending like the okay you can be a slow
player but sometimes uh you waste you
waste time when it's already clear about
move uh what best movies like if it's so
clear to all the commentators it is only
one move and then he's still thinking
that means okay he's just double you
know doubting himself and um being
practical you know not falling for this
body language tricks
this kind of things that are also very
much part of Chess actually proud part
of practical chess in that kind of game
Jan is far superior
um so far at least that's that is the
case to me even if you just look at Yan
you know the way he sits I mean he's
just you know he's just sitting there he
owns the stage he owns the board he's
now playing with the pawn it's like I
mean you know who gave him permission to
play but he he took the permission to
play with the pawn there it's his board
you know and uh he's sitting there on
the table putting all his weight it's
it's just different with ding you know
he's um
and it doesn't matter for many players
but
um sometimes it really makes an impact
and it translates into the moves if it
does turns into the moves it's all good
sometimes it translates into the moves
and then you see that okay you end up
trusting that guy
um you end up questioning yourself and I
think with ding I see that
yeah he in the last few days he's been
lacking
um some of that confidence that he
needed and um
that's that's an issue and the problem
with today's game even if it ends in a
draw
I mentioned before the draw is fine but
I realized that you know it's not just a
draw he will come back to the to his
hotel room
and first of all the hotel room is too
big as he already said that's already an
issue and the other issue is that you
come back to that hotel room and then he
will realize he was winning
and he realized that he just he just had
to take the just take the rook and game
over and he'll of course get very pissed
at that and uh he has to recover from
this blow as well because if he had come
back score would be equal and that would
be a very different story so another
psychological blowout today even after
him even if he makes a draw some bad
situation for the very important
situation uh today's game is not a plus
for his psychological mindset definitely
not a plus a draw would be okay I think
it would be neutral but the way the draw
is about to happen if it will happen uh
it's just not uh yeah not not positive
for dink another basically another
missed opportunity and a very upsetting
one so not too optimistic for ding
overall
like emotional rollercoaster from for
ding starting from day one of the world
championship match even though that
ended in a draw game we saw him in the
press conference and just what he was
struggling with and we've got a question
from Chad Anish from Hampton and he's
asking what does they need to do to get
over that mental barrier he seems to
have accumulated because I think that
really is what this is coming down to
well this match is coming down to as a
player with his strength I mean dingler
and yeah
just the world's very best players but
there does seem to be this presence that
Jan napomnishi has on the board this
presence that he has in the playing
Arena and it just seems to go bigger and
bigger by the day while ding is really
struggling so
what do you think with your experience
what is it that thing needs to do to
overcome this psychological aspect of
the match
yeah I think it's really hard I'm myself
not able to do so as you can see in my
many of my tournaments um also I've had
many good tournaments but also many uh
many whenever I performed under my level
and once things go wrong it's really
really hard to study the ship and
there's only
um you know there's a limit to what you
can do I think the point is that you're
supposed to try and not let the previous
games impact you so try to show up to
the game as if it's around one
but that's easier said than done because
you carry the weight of the entire
competition
that you have already played and it's uh
yeah it's it's you know it's a recipe
but it's just really hard to follow
you gotta try to put it all behind you
and you gotta stick to the process to
just take doing what you're doing and
one thing it has to be just you know
just preparing playing and calculating
and making making a decision it's what
he what's how he always played and how
he should play and then everything
should work but yeah it's easier said
than done of course you know you have to
do it but somehow it's just not the same
you feel a little bit more pissed you
you try to learn lessons from your
previous games which is also like that
is by the way such an awful thing that
everybody is doing
but it's also I noticed in my own Games
you start drawing conclusions from the
games you played I mean you've already
played you know ding is um born in I
think 1990 three I believe is a 92
actually he is a play chess for um
decades by now and learning from one
defeat now I mean this is ridiculous
he's learned from so many games already
and he's of course yes he played this
unfortunate game last time and now he's
trying to speed up which is also what I
do as well in tournaments like that but
um yeah this is ridiculous because then
you start speeding up in the wrong
moments and it only backfires so yeah
these are all the stuff that I mean it's
it's not that um I can easily call it
out because I know I do it as well but
I'm not really able to not do it you
know what I mean these are like um I I
can sort of tell you all how it happens
how it all goes wrong but if I knew how
um to do it right
uh I would probably be sitting there uh
myself so it's not not so easy and you
see even the greatest players
they're still not immune to this I saw
once Magnus Carlson you know devastated
in Norway chess when he scored the minus
a score one time
um he was just a broken man you know
world champion dominating chess for so
many years he was sitting there uh
complaining about his confidence and I
was looking at him thinking what's wrong
with you man you just had you just lost
the game or two you know you're the best
player of all time probably he was like
genuinely heartbroken and it uh and it
just showed me that you know it doesn't
matter who you are and what you what you
have accomplished when you're down yeah
you're just
you need help
yeah yeah and I guess these are the
moments that you really need your
support system around you as well you
need the people around you to
somehow get you out of it to say those
right things as you mentioned and
there's such a small there's a blurred
line between what's the right thing to
say and not and it's such a difficult
moment but this is part of being at the
world's biggest stage as well right it
is part of being the world's best it
sort of seems to come with the territory
the pressure of it we can only imagine
it I can only imagine what it must be
like is this even hard to imagine really
what it must be like uh and it's of
course we're seeing the effects that it
has the one thing that I want to ask you
about a niche while nepo still has a
think about this position and it's been
something that has been sort of staring
at us from day one of this world
championship match especially during the
press conferences ding has been
extremely candid he's been very
emotional he's been uh very open about
how he's feeling
and yes that's heartwarming to see as a
player as a viewer as a chess fan
but it also can come across as a
weakness it can also be something that
can at least for your opponent be seen
as something that can be sometimes can
be used against you
do you think that Ding is giving too
much of himself away during the press
conferences and do you think that it's
something that you can just say that you
don't want to answer a certain question
or is it how do you how do you handle
this situation because
for me I have never seen in a world
championship match players opening up
about their feelings their mindset as
much as ding has
yeah I I guess he is trying to stay true
to himself which is uh very sensible and
I think it all it would all be fine
um it would all be fine if uh he he
would be able to uh during the games to
just show his best self and play the
games unaffected and then he can be
honest and um
I mean I don't think the press
conference is a problem I think the fact
that he didn't take the Rook is the
problem let me put it this way
I mean if you take the Rook it's all
fine
um but it's yeah it's I mean it's of
course understandable I can totally
describe the thinking process
um and why he didn't take the Rook he of
course briefly calculated it very
briefly and he thought let's not waste
the time because I will need the time oh
yeah by the way
um plays an interesting
move I was also thinking about the
screen to six a lot because you already
saw this idea we saw this idea before
going for this end game even with the a
Pawn on the board and I was really
curious after trade I was actually the
whole time we were talking I was
um calculating the queen D6 really
significant before end game and it's a
fascinating one I was thinking about
that because I I'll try to um
activate my king but maybe I'll not be
able to and then I'll just lose against
the g-pawn so uh yeah this is
interesting approach by Yan and I like
this because I think the same game only
only black can win that one I think
black is actually pretty safe there
yeah that's an interesting idea but
you're down a pawn but you're saying if
anyone has a chance it's black because
the g-pawn just seems like such a strong
passer in this position Robert that
you're mentioning would you agree in
this that despite white it has an extra
Pawn it's black who can be pushing here
well the problem for white is is it much
of an extra Pawn we each have one
unopposed pass Pawn the g-pawn for black
the a pawn for white but the difficulty
is you would love to adjust this Pawn
over and then white would be completely
winning so I feel like this is the type
of position that you know if you're
young to Palm should you just bring your
king up try to Usher the pawn but then
you have to be worried if somehow you
allowed the king into B5 and C5 is
targeted that would also be a bit of an
issue so maybe it's not that clear-cut
in this kind of position I see the eval
bar saying zeros it said that throughout
the game even in very difficult
situations but I don't think I really
want this uh position from either side
it just would make me a little nervous I
would take black Robert any day because
after King A4 I have Rook B6
I'm not sure it's so uh so easy and I
was thinking about that so what I was
trying to calculate is if I'm in time to
get my king to A8 and pawn to A7 so
let's say uh yeah I think has to trade
Queens he does so let's say King B3 I
got G5 King A4 I go Rook B6
what do you play
I was wondering if I should release my
Rook or not but uh I wasn't sure
yeah let's say you played yeah let's say
King a F5 would be one let's say
okay you want to go active no I don't
know yeah I don't know where but let's
say P1 was most natural to me and let's
say king of five okay eight G4
uh G3 yes Rook G8
kicking F4 A5 King F3
King A7 G2 A7 is what I was calculating
King F2 King A8
uh oh sorry I can give checks with Rook
also but let's take it uh G1 Rook G1
King G1 A7 this is the position I was
thinking about and this is a draw
this is like a study you just created a
study on the board Denise yeah I think
ding is going for it I think it should
just draw probably yeah no but I that
what I want to say is that it looks
dangerous for white because black of
course was never risking throughout the
entire line but I guess it's just uh
it's just a forced draw because I I
don't see how white can uh go wrong here
it's just all forced moves because if
you play A4
if you get a 5 king A4 you're happy but
you should be wearing it after like Rook
A6 you're not stuck you know forever
because imagine I have Roku knife Rook
on A5 let's say against the King on B3
and uh you can do nothing you cannot
touch me with white so you you have to
defend
um you have to defend against the Jeep
on alone so yeah this came to A4 and
then King to A5 and then going all the
way down and using this still made idea
is probably the way to draw here for
fighting
and if this was to end in a draw in this
line that you're saying yesting had his
chances but it's not an app an absolute
disaster for the match right we had this
smarter chess prediction earlier on
which did say that it would I don't
remember what the exact number was but
it was 80 and higher if this game ends
in the draw as Yan yes as Yan being a
favorite to win the match but ding still
has some whites coming up and it's still
just a one game lead and we've seen so
many decisive games that it's still a
match wide open Robert yeah but the
problem is right so dingley ran has
proven he can get in in advantage of the
black pieces he did that in game seven
he played the French defense he was
executed well until he froze so for dink
he knows that he can do well with black
but for Jan it might be time to just
park the bus you just say I am I'll have
the white pieces I'll play something
calm if ding makes a draw so be it he
doesn't need to take risks at this point
in time yes dingler and will get the
white pieces again but the number of
games remaining is shrinking there
aren't that many games left in this
match dingley Wren is certainly capable
of winning at least one of them but I
think Jan as he did in the candidates he
knows when he has the lead he could
sometimes just sail to the finish line
and not take any unnecessary risks
yeah Jan is getting better
the better the situation the better
young gets and the worse the situation
the worse young gets and that I think
holds true within games and within
tournaments as well so if you notice the
better Young's position
like the faster and stronger he plays
and also his tournaments like they go
like once they go good they go even get
even better and the same in Reverse so
once he has a bad position it usually
escalates very fast as well in the other
direction and also when the tournaments
go bad like the ultimate
the ultimate demonstration of like Jan's
worst event I've ever seen was a speech
championship match against Maxima
shilagraph not too long ago the previous
one and that match was really
spectacular at some point Jan uh started
to to get tilted and the games they were
just like he just couldn't play at all
he didn't want to play at all and he
just threw all the games and um at some
point he almost started losing them on
purpose so
um also because he didn't like the fact
that he has to keep playing the match
after that he was already lost pretty
much so yeah he really hates being in a
bad situation but when he is doing well
uh he is really excelling like we saw
the candidates tournaments remember how
he just crush the field and every wind
made him stronger and he dominated a
field where each player is you know is a
very formidable player like ding Fabi
alireza you don't report do these
players you don't really dominate them
usually but he just dominated the entire
event so Jan is really uh looking good
and now that he smells blood you know he
smells the victory in this in this
competition in this match uh I think the
chances are high that he will start
playing better and better and then he
has more and more psychological uh
traumas you know uh to shake off there
was that game where he froze there was
now there's now this game where he
didn't take
um the win
um to this fake perpetual
so all these you know they accumulate
all the negative feelings negative
thoughts and I think it's really hard to
come back from that but you know
um ding is a special uh special player
and he's capable of course of anything
the thing is like the opposite of that
in that way we've seen him often start
slow have these slow starts at
tournaments at big events and then he
really seems to find his rhythm and
cover up and finish right at the top in
the second half are often going late
into the event so uh two very different
players world number two world number
three what we've spoken so much about
this on the broadcast that they're
playing strength is so similar but
they're playing styles are so apart from
each other and that's what this world
championship it is truly a clash between
two uh of the world's best players in
each and every way their personalities
their personas on the board their
approaches to the match uh it's been a
very fascinating one to watch and we see
the end game it's developing the way you
said King to F6 ding now thinking about
how to proceed in this position he has
this extra a pawn with the black Street
Pawn is marching down the board you
pointed out that line which is a study
like Finnish at the very end is there
any other idea any other plan in this
position in this Rook Pawn ending which
perhaps gives ding gives ding a little
bit more hope to try for something here
I just don't think he has anything I
mean he can bring his Rook activated
that way and try to go after the C5 Pawn
but the g-pawn runs fast and something
you just said I think about the Clash of
styles I wanted to touch on that a
little bit because uh dingley red he won
a hundred classical games without a
defeat if Yonder Palm she did like a
quarter of that I think we'd be pretty
shocked because he's a very combative
player he's super duper strong don't get
me wrong but he's more likely to win a
bunch of games and then maybe lose a
couple whereas dingley Rand I mean just
the guy is really hard to beat when he's
on his best form and he did in fact play
rookie he wants the activity rather than
slatting his King up the a file uh but I
think that Jan has become a more settled
down player and it's been to his benefit
it's allowed him to win consecutive
candidates tournaments I think in the
past he used to take more risks he was a
bit impatient he would kind of just uh
you know play often too quickly in
critical moments but I think we have
seen a new Yonder pump she at least in
the last candidates and even the 2021
World Championship but dingley rent has
taken him out of his element I mean this
has not been and there's a draw greeted
Fair result but what a match we have
yeah handshakes and this one ends in a
draw well it looked like that was the
most uh the outcome that you're
expecting but so quickly while the
players decide to call it a day we see
both of them analyzing uh and Robert
just what you mentioned about their
Styles but just to follow up on that
when you're trailing the world
championship match by a point the
opponent that you want in front of you
is a player like janapamnushy because
his style is so exciting you know that
he will perhaps just stylistically
choose more interesting options
combative options that's going to give
everybody a chance to try for a win like
you said you'll have more decisive games
when Yan is playing so for ding it's
definitely something a big missed
opportunity but not an absolute disaster
the game does end in a draw he did have
his big moments to take this one Anish
how would you sum up this finish and
this abrupt handshakes that we just saw
right now
yeah no I just realized well dig by
rookie ate that there are a lot of
different ways to probably make this
draw you could also indeed start giving
checks to the king and then pick up the
C5 Pawn in a favorable version and then
eventually return The Rook for the
g-pawn and promote your own uh so there
are all sorts of different ways to to
make a draw and uh yeah the players just
decided to not waste each other's time
it's been a very eventful game very
eventful game and uh at this point it's
it's basically the Intrigue has died out
and I like ding's body language now in
the post game analysis he um he's quite
interested uh discussing the game
um talking about all sorts of different
things as well so but you know the
problem for ding is I think he doesn't
realize yet what kind of opportunities
he missed I think he's feeling quite
fine now but once he will see what he
missed he's not gonna feel this fine any
longer well they're pointing to various
parts of the board and my big question
is after spoiling what was a promising
and winning position some players would
be so upset they would just storm out of
there uh and if you said you like his
body language he's just analyzing the
game do you think he needs to just get
back to the basics of Chess just like
loving it having fun rather than feeling
the pressure and is that why he's
sitting there and talking it through
yeah he's loving and I I think he's
basically uh he just doesn't didn't
realize the opportunities he missed
which is understandable he missed this
move so he hasn't seen them yet and Jan
also hasn't told him about it yet
probably so he's just thinking okay I
had some chances probably but okay was
uh at some point I was already worried
I'll be I'll maybe lose so then okay
draw draw whatever he thinks it was
maybe interesting game maybe was not so
bad but when he will see that he missed
you know a win that's when he will
um he'll probably have a moment of a
devastation
of course he will try to come back from
that but I think right now he's feeling
fine but I think the reason he's feeling
fine is that because he just he just
didn't know he doesn't know he doesn't
know what he missed yet that happens I
mean I also have it very often I played
the game I think okay it was an
interesting game uh all fine and I feel
fine then I'll come back and I see oh my
God you know I had such I had a direct
win and then you feel bad and
um yeah right now he's feeling fine
because I think he didn't have the time
to think about all the possibilities
that he had and he didn't have time to
realize that there was a win because we
saw the win of course we were there with
the computers and we already know it but
he didn't and Janos probably didn't tell
him Ruby and also didn't see it so they
discussed something you know some
options this that but yeah I don't think
that he's aware of of exactly how big an
opportunity this was
yeah you say that he doesn't realize it
but Anisha I had the feeling that right
after the game he did look a little a
little
unhappy with the result a little
dejected about how it had gone maybe not
realizing the exact opportunity but
there's little doubt that he felt it
that he knew that this was his big game
this was his big chance to come back
into the match to equalize the score uh
and what a game he played right from the
very start starting with the opening
creating chances Tingler and could have
equalized the match but yeah and I
promise he's such a sneaky player uh and
he just knows how to keep things under
control very resourceful take it away
Anish and show us the big moments
yes uh I will uh indeed show that so E3
and A3 this idea of Fabiana carvana was
employed and uh the idea of Rook A2
followed by E4 and this bishop sacrifice
it seems that many players were familiar
with it also Jana punishi I think what
we expect is that Janice probably mixed
something up because he probably wanted
to take on default first but after G6
Dean got this opportunity of going E5
and D5 which is not possible had the
pawns been traded because position would
be too open but now with the position
more close this is uh this was an
interesting way of playing for for Ding
and Yan had lots of interesting
possibilities I think um if you click
through the game
all the options on each move for both
both sides but the crucial point was
around here Jan had different options he
could take here he could also sacrifice
a piece which was interesting the way he
played Knight H4 was also playable here
Rook h8 uh was the best of the current
computer but I think still under a lot
of pressure uh he would be but after
yeah Bishop before ding found it
brilliant idea of the two uh the screen
G5 Queen E5 F6 Queen of the H2 rook h8
and this
sacrifice let me just show it because it
was extremely beautiful this idea that
Ding has found which uh should have
yielded him a win but um unfortunately
Yan resisted very well unfortunately for
ding it's here this would be a win a
young resisted well here he tried to
catch it and now dink had a couple of uh
Solutions D7 was possible also taking
and Rook D3 was very clear-cut a
difficult move swinging across to the H
file but a very clean one I think here
um I can't imagine Jan putting up a
resistance
although he would of course have tried
but uh after what ding has played Janos
back in the game until this remarkable
moment where Jan Bluffton with Queen H4
hoping that after queen d8 queen E4
there will be Perpetual but there wasn't
one because uh White could uh run away
and the Run Stars here
you just run forward and hear queen of
one king D2 is uh relatively easy but
after Queen D1 you have to play King to
E4 not Rook to the two and uh in down
this line white is uh indeed winning
I think the line went like this
and queen of six uh Queen and yeah black
just doesn't have Perpetual here a few
more checks but at the end of the day
here or here uh the king just walks away
so a long line but it's a pretty forced
one but somehow didn't trusted uh Yan
and then the game continued and it was
never easy any longer and here yes the
decisive mistake but I think he could
still have a winning position had he
gone for Bishop C6 kept the Deep on this
counter play is there but it's not as
scary as it looks instead he allowed
this Knight F2 sack and this position
was already very difficult for him if
anyone it was black who was in the
driver's seat with uh Jan regaining this
deep one and the problem is this bishop
so miserable and uh even in this
position you could see in the end that
white spawns are useless for now and
this bishop is so miserable it just
sacrificed itself for the pawn for two
pawns because on G2 it's staring into
these pawns and eventually black would
bring the king to the center push all
the spawns down the board and then
finally he would need to only protect
this opponent push F4 F3
um yeah and and just uh finish it off so
the bishop was miserable and um yeah
everything had to make a draw a few
really decisive moments there so
a missed win by by ding on multiple
occasions
definitely something he'll be kicking
himself for today because a huge huge
opportunity missed uh given also the
score and the match situation it was
just so important today to come back and
um yeah big disappointment for uh for
dignity for sure
you see Robert in Astana they are
getting ready for the press conference
has taken his place he will be joined by
Dean Lauren soon it was such a thrilling
game so many chances and also
resourceful play by yandere at the end
especially that night sacrifice and it's
also painful right when you come with
this amazing opening preparation and it
works to Perfection it wasn't an opening
that we were expecting this e383 idea
and you seem it seems like you've done
everything right you get so close to
converting that into a full point Robert
and then it just slips from your hand
and that can be really frustrating to
get over knowing that you start with
black the next day
yeah he's gonna have to uh find it
within himself to combat Jana palmchi
tomorrow when Giannis had the white
pieces he's been scoring dubs so for
dingley Ren after a very heartbreaking
around here uh his press conference not
going to be particularly fun for many
different reasons right now uh so I
think that uh for dingley Wren it's just
not going to be pleasant to rest this
evening I don't know how he's going to
sleep it's gonna be a challenging night
ahead because this game did not go the
way it should have based on how he
started it
ding
so much about his opening approach and
talk about how what his preparation
entailed for the day and I still
as a player I just still feel that thing
often is so candid about his expressions
and that's It's just sometimes he gives
away a little too much it's it's amazing
to watch it but at this stage at the
world championship we've seen Jana
promise the way he handles questions and
just how uh professionally he keeps his
answers he's never emotional he's always
almost seeming dismissive he's got this
sense of confidence about him and I feel
like that's an important part that thing
needs to find in himself as well going
forward you see we're almost ready uh
Anish big opportunity missed by ding to
equalize the match he starts with the
black pieces what do you think is the
positive takeaway for ding in this one
foreign
I have to think really hard about what
the positive takeaway would be
um
I mean at some point he was probably
already on the worst side of uh of
things so it could have gotten even
worse especially as he was there in time
trouble here thinking about the
possibilities all looking pretty bad and
couldn't be 627 was the opportunity
after Roger two Robert pointed out the
23.6 option where the end game would be
even more dangerous than it happened in
the game so it could have gone even
worse that's the positive the other
positive is that the score is only one
down so he just needs one more win I
mean the equal score at the end would be
fine that break is more than welcome at
this point so it's all limited and he
could also definitely see that he keeps
getting chances
a young keeps giving him chances I
think's opening uh experiments they keep
giving giving him decent positions where
he gets opportunities so uh if he
manages to play well the upcoming games
I think it's sort of Still In His Hands
although yeah in chess when you are one
point down and in a match like that you
know that you know in just the position
that you start with is always equal so
it doesn't quite feel like it's in your
own hands anymore so um no not not real
for ding but okay it's early to it's
early to say and even the smartest
predictions that we had which said that
ding's chances are 86 um are 86 that Jan
wins after this um of this draw I think
still okay you take those 14
um
not so bad you know one more than one
intent to become a world champion could
be worse could be worse let me just go
for it
yeah no it certainly could be worse but
the press conference is delayed a bit
and while we wait for dingley Ren to
find his chair we just do want to say
we've seen everyone talk about in chat
we've seen it on social media uh the
conversation about preparation whether
that was dings that was released he will
answer those questions in the press
conference uh but I think as he's
walking up now just the fact that he has
to answer them will not be fun in
addition to spoiling the game so daily
run about to sit down and I hope this
interview gets underway in the near
future
yeah we see that a ding is joining the
press conference in Astana so we're
gonna head over to the players and hear
their reactions on this thrilling game
it
hello everyone welcome at the press
conference of round eight at feeder
World Chess Championship the game has
ended in a draw and the current score is
four and a half two three and a half in
favor of Jana pomonishi I'm starting
with the questions and then the floor
will go to a press my first question to
Yan
if you can please take us through the
most critical moments of the game today
yes so
other than the line that occurred in the
game is
I guess one of the very very topical
lines nowadays nimso
uh so as as artificial as this rookie 2
looks it's uh somehow I think it's top
engine choice in certain positions
uh sir it was more or less
aware of all this
uh please sacrifice at least I knew that
after 26 black is fine
but E5 I would say was sort of surprise
for me so
I thought like
well I was choosing between Queen F4 and
capturing on E5 so I went for the
principal line as it seemed and then it
was like pretty much forced I guess yeah
like this uh Knight E4 Queen d8 and
something
and then I don't know why but I felt
like other ambitious and uh I think I
made like some Alpha moves which almost
cost me the game yeah so it was half a
point
so like it was
a simple choice I would say you had to
I guess after request free just to
capture only four capture on D6 with the
queen
uh Rogue to Queen C7 takes only five
takes only five and this should never be
worse like okay these three pawns and
all right like I just put put my phone
on each forehand okay
uh I guess it's never worse but also I
could go principle but I completely
forgot yeah like playing rookie shade
also with smart but I just completely
completely forgot about the move Ruby
too
I think black is lost but uh yeah I was
I was very lucky
and then I guess yeah I was very lucky
to to Bluff uh with this Greenwich from
off I think in fact white can capture it
and then I saw these okay was I mean uh
maybe after Queen f80 position is bad
but at least it's not it's not it's not
lost by force but indeed after King D1
Queen G5 I mean practically I have some
very nice chances to escape
and uh well I guess it was a lot of the
mess a lot of mess in
later in the game yeah but
yeah I guess
yeah this
this
495 maneuver link instead of some normal
position just just nearly losing yeah at
least
I shouldn't go to to my credit
um right yeah you mentioned about the
screen age for a new called it the bluff
so you surely knew that it was just lost
position if ding would capture The Rook
on d8 well when I played it I thought
it's like I'm very smart but then I
found out that uh the king Escapes in
some tricky way I like
at least like Queen E4 or kitsu queen B1
King D2 Queen be talking D3 Queen B1
Rook C2 and here Queen D1 I thought it's
a draw but uh no it's king D4 here Queen
City Bishop D3 uh which was very hard to
spot from distance and here yeah maybe I
can go still for something like 90 free
check but
yeah I guess it's I guess it's over
uh yeah so yeah that was very lucky
moment
very much I think I would like to ask
the question about this moment too when
Jan played Queen to H4 obviously we're
considered to take the Rook on d8 but
then in the end you decided not to can
you please tell us what was your the
reason why you decided so
well I briefly checked the line but I
stopped
I think at uh maybe Queen U1 queen queen
B1 Rook C2 I I didn't calculate any
further
so I just stopped there maybe because my
timer knows so much
considering yesterday's lost so I want
to play quickly in time travel
but that's
but today it's another story
uh right so you
you mean that the time was a factor
today in this game that you did not
capture for instance at this moment to
work yeah I guess so
uh right and to talk about the time
um
have you have you got some some advice
from your team how to deal with the time
situation because today there was a
moment when you made the move like last
seconds
or perhaps do you think maybe this
happens that you have less time on the
clock because of the lack of practicing
or TV tournaments
of course the best way is to play and
quickly and good as possible but
the the position after the opening is
very very unclear and there are many so
many options for me so I have to figure
out which was the best way to continue
and it cost me a lot of time
and I think the time I spent during the
first half the game was needed because I
prayed some good good moves or maybe not
the best about time at least I was not
worse
yes just because I didn't cover the
advantage when I have the chance
to uh before before we captured the
bishop on G5 have you considered also C
takes uh D4 move
uh actually I think both moves are in
the files but in my lines but uh I mean
I just thought that any uh any you know
anymore should be good but I thought
it's pretty much forced
so
when I when I come to my room okay I'll
check if I if I miss something I mean
mix it up but I guess this is uh
uh just another weird Engine line
yeah so it's
it's fun to analyze yeah but it's it
turned out to be not so fun to play
[Music]
about the opening and also about this
Rook to A2 idea uh were you were you
happy during the game of your opening
Choice today and if you can uh
just take us through the moment you
played Rook 282 what is the idea behind
this move locator
oh this idea I consider this as some
kind of cannonball in my opening
preparation because it's where it can be
very powerful and it's all very very
long preparation
I'll be long like a very deep idea
behind this
so yeah today
just
uh
we are very pity yes it could be a very
good game but it doesn't happen
okay thank you for answering the
questions now it's time for the for the
Press please Mike go ahead
Mike with chess.com my question is for
Grand Master ding Loren
I suspect you might know this is coming
some people online have found games
played on leeches that match very
closely with some games played here
what is your reaction to this rumor
well I don't know which
refer
any training games played online that
you can remember that resemble games
played here at the world championship
I don't know I don't know if
all right I'll go to Leon show but I
might come back later okay thank you
Mike learn to please
I have a question for each one for Ian
why did you choose to accept such a
sharp variation when you had let's say
solid Alternatives in the opening and
for Leland
and how do you feel about missing
winning moves
yeah I guess I'll start
so thank you for the question uh I think
it's
I think it's very very principled line
this
uh e3a3 Nissan
once again it's pretty much on the radar
for a lot of players
so it's not really
I mean it's it might look sharp but as
long as you like have an idea what to do
you can you can navigate and I think I
um okay until I felt like other
ambitious for some reason I did it quite
nice
uh but yeah there there is a price of
obviously yes so one one in Anchorage
movement you like can can lose but uh
I guess uh
uh such as chess yeah thank you thank
you I think do would you like to repeat
the question maybe uh I remember yeah of
course Mr so much wins at least two wins
or maybe even more
it feels very bad also very very tired
after the long game but still there are
six games I have one three white pieces
so anything can happen thank you thank
you very much next question please
um
we would like to Heritage so uh when he
played will they played with the Rook
the whites uh did you feel the one at
the right the whites were playing
aggressively and uh taking into account
you know the moves you
uh the movie The Moves you made just uh
were you curious just to try out your
opponent's uh uh your opponent's stance
your opponent's position
um
previously
hmm
okay
um when I made this Rook uh a two move I
uh you know uh I knew uh what I was
doing and uh you know I'm sure it was
many other people knew uh were aware of
this we're aware of this move uh you
know I I know this option looked and
does look interesting so uh after that
move uh E5 I uh just didn't know how it
would be responded to and of course the
game it's been a very complex a very
challenging game and it I wouldn't be
surprised if it had changed if it had
ended otherwise so so it was lucky that
it changed it ended like this
thank you very much
my clan with chess.com uh Grand Master
dingler and I have to ask one follow-up
today is the only day there was a delay
in the press conference I believe you
met with your team after the game
can you please
let us know why you met with your team
before coming to the press conference
we'll analyzed this
game a little bit
and my second show me there's this very
simple way to win we Rook D3 instead of
D7
so I'll regret it
so the the entire meeting was about
actual chess moves is that right
yeah thank you
thank you very much do we have more
questions from from price
you have one more okay I would like to
ask Grandmaster young to promise you a
question on the broadcast Anish giri
said that you are dominating ding
psychologically do you agree with that
I think Anish knows it better yeah I
have no idea what to say
thanks
Q
uh for the
the questions from Twitter so Jesse will
take over from here from please Jesse hi
Jesse February here my first question
was for ding did you take any
inspiration from Fabiano caruana this
game
foreign
yeah I know it will heal opening style
to play something very sharp and
and yeah to attack
with with
at any cost yeah sometimes it's worth
it's kind of preparation that he
uh
his kinds of preparation yeah but today
it's
this idea was not his his idea
all right thank you my next question for
Napa from agat matar
was Queen H4 a bluff what was going
through your mind at that point
um actually Queen H4 I thought it's just
a brilliant way to save the game
but when I I mean spent another minute
calculating uh Alice I mean okay maybe
it's good it was too late but maybe
uh anyway it has been played I I noticed
that in some critical lines King escapes
from the Perpetual check
uh but it worked like a charm but uh
yeah
uh but I guess
uh I guess practically it turned out to
be a great chance but yeah because queen
of age and queen E7
um perhaps I can I can try to hold this
but I think the position is quite quite
ugly
next question Jesse uh
giggly when Jan said made a comment
about Queen H4 do you want to add
something at that point
or when returning to a bullet I saw
crunch full and I just
briefly calculates the line after print
DNA time became very disappointed
because I missed his idea to check on e4
and B1
so I'm
I didn't calculate properly and try to
play for a win
which was not so good but I can do one
thank you please next question Jessica
all right this one's from chess Society
for ding how often do you disagree with
robort when he suggests a line or
opening
you know many times
all right thank you and the last one is
from chess best
why do you spend a lot of time in the
opening when you're the one who chooses
the variation or line often
because
E5 here I have some on on Earth
for example Rook D2 or even Queen G4
also on D5 I have adoption by 94 also on
D6 I have also have 94 so there are
always many options to to choose between
so that's why I take many a lot of time
on each move
to decided which was a better
thank you thank you very much do we have
more questions from uh from press this
can be the last question
um if there is no more questions I will
go with my last question
um we're very much curious as the this
game this particular game was indeed
very tough what do you usually do right
after the time control how how you are
staying focused and also how do you
release the stress a little bit let's go
yarn with you first
well uh I'm trying to take a deep breath
here and see uh you know maybe relate
what happens
in in time scramble so it was wasn't a
real time to scramble today but the
pressure was like was real and I guess
this might have to move was missed
uh by uh by my opponent but at some
point I was like
even like
very optimistic about my position yeah
after I found this uh
uh Knight F2
uh but then yeah by the way it was like
uh I I wouldn't call this latia but it
was a very nice Hawaii that after Queen
takes B6 queen queen takes it uh Queen
takes D7 doesn't work because of Rook G2
and
there is this streak with Bishop H5
going to opponent game
yeah but uh
yeah there was another moment to uh when
you played move E5 there was also a
possibility to sacrifice the FPS with
Knight to D4 have you considered that
one
yeah I checked it but I somehow I didn't
feel it's
it's too necessary uh but I guess it was
a problem that Queen E5 comes with with
the check now
or it's or it's not important
ah yeah good to know
all right
all right my question uh what do you
usually do right after the time control
um how you are still
staying focused on the game and also
trying to release your stress a little
bit
they ate a lot of food to
maintain to maintain my body shape
and
yeah yeah that's what I did after
I reached the 40s movie
right um there was a there was a
question in in public what players have
in the Players Lounge what kind of
snacks what is your favorite in this uh
in this tournament what you're usually
getting
banana and chocolate
all right
makes sense all right I don't have more
questions I say there's no more
questions in the press as well so we can
conclude today the round nine will start
tomorrow at 3 P.M so thank you very much
foreign
[Applause]
was a peaceful one but the game was
anything but so many chances there and
we could see in the press conference uh
visibly disappointed thing with the way
things have turned out and that means
game 8 comes to an end with janapamner
she is still leading by a one point
margin as the second half of the world
championship continues it could have
gone either way and tingling was so
close to equalizing this match uh Anish
so many variations and critical moments
were discussed during the press
conferences many of them we had looked
at during our analysis was there a line
or a moment that surprised you about the
reaction
I think that line he mentioned it I
checked afterwards it involved the
miscalculation as well so I think
um well nothing particularly I was good
too interested to hear that Jan actually
found
um that Perpetual wasn't working because
I would think that he would you know he
might skip but of course if you think
you know keep thinking during opponent's
move you you might because as we saw if
you just keep thinking about the line at
some point you might figure out that uh
actually surprisingly you are winning
there with white on or losing asiano's
black but uh no of course
um The Players you know they have a lot
of thoughts that we we are having here
also of course we are assisted with a
computer sometimes sometimes they have
other thoughts sometimes we have other
thoughts and that's what makes just
beautiful everybody has their own
thoughts about the game
yeah and though especially that moment
there were so many moments actually
where ding had this chance to convert
this game into a full point uh with that
Queen H4 where the Perpetual is not
really there seemed like the most direct
one where you simply pick up the
material call out the bluff and uh
janapamnushi himself mentioned that he
played the move and immediately realized
when he went back into the rest area
that in fact it wasn't a Perpetual so we
saw ding fall for it now Robert
that Miss it's a really big one at this
stage how do you see this being weighted
iron how does one get over it because it
really was a clear path to victory for
Deng in game eight
I was glad to see ding left at some
points during the press conference
because at first he looked devastated
and he should be he let an advantage a
winning Advantage slip out of his grasp
he should have won the game I think if
this were not the world championship he
would have won the game and I especially
think if game seven hadn't just occurred
then he would have won even in the world
championship but it's good to see him
smile as good as him analyzed with yawn
after the game he is going to be you
know trying to figure out how to answer
the question of what do I do with the
black pieces against the on the palm
machine but I think what we saw from
dingly Ren was a very determined player
someone willing to play an offbeat
opening that hasn't really been tried
that much someone who knew that there
were a variety of ways to move forward
but was trying to calculate and conserve
time for the rest of the game so I do
think that there are some good takeaways
despite the fact that he really did
botch what should have been a win to
even up the score uh he's going to be
disappointed he's going to have to get
over the initial hurt but he's still in
this match a single win in the next
bunch of games we'll get him back to a
tie
the smallest of margins as a yarn goes
into a game nine and thing himself
mentioned right that everything worked
out well he was happy with the opening
he was happy with the position that he
got out of the middle game that he just
was not able to convert it but otherwise
quite a brilliantly played a game there
by dingler and many positive takeaways
but yes he does Trail the match now for
me in during the press conference one of
the dramatic moments were Mike's
questions when he bought up the
preparation and the rumored leak of
preparation it reminded me of what we
saw in the 2018 World Championship match
with fabi's video leak that happened I
wanna I wanna start by Anish on this one
that what do you make out of this whole
episode and how distracting can this be
for team ding
yeah I had done to study that in great
detail I also heard of some sort of
potential leak I think nowadays
especially you know often you you play
with cards on the table you know
um Jan was aware of today's line Dean
was aware and it's just about choosing
the right thing so I think the damage
nowadays of um
having your prep leaked is relatively
limited I also suspect it's so deep into
the match we've already seen most of
ding's preparation
I saw some tweets mentioning some H3
move for H3 we already seen so you can
lick that as much as you want and I I
wonder if at this point in the match so
far and so deep with ding showing
already so many different game plans if
ding actually had prepared more before
the match
um I guess he mapped out certain things
but you're not going to work out I doubt
you're gonna work out like seven uh
seven ideas for why
that you would do that
um so I don't know how much damage it is
even if it's something uh something real
leaked but it could also be a certain
coincidence I haven't studied the
details to be honest I'll have to have
to see and and make my judgments on that
but I was in any case good to see ding
not to disturb today I think
uh he gave very good replies you know he
pushed back on uh on all the people that
tried to bully him today in the press
conference he pushed back on uh on all
the speculations he um uh commonly
replied so we know what he missed why he
missed how he feels and he said you know
six games to go and I I like the mindset
and indeed you know um one thing I
recognized because I was thinking about
how devastated he is and all that uh one
thing I recognized is that when you
actually are in the middle of a
competition and you are still in the
running as long as you got the chance
you still have that fighting mindset and
I think ding preserves that he knows
that okay things not going well but most
important things is that he is still in
it you know if you if the tournament is
over okay you can cry it's all good you
can cry you can but as long as you're
still in uh in it as long as you still
have a shot and he has quite a shot with
many white games left as he points out I
think his mindset is perfect tomorrow
will be a tough game because he's
playing with the black pieces he's got a
little bit of a one E4 issue Jan's
already ready for a marshall since the
previous game because ding has dodged it
with the French Jan will be ready for
the French as well so ding has to come
up with the game plan and he has not
much time so tomorrow will be a tough
one uh and well um
if he survives that then that is there
is still a good good shot in their
remaining games
and the word you just use survive I
think is very important because we heard
from ding's own words that he says I
have a few more games with the white
pieces remaining he doesn't seem to want
to take risks with black uh just based
on his language uh what he said in the
presser so I think that uh for dingley
Ren it's the match is not over he still
has plenty of opportunity left and about
the potential leak we don't know if uh
we've been competing this whole time we
have not been able to confirm anything
uh but I will say that I think what
Anish said Rings true that most of the
surprises we've seen they might have
already been played and you know you can
dig up H3 games he's not going to try
that again he lost that game it wasn't
very impressive opening to boot so I
think that unless there was some crazy
sacrificial variation that was you know
the game that was sealed if you need to
win play this I just think that uh it's
just one of those conversations that
will be a talking point it will be
uncomfortable for team ding but they
will have to do their work because
sometimes your opponents play openings
that you didn't expect like Carlson
against caruana playing the rosalimo
every single game they probably had to
work on the Fly too just to come up with
new ideas against the Sicilian so I
think team ding with Richard report
leading the way as the main trainer I
think they'll be okay but I think that
dingley Ren you know is good to see him
happier than I would have expected at
the press conference it was good to see
him smile it was good to see him analyze
and maybe he's just taking it one move
at a time and for his team's sake for
his sake hopefully they believe he can
bounce back
and I'm sure that's exactly what a ding
fans are also hoping for we've seen him
do that in this world championship match
twice he currently trails with the
smallest of Majors just a point and once
again the feeling is that when you're in
that situation and you're playing a
player like Yan with the style of you
know that the chances will come you know
that there will be positions where
anything can happen now that's exactly
what we as fans as well as commentators
uh as well chess lovers want to see the
action that's coming up dingler and will
get his chances to make a comeback in
this match
looks and is being an absolute beast on
the board a bit dingler and a brilliant
a brilliant game so far did not go his
way Robert how how important is it the
fact that he's playing a player with Yan
style let's say if we we talk about
these different chest Styles you know
there's a player players like Wesley for
example you're trailing Wesley you know
how difficult it will be you know that
he's going to shut down any
complications but when you're playing
against a player with such a dynamic
start you know that chances will and
that's definitely something for doing to
take solace from yeah although I do
think sometimes players get mislabeled
or we remember their early games I think
Hikaru is a player who they always say
he's this uh attacking player always
super aggressive most of his opening
repertoire is actually quite solid these
days so I think that sometimes we think
of how they were in their youth and
their up and coming stages Jana palmchi
I mean he always has been a player
willing to uh take risk to fight but if
we look at the last bunch of Candace
tournaments and the world championship
in 2021 he's actually stabilized his
repertoire a lot he was playing the
Petrov rather than sharp Sicilian so I
do think that Jan when he has the lead
he will try as best he can to be solid
when he's the white pieces he's not
going to be playing risky lines but we
saw that French game in game seven that
wasn't risky but dingley Ren was out
playing him so it's possible that Ding
will be able to score a victory with the
black pieces but I think at this stage
this late into the match Jana Palm she
he's not trying to take risks if he can
avoid it
well we are looking forward
s coming up in
The Equalizer match the finish line is
indeed inside this is our upcoming match
schedule we've got a game tomorrow game
nine that will be with Ian starting with
the white pieces ding will be playing
with black and in this match so far we
have seen ding a little shaky with the
black piece especially at the start of
the match with the kingspawn opening he
hasn't been really able to neutralize a
janza 1e4 with E5 we saw him employ the
French is that something that we expect
to be a one game opening what are the
opening expectations from ding with
black to try to neutralize the antimore
Anish
oh yeah tough call I think there is a
chance for a repeat of the French as
well there is a chance for the martial
though
you'd think that's the least likely
um I I guess the more likely is another
surprise
but anything is anything is possible at
this point
um yeah I think basically you know it's
it's the one or the other really and Jan
he's got to be ready for all for all
three scenarios and whatever it is doing
place
well Yang will try to not indeed to take
too much too many risks but sometimes
you know without even taking risks
things just spiral out of control and
when these two combative players uh you
know so tactically gifted and uh such
fighting mindset by both these players
things just spiral out of control uh
very often and uh who knows we might see
another another exciting game tomorrow
and I'm going to uh also you know look
forward to tomorrow because tomorrow I
can finally watch the commentary of my
favorite commentator uh Robert Hess and
Tanya sajidev but also Fabiana Carana
and I think um yeah that's that's going
to be a quite a team for me to follow
going to miss you so much
you have been so so incredible just
breaking down this action and calling
out the moves and just explaining this
chest that we're seeing which honestly
is at God level it's just another a
different level a different League of
moves that we're seeing and having you
around has been has been fantastic and
I'm just gonna ask you one time before
you leave us as a commentator as being
one of the very best players in the
world as a chess player what has this
tournament if you can just sum up what
this tournament has been so far
wow yeah I don't think there there is a
word in the English language that's uh
they can describe this kind of uh event
certainly not a word that I know
um no so it was a great show so far and
uh today we're so close uh to see you
know to see the predictable finally the
predictable one zero after so many one
zeros and yet you're once again
surprised uh always expect the
unexpected in this match so far and you
know I have a feeling
um the story is not over yet the the
plot is still not done there are going
to be a couple of twists left and so far
every game has been a Twist and Applause
and so I don't I don't see any reasons
why just because I stopped commentating
why suddenly the match will will slow
down or I think uh still a lot to to
uncover for example a likely scenario is
doing losing to tomorrow yet coming back
with two wins in the end I mean that
could also be something right so still
lots of lots of unexpected action
possible uh with enough against to go
still six games um
to be played that is that is plenty
plenty of Chess ahead
you while you're gone
well well you know I have to work a
little bit on my own chest as well as as
an experienced player slash commentator
I know at the moment you start feeling
that you are playing better than the
people uh that you watch this is when
you lose a touch of reality and this is
when uh you're you know this this is a
bad sign for you as a player as a player
you should always realize you know the
that's just as hard and so yeah I'll
I'll take a moment to prepare for my
upcoming events because you know when
I'm watching the events of this this big
I uh I always have a formal and uh it's
not even the foremost I think a little
different it's I'm not sure
it's it's even more than that I I really
feel motivated and inspired you know to
try and get all the way up there as well
and uh yeah for me I need I need to work
a lot um to achieve that so
unfortunately I'm not able to commentate
forever but it's been so much fun I wish
it had lasted a longer but again I'm
really looking forward to to follow uh
of course stay tuned for the tweets but
mainly uh you guys enjoy enjoy the
commentary five is such a smooth such a
smooth commentator he you know he has
possesses the knowledge of Chess and uh
all the uh qualities great player has
but he is able to say so much more with
so many less words something that I'm
really jealous of so I'm looking forward
to that
absolutely Anis and the Arabic big shoes
to fill but if anyone can do that it is
Fabiano caruana we are so excited to
have him join us for the remaining of
the world championship match he's your
good friend you must be really looking
forward to it as well
I'm also a little upset I joined for one
day and then she immediately says you're
not done you know and then he leaves so
I don't know if I have to send him a
playlist of Nicki Minaj I don't know how
I'm gonna you know restore this
friendship but Anish man way to Desert
me like that
okay Robert uh you know it's it's been
really a thrill I think I haven't been
commentating with you uh a lot before
ever and ever yeah yeah no and did you
know immediately there you'll probably
noticed yes that I was so impressed with
your today's performance I think the
highlights of there are many highlights
of the game but the highlight of the
game uh From commentator's perspective
was the movie H3 that you found I wasn't
uh insanely difficult and brilliant idea
and Dean also found that credit to him
but uh so did you and yeah no definitely
you know you're you're getting there
getting there I think with Fabiano by
your side you will uh at some point
reach the heights of Daniel noraditski I
think at some point
wow that was really so kind at first
that you've never I thought something
was wrong for a second because you're
being so complimentary but then I knew
that you were gonna stab me in the back
as soon as uh your compliment ended so I
appreciate it
nice definitely don't get relaxed
and Asia's been so much fun Robert today
what an incredible game we had and just
so thrilling to watch and just also the
way it ended with Nepal keeping things
under control we go into game nine
tomorrow it's been a fantastic day of
jazz I've had a blast covering it with
you Anish and with you Robert chat big
shout out to all of you thank you so
much for joining us it's been so much
fun we will be back with game nine
tomorrow for now this is a rewind of the
thrilling action that we had in game
eight see you tomorrow
Dean can win in round 8 after rest day
we might see a new player entirely well
no London as we were saying through C4
has been played me too
make noise such a nice move to make the
Rook will swing across the second rank
before developing any of the Bishops so
aesthetically pleasing that's pretty
much a new territory for Jan and I love
it look he can afford to think now it's
okay he has an hour he can do this I'm
getting a little bit worried for him I'm
getting bad vibes
wait wait wait he just took me he
panicked I told you I told you I didn't
like the position he thought he's
already lost thought he's already lost I
told you yeah
there it goes he gives up his Queen to
get a new one and the Monarch will reign
and unfortunately for Beyond the Palm
shady I mean this is just lost at this
point I'm being bison by the way
it's so easy to buy into it by the way
it is so easy to buy into that but he's
back in the game oh he bluffed him
you can find it you missed the wow it
doesn't go 94. and if Alvar shoots right
up it's again I think Lauren in the
driving seat can he play King B3 King A4
he is trying to force the Knight back to
F6 but it's a blundering
and that deserves the double exclamed
he's let young back into the game it
looks like things are not going his way
at all anymore no he's shaking his head
he has to make a move 10 seconds one
more move remains
look at him
so upset
Queen takes B6 this is losing on the
spot right after Queen the seven he can
breathe I can breathe because I got so
worried he made a move with four seconds
on the clock and somehow the evaluation
bar doesn't change the White's position
but dingley run has taken him out of his
element this has not been and there's a
draw agreed Fair result but what a match
we have
yeah handshakes and
the draw
[Music]
foreign